welcome to this full stack web
development course for beginners first
you'll learn how to use HTML CSS and
JavaScript and then you'll learn how to
use those skills to make a full stack
web app I'm Beau Carnes and I'll be
teaching part of this course and I'm
Tomi Toko and I'll also be teaching part
of this course I'll be teaching the
JavaScript section and the backend web
development section and I'll be teaching
the HTML CSS and front-ended web
development sections
details let me tell you more about some
of the concepts in this course first
let's talk about HTML CSS and JavaScript
every website on the internet uses HTML
and CSS most also use JavaScript
in a website HTML is the structure CSS
is the style and JavaScript is the
functionality here's a great interactive
diagram from code analogies.com you can
see we have the page the structure
styling and functionality and if we move
this slider
so it's like the house so Pages like the
house so the structure or the HTML is
like how many bedrooms there are or how
many rooms the CSS The Styling is like
the color the color of the brick here
and then the functionality what you're
doing like eating is the JavaScript you
can actually see the HTML that makes up
any element on a web page by
right-clicking an element and then going
to inspect
and this all this right here is the HTML
now I'll explain the difference between
front end and back-end development the
front end of a website is the part that
users can see and interact with it's the
part that all happens on the user's
computer or device the back end is the
part of the website that runs on the
server and Powers the front end the back
end includes the database application
logic and API some static websites only
need a front end but if a website
interacts with a database or involves a
lot of dynamic content then there needs
to be a back-end server away from the
user's device to do some processing
before sending data back to the user
full stack development is just a
combination of front end and back-end
development by the end of this course
you'll have a better understanding of
front-end and back-end development now
it's time for you to start learning how
to use HTML and CSS Tomi will teach this
section and before I pass it over to him
I'm I want to thank replit for giving
freecodecamp.org a grant to make this
course possible we'll do all the
development using replit which allows
you to write acmail CSS and JavaScript
all in your web browser
welcome to this section of discourse in
this section I'm going to be teaching
you everything you need to know to get
started building your own web pages
using HTML I'm going to be showing you
what HTML is why we use HTML and how you
can build web pages using HTML now in
this course we're going to be using
Rapids for our coding and I'm going to
show you how to set that up and how to
do everything all from replica
so the first thing we need to do is to
go to replica.com so once you get to
replica.com you're going to have to
create an account and login so once you
log into repllay.com it's going to bring
you to this dashboard right here so once
you're in this dashboard you're just
going to come to this corner right here
and click on this create button or you
can go to the top right corner and click
on the New Rapid button so what I'm just
going to do is to click on Create and
it's going to ask you to choose the
language you want to use so for this
section of this tutorial we're going to
be choosing this HTML CSS and JavaScript
but you don't need to worry about CSS
and JavaScript for now we're just going
to be using the HTML part
so let's name this HTML
tutorial
I'm going to create a new replied so
that is going to take a few seconds to
create all of that for us and once that
is created I'm going to show you what
this is so as you can see it's created
this for us with like a boilerplate of
code
that automatically comes with this
particular replica that we created so
what I'm just going to do is to quickly
show you around replay what it does and
how we're going to use this so on this
corner you can see that it shows all the
files has been created so because we
chose HTML CSS and JavaScript it created
free files for us one is stands for HTML
one is for CSS and one is for JavaScript
but as I said for now I'm only going to
be looking into the HTML part so I'm
going to close that tab just to make
sure that we have enough screen
and in here it shows the code base so
this is basically where we're going to
be doing the main coding it's like our
code editor and at this right side it
shows the output of whatever we are
coding in here
so now that we have that out the way I
wanted to quickly talk to you about HTML
so before we actually go into coding I'm
going to introduce you to what HTML is
and why we even use it so HTML stands
for iPad text markup language
so it's basically a standard markup
language used for creating websites and
web pages so HTML like describes how the
structure of a website or a web page is
going to look like so any website you
will see on the web or any web page you
see on the web there's some HTML coding
that has been done to build that
so HTML basically consists of different
elements to make it what is so for
example if I come into this code you can
see that we have some Hello World text
being printed and if you come into the
code you can see that that hello world
text is right here so this hello world
text is under this element name body so
don't worry about what all of this means
for now I'm going to go through all of
that but just know that HTML comprises
of different elements and now I'm going
to talk to you about what all these
elements are the different type of
elements that we have so first of all
I'm going to remove some text
because we're not going to talk about
them for now I'm gonna remove all of
this script because all of that are
JavaScript and we don't need that for
now
and I'm also going to remove this so
this is just a basic HTML code right
so as I said there are different
elements so for example this doctype
HTML is a declaration that defines this
document is an HTML document so this
just tells us that whatever our coding
is an HTML document and we have another
element which is this HTML right and it
shows the root of the HTML page so this
means that anything that we are going to
be coding in this HTML file is going to
go into this HTML element so we open it
here and we close it here I'm also going
to talk about the structure of how we
code an element using tags so I'm going
to talk about that in a bit but for now
as you can see we have this HTML that is
the root of the whole project right and
then we also have Ed that contains some
information
specifically about the HTML page for
example under it we have the title now
this title is whatever you see on the
browser so on the browser right here
where you see this index.html that is
the title of that page so whatever we
put here is what's going to be shown
here so as you can see that basically is
part of the structure of the whole web
page
and then everything that is going to be
in this section of this of the browser
or of the web page goes into the body
element so that is what the body element
is for it's basically all the code that
you're going to do is going to be done
inside the body element
let me tell you how we actually write
this HTML element so we write HTML
element by defining tags and the content
and the ending tags so let me tell you
what I mean by this now I'm just going
to close all of this real quick because
we are going to have to start from
scratch so you understand it so for
example let's say we have
an H1 tag
so this H1 is an element in HTML and is
used to create like an adding text for
example in here if I put I welcome
and once I run that
you're going to see that it prints I
welcome like an add-in so that is what
this H1 element does but how did we
write this H1 element the first thing we
do is to say we're going to open an H1
tag so we're going to have two
less than sign and greater than sign and
in there we're going to have the name of
that particular tag then after that
we're going to have the content that is
meant to be shown in that element after
that we're going to close that tag so
this is how we close the tag now let me
show you another tag there is another
tag that is used to define a new
paragraph and this tag is called p so we
have this sign less than sign we put p
we close that automatically replace ends
the tag for us but I'm going to delete
that and show you how to close it so in
here we're just going to put something
like this is a new paragraph
and then we're gonna have to close it we
close it by using the less than sign the
slash sign we put p and we close it back
so this is how to open your tag so it's
something like this we're going to say
tag once we close it
so this is basically the opening tag and
then in here the content
and then to close the tag it's basically
similar to this but instead we have a
slash
so what we can just do to do
less than sign slash replied
automatically close that for us so that
is basically how to you know create a
tag and
elements in HTML
now we're going to be talking more about
the basics of HTML so basically the
structure that you're meant to follow
when you create a new HTML page
so I'm gonna get rid of all of this and
let's start this from the beginning
so whenever you create a new HTML page
you must first Define a doctype
declaration now this shows the type of
documents that this represents so it
allows the browser to know how to
display the web page correctly
so what to do this we just need to use
the less than sign because it is an
element so we do it the same way and
then we use the up this sign and then we
say doctype
and then we're gonna specify the type of
you know file that we're actually coding
in and this is HTML and we're just going
to close that so this is the first thing
you should do when you create a new HTML
file right and then once you do this the
next thing that you want to be doing is
to
create the HTML tag so this HTML tag as
I said in the
a while ago is is the root of all your
of the oh HTML structure so everything
that we're going to be coding should be
inside this HTML tag we're going to
write HTML
and automatically replace closes that
for us
now inside this HTML there is something
else that we need to have and this is
the body so the body basically takes any
visible code or any visible
thing that we want to show on our web
page now for example this I welcome
should be under the body
for example the the code used to create
the HTML code used to create this replay
all everything that we see right here
should be stored under the body type so
right here we should have
a body
and as I said replace closes that for us
automatically
so anything that we're going to code
should go in the body right here
so now I'm going to talk more about
different types of tags what they are
used for so we have the add-in tags and
they are mostly defined from their name
to show add-ins so we have them in a
list from H1 to H6 so in the a while ago
I showed you how to create this add-in
using the H1 tag this editing that we
see right here so
we do H1 and then we close it you can
say first adding
now if we run that you're going to see
that it's just going to print a show out
the first adding as you can see it says
first adding now if we use another tag
named H2 this is also an adding tag but
it is smaller compared to H1
so if I say second adding
and I run that you're gonna see that
it's going to show second editing but
quite similar to this and if I use
another one H3
I can say third adding
and once I run that you're gonna see
that it's going to be smaller
so the size of the heading keeps
descending
right as the
H1 H2 so as you are sent from H1 H to H3
all the way to H6 the side skips
descending so H1 is the biggest so you
can use this whenever you see fit in
your code now the next one I want to
talk to you about is the paragraph tags
I talked about this briefly a while ago
but let me talk more about this now so
it is a very basic and simple tag what
it just does is it creates a new
paragraph so for example in your code
let's say you want there to be some
spacing between different text or you
just want to show like a new paragraph
structure we use the P tag so once again
we use the less than sign we put P we
use the greater than sign
and in between this opening and closing
tags we have the content of that
paragraph so we can say
this is
a test paragraph
so if I run this you're going to see
that
first of all there's going to be spacing
between it and this is a normal text
it's not a heading it's not bold like
this H1 tags so as you can see it just
say this is a test paragraph right
now the next one I want to talk to you
about uh HTML links so for example let's
say on this page if I click on invite
and it takes me to another link or
another page there's basically an HTML
link tag that allows me to do this now
let me show you what I mean so for
example let's say I want the user to say
something like click this link
right and once the user click this link
I want to take the user to you know
freecodecamp.com or
oh I want to take these out to
google.com so what we can just do is to
say
I'm gonna remove this real quick
we open a new tag but this time around
we're using an a tag right and then I'm
going to close it
so once I close it I'm going to have the
content in here so I can say click this
link
right but now there's something
different with this this is when I'm
introducing you to what we call HTML
attributes now if you don't understand
this now you don't need to worry because
I'm going to have a whole section
dedicated to talking about HTML
attributes so HTML attribute just shows
me what parameters a tag needs to take
for example this a tag is used for
redirecting a user to another link or
sending a user to another page but it
needs to know what page it wants to send
the user to so for example once a user
click clicks on this click the link
and we need to specify the link that we
want to take the user to so it needs to
have an attribute and the name of this
attribute is href and this is how we
input attribute in HTML tags in the
opening tag we leave a space and we type
the name of the attribute and we say
equals to and we use this quote
now in this code we specify the value of
that attribute so in this case the value
of this attribute is the link I want to
take the user to right so let's say I
say google.com
now if I run this you're gonna see that
we have like a blue
color with underline that is underlined
and if I drag this right here
so I'm just gonna go back to that
and let's say I drag this right here
okay so
um it gives us an error it says
replica.co.google.com now this is
because I didn't Define that it's an
external link so it's thinking that is a
link under this particular web page so
what you need to do is just to say https
so basically specify it as a new link on
his own so once I run that and it runs
again if I take this if you look at the
left bottom corner you can see that it's
showing me that I'm going to go to https
google.com if I take this and paste this
year it opens google.com
so this that is the basic way of
creating a link right and don't worry
about the attribute for now I'm going to
talk more about that soon
now we are going to talk more about HTML
attribute so a while ago I showed you
how we used a simple HTML attribute to
show the link that we want the user to
go to once they click on this click the
link button or just click the link text
but now I want to talk more about what
this attribute actually is why we use it
how do we use it and different tags
where we can use this
so as I said a while ago the attribute
basically gives more information about
the element or the tag so for example
this a tag it needed an information and
that information needed is the link we
want to send the user to so once the
user clicks on click the link we want to
send the user to google.com now there
are other tags that actually need us to
you know specify different things that's
when we use the HTML attributes for
example we have the IMG which is also
known as the image tag and this needs an
HTML attribute that specifies where or
the source of that image that we want to
show so before we go into that let me
quickly go through again how we you how
we specify how we create HTML attributes
so as I said in the tag in the opening
tag we write the name of the attribute
and what the attribute contains so
basically like the value of that
attribute right so first to do this now
let's test it on another tag so let me
show you how we can display an image on
your HTML page so right here we want to
display a simple image so what we can
just do
is to say IMG right
and we're going to close this so this
image tag is uh is a tiger is an element
that doesn't need to close it so you
know how we
close the P tag by using this slash we
don't need to do that right here for IMG
and now the reason why is because the
IMG tag or the image tag doesn't take a
value right now what I mean by this is
like it doesn't showcase the value the
only thing it showcases is the image so
it just needs the source of that image
so we do all of this in here because we
want that between those tags we want to
show this text we want to show this text
we want to show this text we want to
show this text but in an image tag we
don't want to show any text we just want
to show the image so what we just need
to specify is the source of that image
so we can do this similar to how we
specified the link to this URL that
we're redirecting
we are going to say SRC
so right now we want to specify the
source or the link from where this image
is coming from right so as I said this
is the name and India is going to be
like the value of this source so we can
just take a random image for example we
can you know
take let's see if we can take an image
from this page
um we can take an image so we can just
go on you go and search random
image
and then in here we can take this dice
image
and also click on this dice image
we can say copy image address so now
that we have that image address once we
paste this in here that is the source of
where that image is coming from right if
I run this
you're gonna see now that it shows that
image right now obviously this is a tag
used to show an image and the reason why
I said we don't close this tag is just
because we don't need to write any text
that is why we don't like have a closing
tag and put a text within it so that is
how we basically do that very easy very
simple to do now we can
a an HTML tag can have more than one
attribute right now in here you can see
that we have this SRC attribute but what
if we want to do more to this image we
need more attributes like what if we
want to change the size or anything so
for example we want to change the the
width of this image I want to change the
height of this image so let's say I want
to change the height of this image right
and let's say we want to make it smaller
or bigger to do this we're going to have
to specify another image attribute and
this attribute is called height
so once again we specify attributes by
writing the name we put the equals to
sign and in here we put the quotes now
inside our code is where we put the
value of that particular attribute so
let's say we want to make this 200. if I
run this let's see what changes that
makes to this particular image you can
see now that the image is shorter and I
can also do the same thing to do with
what if I want to reduce the width or
increase the width I'm just going to do
with
equals then we put the column
the code and then we also have the size
let's say the size is also 200 and we
run that
so once we run that
you can see that the width has also
decreased so this is basically how we
can do this
so we can also have another attribute
called alt now this alt attributes
basically tells us like let's say more
information about this image so let's
say we just want to say the image
contains a dice right
say Alt
equals we put quotes now we can see
something like
this image contains a dice
now once we run this
we're gonna see
that this has a description of this
image contains a dice so we don't see
this right but for example if you go to
the let's say you get the source of this
image or whatever once it's coming with
a description it comes with this alt
description which is this image contains
the site it dies now this is not what is
shown to a user right but this is
basically part of the attribute of this
image
so there are also various attributes of
different things we can use right and
for example right in here where we have
this paragraph so let me just get rid of
this image because we don't need it so
right here where we have this paragraph
let's say we want to show like
I don't know maybe another information
of this paragraph So something like
um once a user clicks on this right but
what's the user overs over this we want
to show that this is a new paragraph or
something like that we use a title
attribute now this is not really widely
used but just an example of what
attributes are let me say I say titu
equals this so and I'm just going to say
test
once I run this
I'm gonna wait for that to show so if I
come to this paragraph right here you
can see that when I hover over this you
can see that there's a small button that
comes up that says test so that's just
another
useful attribute now as I said there are
various attributes and it's very easy to
make mistake while defining attributes
so you must make sure let me go through
it again you must make sure that you
have the name of the attribute you put
the equal sign you put the double quotes
and in there you put the value of that
attribute if you do that you can't go
wrong
now let's talk more about HTML
paragraphs so in here I briefly talked
about what paragraphs are and how we can
use them so first of all I'm going to
get rid of this title attribute that I
added to the paragraph
so as I said we talked about this
paragraph right here but now I want to
go deeper into what these are on you
know how they actually show in your web
page now for example let's say we have a
paragraph right here and we write this
like this is a paragraph and first of
all let me just have this like this and
put this here so just to make it a
little bit more structured for me as
decoder to see
so guys I said this is a test paragraph
and I say something like this is a new
line
now you expect that it should print it
or you should show it here the way I
typed it in here but no it's not going
to do that so if I'm going to run this
now and you're going to see that it just
shows everything on the same line
but most of the time or sometimes I
might not want to do this now even if
let's say I put let me see let's run
this
and then once you print it you can see
that all the spaces are lived in from a
to new didn't show so none of these
shows and there are different solutions
to this because most of the times we
might want to create a new line we might
want to you know do various stuffs so
first of all let me show you the first
solution that we can add to this
so let's say we want to have a break
right so for example
in here we want a new line to be created
so we wanted this text to come to a new
line we can use uh another
HTML element called break so it's short
form for br well it's called break and
what this means is just after that
wherever we put it it's going to break
to a new line so this is another HTML
element that doesn't require uh
closing tag and once again this is
because we are not showing any content
for it it's just there to perform its
own function so once we specify this BR
like this it's going to create a new
line for us so I don't even need to you
know make this in a new line once I just
do break wherever
I put the break from a new line is going
to be created so now once I run this
you're going to see that it says this is
a test paragraph and a new line is being
created there now that is one solution
to the problem but another solution or
the solution I go with when I have this
particular problem don't get me wrong
break is very useful you're going to use
it a lot when you're coding HTML but for
this type of problem I use the pre tag
so it's basically similar to the
paragraph tag but the difference is that
the way we write our code our text in
here is the way it's going to be shown
on the web page so for example first of
all let me change this to pre
I'm going to change this to pre so I
call it the pre tag you can call it the
pre-tag or whatever you want to call it
so let me just have this on a new line
and let me create a new line and say
another line
yet another line
and another line
once I run this you're going to see that
the way I wrote this year is how it
shows here you can see that even with
the spaces that are put in here is what
is showing there if I get rid of these
spaces
let me get rid of all the spaces real
quick
can you see that the way we put it in
there is how it's going to show for us
and that is a solution to that
particular problem now let's see it
run again so I'm gonna run this
real quick
I'm gonna wait for that to run as you
can see everything has been fixed so
that is a way to solve that problem in a
paragraph tag now let me show you some
other you know elements that are going
to be very useful when writing bad text
like this for example let's say we want
to have a line across this to let's say
differentiate two different parts of a
page just the way we add the BR tag
we're going to have a tag named HR so
this tag is an empty tag once I just do
HR
right it doesn't have a closing tag it's
just an opening tag
from wherever I did that HR there's
going to be a line
an horizontal line that is going to be
rude right here and let's run that and
let's see what that gives us
as you can see we have a line it leaves
a space it continues I can have it
everywhere and just say
HR
I can do the same here
and say HR
and I can do the same here and say
HR
so once I run this you're going to see
that lines are going to be created
everywhere exact same way the way we
want it as you can see it's structured
very well the way we want it now that's
how to use an HR tag in your HTML code
or whatever you want to use it let's say
paragraph or another code
now we are going to be talking about
formatting text or formatting elements
in HTML so we might want to show
different texts in different ways for
example we might want a text to be bold
we might want to text you know to be
superscripted or subscripted or we might
want a text to look like an italic text
so for all of these we need to format
them to look the way we want them to
look so to format it we need to use HTML
elements right so for example let's say
we have a simple a simple text in here
that says this is a text
so once we have a text that says this is
a text right here if I run this now make
sure that everything is under the body
element as I said from the beginning so
it says this is a text
but what if I want this to be bold now
for me to do this I'm going to use an
element named B and that b stands for
both so it basically makes whatever
content is within it bold so I'm going
to cut this
I'm gonna do B
I'm gonna paste that in so now once I
run this you're gonna see that that text
is bold
so this is how you make a text build you
open a tag normally the way we do you
put B you close that you put the text in
there and then you close the whole tag
so once you have that done and you run
it this should show this is a text
now similarly you can also use another
tag name strong so if I come here and I
say strong
right and I close it and I say this
so strong
and once I run this you're going to see
that it looks exactly the same thing as
this is another way for you to do that
so let's actually have a br tag here and
we've talked about what BR does it
breaks the line just so we're going to
have each text we're having on another
line so let me run that and you're gonna
see that we have that on another line
so that is how you can you know use the
strong but what if let's say you want
your text to show as an emphasize text
so for example we're going to use a tag
name em let me say em let me just say
emphasize
once I run this right you're gonna see
that that text looks emphasize it looks
different from the normal text so this
is kind of like an italic text so if you
want your text to look italic you can
use this emphasize or or you can use the
I tag and this I tag stands for italic
it makes that text italic so once I say
italic and I run this italic text
you're gonna see that it looks italic
right if you look closely you can see
the little difference between it but
they look very similar so instead of us
having let's say a break
you know a break
elements after every single text what we
can just do is to cut all of this and
then we can have a pre-tag
and this pre-tag we can then paste all
of that text in it and then when we
paste all of that text in it the way we
put it here is how it's going to be
shown here so once I run that you can
see it says this is this text and all of
that so it leaves the space for us let
me remove this
and then in here we do this just to make
it look better
so once we run that that should show the
text how we want it right so once we've
done with the italic we can also Mark a
text so let's say we want to do
something like
mark this
and then we want to have
Mac
and say marked
I'm gonna show you what this does
so as you can see it I liked that
particular text for us right so it makes
that test highlighted how we want it so
we can say let's say we want to say this
is an example or this is an important
information and then we just want to
mark that important information
important
information
Ronda is going to show us that important
information highlighted so that is what
the mark element does
now let's say we want a text to you know
be canceled out for example you know
where you see maybe on different web
pages and you see something like this is
something you shouldn't do and then you
see strike like a line is stroking
through it that is a delete element so
let me show you what I mean so let's say
we have a text that says don't do this
I would say
delete
and in there we say
do it right now once I run this you're
gonna see that that do it as a strike
through it that is how that is done if
you see this anywhere on the web it's
done using or you can do it using this
delete element
now we can also have an inserted text so
let me say ins right and say inserted
if I run this you're gonna see that it
has this text like underlined or
basically highlighted but not in this
way but it's underlined
now let's say I want a text to be very
small compared to what all of these are
so I can say small we're going to use a
small element and say this
is quite small
I run this you're going to see that the
size of this is smaller compared to all
of these texts
now the last two ones I'm going to talk
about are subscripted and superscripted
now you know in let's say chemical
formulas where we have something like
oxygen which is like O2 and we want o to
show right here and then we want two to
show but we want it to show like at the
bottom or let's say we have something
like 7 raised to power 3 right instead
of doing using this sign right here we
actually want it to show raised to power
3 on there so it's very easy for us to
do this so for us to do the chemical
formula type we can say o
and then where we have these two we're
going to say sub so this subscripted
means that it should be on the bottom
I'm going to show you what that is go to
we're going to run this real quick and
you can see that it shows two
subscripted compared to O now let's say
I want to have 7 raised to power three
this time around I won't use sub I will
use superscripted I'm going to change B
to p
now once I run this you're gonna see
that it has seven raised to the power of
three
we're going to quickly talk about colors
in HTML so I want to go more into like a
little bit of styling of this text or of
a particular element so for example what
I mean is let's say I want this text to
like have a background color or I don't
want this text to be black I want it to
be let's say white or you know blue or
whatever now I can use the background
color attribute now let me first show
you what I'm gonna do let's get rid of
all of this under the body tag
and back in the body tag what I'm going
to do let's say I just have a basic H1
right and I say this
is my adding so if I run that from now
you should know that it's just going to
print a basic this is my heading right
so I'm going to have an attribute so you
know what an attribute is it gives more
information about that element so we can
have an attribute name Style
now this style attribute basically gives
us
a way of Designing this particular you
know elements so let's say I want this
particular element or this text to have
a color of let's say red so I'm going to
say Style
equals to and double quotes
right in there I can have different
things I want you to do but we're not
going to go in depth into that for now
because that is more of like a CSS type
of code which you don't need to know for
now but what I'm going to show you is
how we can you know make it have a
different color so let's say I want the
color right
to be blue this is how I do it I just
say color
column blue
now once I run this you're going to see
that it changes that color to Blue and
this is the simple way of doing this
it's very easy very simple you know
there are various different like I will
call it like a styling command that we
can give it so this is a styling command
in my words so it's like we're saying
that the color of this particular text
should be blue
now let's say we want to have another
like another style to it like let's say
we want it to have a different
background color on its own now what
we're going to do is to
stop this or no we won't say stop this
we'll end this by putting a semicolon so
this means that after this we can have
another styling done in there so what we
want to do now is to just say
background
and then we're gonna do I think color
and now we can change the background
color to whatever we want let's say I
want the background color to be red
right so as you can see we say
background color we use the colon and
then we use the value right so the value
is red and we put this semicolon too so
that that is where it ends now once I
run this you're gonna see that only that
text has a background color of red now
that is the basic way of you know taking
care of colors like that and there are
various stuffs where you can use like
CSS code to style this like we can make
this be in the middle we can you know do
more stuffs but we're not going to talk
about that for now so that this is just
basically how you you know use colors in
HTML
now that we've talked about colors the
next thing I want to talk to you about
is comments in HTML now this comment is
not just only a concept in HTML alone
it's a concept used generally in
programming so what comments does is
that it basically makes a particular
block of code not display in you know
when your code is run or something now
let me explain what I mean better now
what I mean is for example let's say we
have a text
that is p and we say
a text
so we we don't want this to show because
obviously when we run this this is going
to show in here but we don't want this
to show here right but we don't want to
delete it also we don't want to remove
it from there what you can do is to
comment that block of code or that line
of code now for you to comment what you
need to do is to use
this particular syntax now just follow
as I do so what you're just going to do
is to say less than
gonna use the sign and then two
of this and then after the code that you
want to comment you're going to close it
by doing the same thing except with the
the exclamation marks so as you can see
what that is it's basically graze this
part out if I run this you're going to
see that that part doesn't show now this
is a very good use of when we want to
use comment because we don't want this
particular part of the code to be run
when all our code is run right that is a
very good use of comment that is most of
the time why I use comments the other
reason you might want to use comments is
to actually drop a comment on the code
that you are creating for example let's
say we want to comment and say the code
below displays uh adding that as a blue
color right we don't just want to write
that in and say the code
below this place
and edit
right we don't just want to write that
there because if you write this there
it's obviously going to show right here
in our code so let's say we just want to
put it in a comment so that whoever is
reading our code we understand what we
are doing so what we're going to do is
to put this in a comment now just the
same way we did here we're gonna have
the same syntax
and close it
so now whoever is reading our code knows
that this code here
just displays an adding if I run this
it's not going to show with it no more
that is because it's only in the source
code right but it's not in the output so
it basically hides that content now you
can use it as I said to hide a code or
to stop a code from being executed when
you run it or you can use it to actually
drop a comment on a code
now we are going to look more into links
in HTML now earlier in this course we
talked briefly about links and now you
can make a user click on a text on a
button and it takes the user to a
specific link but now I'm going to go
deeper into what they actually do and
more use cases of links so I'm going to
get rid of this real quick
remove that and then we can remove that
and we are back to just the body
so now obviously I showed you how to
create a link and you want to create a
link we say a
and in between that we say let's say
go to site
let's say go to site
and then we have an attribute named f
href
and let's say we want you to go to you
know https
google.com
now once I run this
and if I just over over this on the
bottom left corner left bottom corner
you can see that the link shows that is
redirecting us to google.com
so this is a basic way of just creating
a link in HTML
so I'm going to talk more about like
different things you can do with it for
example if I click on this go to site
it's probably going to take me to the
google.com but then it's going to go
away from this page and take me to that
page but what if I don't want to do this
so you know for example on different
blogs or different website where you
click on the link and it automatically
opens a new tab with that link so it
doesn't close the tab that you are
currently on you can do that using an
attribute named Target so if I say
Target
right and I make the value underscore
blank
now this is going to create a new
it's going to create a new
tab for us so let's say I run this
and then I say go to site you can see
that it opens it on a new tab it doesn't
like go to that site from here that is
what that Target blank does it is very
useful because sometimes you might let's
say you're building an application that
you want a user to let's say view
something but you don't want them to go
away from the site that they are in from
your site because maybe there's some
things that still need to be changed
this is a good use case of this target
attribute
now there are two things because our
absolute URL and relative URL now if you
remember in the beginning when I was
trying to create a new link and I put
google.com right when I run it and I
clicked on go to site so let me just
go to site it's going to open a new tab
you can see what he's doing he's saying
replica
google.com now this is because it sees
this URL this link as a relative URL now
a relative URL means that we are trying
to link to somewhere else within this
particular web page so it's basically
saying something like let's say I just
say slash
um slash go so it's basically going to
go to reply.com all of this slash go
that is a relative URL is is just going
to this particular URL this link within
the local you know the local application
or the local website well let's say we
want to go to an external website like
the way I went to google.com now that is
an absolute URL that is when we have to
do the https right
and then we have to specify the site
that we are going to
so now that is an absolute URL that is
the difference between both of them
so we can also link to different things
like let's say we want to link to an
email address so let's say we want to
say something like
let's have an a tag
I want to say
send me an email
and one that once the user clicks on
this it's gonna like open a new tab that
is sending an email to a particular you
know a particular email address first to
do this we're just going to say href
equals now we are going to specify the
link what we need to specify is the mail
to
colon and then we're going to put the
address so we can put sample
at sample.com
so for example where I run this right
this is gonna show me send me an email
and if I open it it's gonna
it says mail.google.com refuse to
connect but it basically open a Gmail
and tries to you know send an email so
this is just not showing because we're
under like this report but let's say you
have your own website and you use this
it's basically gonna open a page where
you can compose an email to that email
site
now we are going to talk about titles
and favicons in HTML so a title is very
simple and very straightforward so what
is it what it is is basically the text
that is shown at the tab or the top of
the tab on a web page for example on
this webpage you can see that what is
shown is this index.html HTML tutorial
replica that is the title of this page
so for you to specify the title of a
page right you need to have an add
element
to write
after the HTML tag we're going to have
this Edge okay right here
am I going to close it now this Edge tag
basically contains different you know
information about the page some of it is
information about the top corner like
the icon that shows here which is the
favicon the title and some other
information but in this part we're going
to be looking more into this title and
this icon that shows here which is also
known as the favicon so first let's look
at the title so as I said the title is
the information that has been displayed
in here so for us to set the title of
our web page what we're going to do is
to open up
new tag and say title
and this title tag must be in the add
element so this is also another nested
element just like the way I talked about
previously so now this type 2 elements
must be under this Edge element so what
I can just do is
my page
so I can see my page is the title of
this particular you know web page now if
I run this right well I'm not actually
going to see anything here because this
is just like a you know a demo of this
but let's say we have our website we
have our HTML file and we run it on our
browser here you're gonna see that
detects here
is gonna be that now I'm also going to
show you how to you know create your
HTML files on your local computer and
actually run it on a browser so you can
see like this type of examples but for
now know that this title is what is
being shown here
now the next thing we're going to talk
about as I say is the favicon now this
favicon is known as the logo or the
image that is shown before the title on
your page so
right here you can see I have this tab
and you can see this Google logo that is
the favicon
so to have the five econ we're going to
have the link tag right and then the way
we close the link down is just to do
like that we don't close it because it's
similar to an image tag we are not
actually writing a text so in here I'm
going to save rail that is an attribute
I'm going to give it and I'm going to
say it's an icon right
and I'm just gonna say href which is the
link of where I want to get that favicon
from initiate equals this now let's
actually get that link right here I just
searched free code cam favicon PMG I got
this and I'm just gonna copy the image
address I'm going to come in here and
paste it now if I run it once again this
is not going to actually show here
because this is a demo of this but when
I show you how to you know run your HTML
file on your browser you're going to see
all of these details but that is how to
use a favicon and the title in HTML
now let's talk about tables in HTML so a
table where you can just basically
represent data I'm going to show you how
to create that right now
so as you might have guessed we're also
going to use another element and the
element we're going to use this time
around is going to be called table
so let me get rid of this right here and
I'm gonna get rid of this link right
here
so in the body what I just want to do is
to create a new table so just a normal
table right just a normal table where we
have the adding and then we have the
data that this table contains so first
to do this we're going to say table
and then we're just going to close it
just like that
and for us to now create like a new row
in that table we're going to use another
tag named TR so this stands for table
row
so in this table row I can say something
like let's say I want to have
let me visualize this so let's say table
data
let's look for images
let's make that table
good so now for example we have this
right so this is going to be a row so
what we just created right here this TR
is a new row right here I'm let's say I
want to create another row to store all
of this data under here I'm going to
create another TR right and I'm going to
close that so this means we have two
rows now so we can keep doing that for
the amount of rows that we want so what
we can now do is that under the first
row we want to have the heading so we
want to say name rank gender and yeah
all of this adding so for us to do this
we're going to use
a tag name th which is also known as
table heading so that table heading
we're just going to do this real quick
so this th is going to be the adding so
let's say something like name
so this is going to stand for name we
might want to have another table heading
named age
and then let's say we want to say
something
like Plus
right and then if I run this you're
gonna see what we have so you see that
we just have name age and class and
let's say under this now I want to have
a name like let's say Tommy and my age
and I might put a class so what I'm just
going to do is I'm going to create a new
row as you can see I already did that
here but now instead of doing th what
I'm going to do is TD so this means
we're adding a table data not a table
adding right so you only use th when you
have when you specify the edge of that
class so of that table data but for the
values we use TD
so let's say something like Tommy
and for the age is another TD
and let's just say I don't know 18 19
let's just put a random H there and
another TD
let's get rid of that let's just small
letters and it says class and we can say
here
I know you're 20.
12 and then once we run that
you're gonna see that we have this basic
table that says name tell me 19 year 12.
now we can keep adding more rows what we
just need to do is to do TR
and on that TR I'm going to have TD
and I'm gonna I can use another one and
just say John
I'm gonna have another TD
and let's say the age is 30
and let's say
um is in year 15 or something like that
now once I run this
you're gonna see that we basically have
a simple table that shows that so as you
can see it just shows the you know
adding it shows the
data which is told me 19 yeah 12 it
shows John 30 and all of that so that's
basically what we need
to build a table very simple and very
easy we make sure we have the table
class we make sure we have the TR and
then we make sure we have data in
between
now let's talk about lists in HTML so
let's say we want to have a simple list
right here that just lists let's say a
list of names a list of years or
whatever first of all let's get rid of
this table that we created I'm not
talking about that now
so
what we're talking about is lists so
there are two types of lists there on
other lists and their order lists now
another list are the ones that just have
like a simple bullet point mark between
them I mean before them but on other
list is listed from one two three
for basically numerically now let me
show you what I mean now for example
let's say we want to write an unordered
list we need to use a tag name UL
once you use the UL tag we need to open
and close that type I'm going to press
enter and for us to now add list this UL
stands for on other lists so first to
now add elements in this list we're
going to have to use the Li
stands for list and we're going to say
something like
name one
and we can do the same thing to have a
second name Li
again I say name two
let's have a third name I say l i
I'm going to say name three
so as you can see we have three
different names if I run it you're not
going to see that we have name one name
to name three now this is shown listed
but it's not ordered it doesn't have one
two three four five and so on we want it
to be ordered like to show in ascending
order then what we just need to do is to
Simply change this UL to ol and this ol
means ordered lists so if I change that
right here and I run this you're not
going to see that they have numeric
numbers before them so if I keep adding
and let me saying another list and I say
name four
it's automatically going to add 4 as a
number before that
now there are also more to list like for
example we can show a description of
this name
now first to do this we need to change
these other list to description list so
this description is basically allows us
to show more description on each list if
we want to so what we're going to do now
is we change that to description list
and let's say on the first list we want
this to be DT not Li that's the
difference
we're going to remove all of this real
quick and under that let's say we want
to have a description of this name one
we're going to use DD so this just shows
the description and let's say something
like
um
let's have like an asterisk and say this
is the first name
now once I run this you're going to see
what it shows us so you see that it says
name one and under here it leaves like a
space and it says the description of
that name we can add another one and
just say DT
and just say name two
and now to show the description of this
we just say DD and we can have the
asteric again and say this is the second
name
now if I run this you're now going to
see that we have name one we have the
description we have name two and we have
the description
now let's look into block element and
inline elements so the difference
between block and inline elements is
basically this so a block element always
starts on a new line and the browser
automatically adds some space before and
after the element but for an inline
element the inline element doesn't start
on a new line and
it doesn't it just takes the space that
it needs so it doesn't you know have a
space before it and after it so there
are examples of block elements and a div
is one good example of block element now
let's quickly talk more about this div
tag
so div tag is written like this
the IV and it's closed see most of the
time is a wrapper or is a tag where all
other HTML elements are contained with
so let's say we want to group like our
old application or our old web page into
different sections we can use a div tag
to do that
so for example we have this deep tag and
I can just say something like H1
where's the div and after this I can
just say I can just have a b tag in here
I can say this is bold
right and I can then have another div
tag just to separate that
now it's just this is wrapping all of
these elements in it and this one we can
have an H2 and say
another one and for B
we can say I
so if I run this it's basically just a
normal text that prints this but it
wraps it into this div tags now we can
use different things to you know know
these div tags like for example I mean
to recognize the divs like we can have
an ID as an attribute that says that
this old div tag has an ID of you know
first div or we can represent it using a
you know a class but we're not going to
go into that for now we can also do more
things like you know in the beginning
when we made the background color of
this first div of this H1 like red we
can do that to this div and now
everything inside the div tag will be
affected once anything here is changed
now let me tell you what I mean so we're
going to use a style attribute we've
talked about this before and let's say
we use color
and say that we want the color to be
green
now once I run this
all the elements in here are going to
have the green color
right I can also change the background
the background color
let me say blue
now once I run this
all the elements in here we have a
background of blue and not the other one
you can see now that we're able to
actually like separate different
sections of our code and give them
different attributes
so I can do something similar and say
that style
and I want the color
to be red
and I can see I want the background
color
and I want this to do something like
purple
now let me run this and see what it
gives me
you can see now these are two different
sections this has a different color and
the different background color this also
has a color of red and a totally
different background color now that is
what a div class is and you can see that
there's a space between and after that
particular d-class space between after
that particular div tag
so now there is an example of an inline
element as I said it doesn't take us as
much space as a digital and it doesn't
start on a new line so an inline element
an example of that is something like an
a tag for example or a B tag this B tag
now is an inline element this means that
I can basically let's say just have a
normal P right and say this is a text
and in there I can just have a b tag
and say bold one
so it can stay within a text it can stay
wherever you put it it doesn't really
need to be separated on its own compared
to a div tag so that's the difference
between a block element and an inline
element so there are various examples of
block elements like a few that I can see
on top of my head are like you know HR
like div as I said you know like pre
[Music]
UL you know section and there are other
elements like that and for
inline element we have the a tag which
we just which we used earlier we have
the both tag we have image tag and
various more so this is basically the
difference between those two
now let's look into iframe in HTML
so an iframe is used to show a web page
inside a web page so what I mean by this
is using an iframe we can have like a
box that shows another web page in our
own web page so let me show you how to
do this it's very easy and very simple
all we just need to do is to use the
syntax so we're just gonna come here
we're gonna get rid of all this D
and I just want to say iframe
we're going to close it now it's going
to take some attributes the first
attribute is going to take is the source
so once it takes the source attribute
this Source attribute is the link that
we want to show in here so let's say I
want to show google.com
so this is going to show google.com in
here for me so that is that easy to do
and once I run this you're gonna see
what it shows you can see that it
creates a box it says refuse to connect
that is probably because of this replay
um page but normally once you use this
iframe as you can see it's trying to
connect to google.com
so there are more you can do to this
iframe more things like you can you know
specify the height the width of what how
big you want this to be so I'm going to
give you more attributes and say height
and let's say 100
if I run that you're gonna see that it
goes smaller and let's say I also give
it a width
of 100.
now if I run that you're gonna see that
the width also goes smaller so I can
increase it however I like I can say
this is 500 and I can say this is 500.
so if I run that and I'm gonna see that
we have a big iframe right here so
that's how to create a very basic iframe
for us now you can also remove the
Border you know this line where you see
we can do that so to do that we are
going to use the style attribute we've
talked about this style attribute before
easy to you know add some styling to
that particular element so now what
we're just going to do here is to say
border now this border is basically the
line that we see right here I'm going to
say border equals none
if I run this
and now gonna see that there is no lines
there the lines that were shown before
are gone now let me just make this quite
smaller so you can see that very well
if I run this
you're gonna see that it's just a square
there's no lines on that so that's a
very basic way of how to create iframes
in HTML
now let's look into symbols in HTML so
let's say we want to display different
symbols like let's say the pounds sign
or the hero sign uh we want to display
more symbols like the copyright sign you
know Card Sign I'm going to explain what
I mean in a bit so if you want to
display all this stuff there is a
particular you know
syntax that you have to follow in HTML
so for example let's say in this body I
have a P tag I'm just gonna say
this is
0 sign
so I now want to display this sign of
the Euros currency for me to do this I'm
going to say and so I'm going to use
this and right here on my keyboard and
I'm going to say Evo
now if I run this you're going to see
that it displays the hero sign for me
that didn't display the Euro sign and
that's because we didn't have this
semicolon so we must make sure we have a
semicolon now you're going to see that
it displays the hero sign now there is
more and more that we can do and I'm
going to go through most of them so for
example let's say we want to have you
know
um something like
the copyright sign so the copyright sign
what we need to do is to do and I'm
gonna do hashtag
and we're gonna do 169
. the note that it must end with this
semicolon if not it's not going to work
so once I run this you're going to see
that we have the copyright sign now
there's a lot like we can have the
registered sign is similar to this but
it is 174 and once I run this you're
gonna see that we have this R sign so we
can also have like the you know the
signs on the card like the Spade they
are to the diamond and all of that so
first to do this right here let's say I
want to have the Spade sign I'm just
gonna have nine a
two four and this is gonna show the
space sign on a card as you can see
and if I want to have the clubs I'm
going to do 9827
right that's going to show the clubs and
let's say I want to have the Arts I'm
going to do 9829 that's going to show
the hidden art and if I want to have the
diamond I'm gonna do nine eight and
three so once I run that we're gonna see
that that shows that for us now there is
a lot like let's do one more for example
I could trademark we're gonna just
change it to 8 4
2.
so once you change this you're going to
see that we have the Trademark Sign TM
so this is just a basic way basic syntax
of you know showing symbols in HTML
now there's a lot of you know all of
this and you don't have to know this off
by how you can just search on Google
HTML symbol for displaying the you know
the pound sterling sign for displaying
the pi sign anything you want to do you
can just search on Google I don't advise
actually knowing all of this off by her
so that is what that is how to you know
create symbols or show symbols in HTML
now let's talk about forms in HTML so a
forms is a way you can collect input
from a user so when you collect the
input from a user these forms are mostly
sent to like a server for you know
processing or whatever the data is
needed for for example let's say you go
to a website and you want to log into
that website you're going to see that
there is a simple form where you're fill
in your username and your password then
you click on submit and that data is
being sent to a server that checks
whether your username and password are
actually in the database of users so the
basic reason why we are form in HTML is
to collect data from user so let me show
you how we can Implement a form in HTML
so the first thing you need to know is
the form tag so I'm going to remove this
and I'm actually going to just start by
saying form
and when I close it it's going to close
by itself
so now this form tag is HTML knows that
we're trying to create a new form so
it's going to have like an input like an
input bar where a user can input you
know something
but now they are more to just this form
than only the in the just the element so
we need to
have the input element also so the input
element is used to display what type of
form or what type of data we want to
collect so for example let's say I have
inputs this is how we type input
and then we close it like this
right and what we can just do is to it's
going to collect various attributes but
the most important one is the type
so as I said it shows or it specifies
what type of data we are trying to
collect so let's say I just want to
collect a text I'm going to input text
in here and I can run that
so once I run this you're going to see
that we just have this simple bar right
here where I can input a text right
I can also have an input that just you
know collects numbers so let's say input
type
or we can say number if I close that and
I saved it I run this
you can see now that we have these two
buttons here which can help us increment
and decrement the number so this only
collects numbers so with this basically
tells us like what we actually want to
you know
input what type of data we want to input
in here
so let's first of all look into this
text field very well
before we go into the order of fields
I mean this text type
so for example whenever we have an input
right we must always have a label beside
it so right here where we have this bar
if we don't have something saying input
your name or name or username the user
is not going to know what to input
that's where the label comes in so we
have a label
and we close that label and here we can
just say name
so here where we have name we can now
say input type text so I can run this
and you see it just says name and it has
the bar bit beside it so let's say I
want to leave a space and I want this to
be on the bottom I can just add a br tag
and I can run this
so you're going to see that it's now on
the bottom
but now the name the input needs more
stuff than just you know the type like
we need to know the ID and the name of
that particular input so whenever a data
is being sent from this HTML on from
this HTML form right it's been sent
using the name of that particular input
if there's no name there is no way a
data can actually be collected by the
server so we need to specify the name
right of this input I can just say the
name of this input is username right
and we also need to specify like an ID
now we use this ID just to be able to
recognize or to be able to refer to this
particular input within our HTML page so
I can also say the ID is something like
a username I can give it the same
name
now for this label I want this label to
actually be linked to this particular
input because for all I know right now
there are just two different elements
but what I want to do is that I want
HTML this our you know code to know that
this label is for this particular user
input so for me to do that it's fairly
easy I'm just need to gonna need to have
an attribute here that says four
and we're going to say for username
you see we said that by using the
attribute that we already you know
defined here so if we run this that is
not going to make much of a difference
but now we know that this label is for
this input now let's do the same thing
for let's have another form
let me just have a br
and let me have a label
I'm going to close that label and let me
say you know h
let me just say it's cool
right
and I'm going to have a four but for now
I'm just going to leave it blank so
let's quickly create
an input for that
let's say input and then we're going to
have a type
and the type of that input is also going
to be text
and let's give it a name
of school
and also an ID
obscure
now I'm gonna say this is for school
now once I run this I'm going to see
that I have another particular
field right there so that is the basic
way of doing that now let's look into
another type of input like we've talked
about text but what if we want to talk
about like another type like let's say
check boxes right so let me come in here
and I'm just gonna remove
this particular
input so this input where it says type
text I'm going to change our text to
check box
and I'm going to give it an ID of
username same username and let me just
say the value
is something like
um let's just say Tommy so I want the
user to check if you know this is its
value and I can just give it another one
and say right here I can just remove all
of this right and I can just have this
and copy it so it's basically the same
thing but with a different type
so now I'm gonna say name this is
another username we can say username two
username two
and let's say team
right now if I run this you're going to
see what it gives us
so you can see that it gives us name and
it also gives us name so what I want to
do actually is right here
oh no I've told me
I want to have team
so once I run this I want the user to
pick which one is your username is your
username told me then ticket is it team
or is it both of it you know then take
any of it right so that that is fixed
right there and what you just need to
know is that whenever the value is being
sent for example if a user ticks told me
or it takes both of it the value that is
being sent is not this value that shows
here it's actually the you know the
value that we specified as an attribute
in here right so whenever a user clicks
on submit we're also going to talk about
the submit button soon when the exact
clicks on submit that all the data is
going to be taken from here and sent to
whatever server we want it to be sent to
but the value that is actually going to
be sent is this value that we specified
here
now we can do exactly the same thing for
like radio buttons so very similar to
what we just did but what we're just
going to do is instead of checkbox we're
going to say radio
instead of checkbox we say radio
if I run this now you're going to see
that it prints to me but this time
around it is like a radio button so that
is fairly easy to understand
right so the next thing I want to talk
about is actually submitting this data
so let me remove this right here and let
me move this BR let's just make it look
good
it doesn't look confusing now once we
run this this you just have it beside it
so we can pick with the one we want
now that we have that I want that
whenever a user now clicks on submit one
actually I'm going to submit a button
this is the easiest what we just need to
do let's first have our BR tag right
here so
it doesn't collide
we can just we're just gonna have
another input
but this time around what we just need
to do is to say type
submit once we say type submit
HTML knows that we want to have the
submit button that means the button that
whenever a user clicks on this it's
sending all those data or those inputs
somewhere
but now we also need to have
a value let me run this first and see
what it shows you can see that
automatically write submits there but
what if I don't want this to be submit
let's say I want it to be you know send
then I can do value
and I can say send
if I run this you can now see that that
submit button has been changed to send
now that is how easy it is for you to do
that
but now where is this data actually
being sent to like when we use send
remember I said for this radio and
checkbox it's not actually this told me
that is being sent is the value that we
specified here that has been sent but
when we click on send where is it being
sent to
now this is when we need to add an
attribute to the initial form
now this attribute is called action this
action will tell us where the data is
meant to be sent to so again when you
say action
equals now let's say we want to send
this data to another page imagine we add
another page like let's say something
like
um
um
form.html right we can create that
and we want this to be sent to that form
dot HTML once we hit send that is going
to be sent to form.html basically so you
can also like send it anywhere you want
to send it to you let's say you have a
web application you're building and we
can say we want to send it to like slash
receive you know you can do anything you
want to but this action basically
specifies the place or the URL or watch
over link is getting
that particular form where you want to
send that particular form to so that is
fairly easy and that's how to easily do
that
the first thing we need to know let's go
through what we just did so the first
thing that we did was to create our form
element and then we created different
labels and inputs I showed you the types
and I showed you how to use the submit
button and once you have the submit
button I also showed you how to add the
action so that you actually know where
it's going to
but now that we know where he's going to
right where we put in this action let's
say from dot HTML
we also want to know what method is
being used to send this data now you
don't need to know the details of what
I'm about to say but there are basically
two methods that we can use to submit a
data and it's called get and post
so when submitting a data you can choose
to either submit it using get and post
you can learn more about that you know
on YouTube anyway if you want to know
but for example you can just specify
method equals post so let me just show
you the the quick difference between get
and post when you are sending the data
using a get method all the details of
the data that you're sending is going to
be shown in the URL bar for example if I
say something on Google and I hit enter
everything I searched the key word I
search is going to be shown in the URL
bar right that's when you use a get
meter well if you use a post method it's
not going to be shown they also just a
lot of differences between the two but
that's just one difference that you know
I can use to easily explain it so you're
going to pick whatever method you want
to use to send this data you can use
post or we can use get
if you don't use any method imagine you
don't specify any attribute right here
as default HTML you're going to use a
get method to submit that data but for
us let's just specify it and say we can
say get so it's that easy you just need
to you know some you need to specify the
method the action so that everything
works perfectly
so I hope you understand everything we
did about this HTML forms is fairly easy
and you know I hope you were able to
follow along
so earlier in this tutorial I said that
I was going to show you how to actually
create an HTML file and run it in your
browser so I'm going to show you how to
do it locally on your computer
so what you need to do is to open a code
editor right here I am in future Studio
code but you can use any one you want
you can use Sublime Text you can even
use a notepad anything that can make you
write code and you are comfortable with
you can use it so once you have your
code editor opened I'm just going to
create a new file right here and let me
name this file index.html
now whenever you're creating an HTML
file it must have this dot HTML
extension at the end you can name this
whatever you want to name it let's say
test you know let's say
website.html you can name it whatever
you want but it must have this dot HTML
at the end I'm going to create that file
and I'm just going to create it in this
particular folder now that I have this
file created in here I cannot code
anything I want to code but let's say
I'm just going to come here and copy all
of this code that we did here and I'm
going to paste it right
so once I have this code in here I've
created all my HTML everything I want to
do now what I can do is to now run this
on my browser for me to do this I'm
going to come into the folder where I
created that and I'm just going to open
index.html
so automatically when you open that
index.html file it's going to open it on
your browser and show you the result of
what you are coding
so earlier I talked about the uh the
title so we tried to create a title here
but it wasn't showing just because we
are using like this browser right here
and not an you know an actual page but
now that we have the page you can see
that this is my page title is showing
now if I go back to this you know code
and let's say I change this to
test title
and whatever I change in here once I
refresh you can see that that title is
now test title so that is an easy way of
actually coding you know HTML files or
doing it locally then showing the result
on your browser
in this section of this course we're
going to be looking into CSS so CSS
stands for cascading style sheets now
what it does is that it allows you to
add styling to your HTML page
now I'm going to take you from a
beginner's level to a level where you
can confidently use CSS to style your
HTML code
now without wasting any time let's
actually get straight into this section
so now we know that CSS is what we use
to basically style everything we do in
our HTML so but how do we actually even
you know create a CSS file how do we let
that CSS file be linked to this
particular HTML file and I'm going to
show you how to do that so first of all
to create a CSS file you need to create
a file named style.css so first of all
right
we are using replay so rapidly
automatically created this file these
three files for us but right now we're
going to be looking more into this
style.css so I'm just going to drag it
over here
so
style.css is basically a CSS file that
we're going to be using
on this HTML file right here so you can
name it whatever you want you can name
it you know main.css but whenever you're
creating a CSS file it must have this
dot CSS extension toory
so now that we know that we have that
how do we actually connect this CSS file
to this particular HTML file right here
now this is very easy we're going to use
a HTML element called link so right here
we need to say link
and we're going to close it like this
that is how we close this side and it's
going to take two different attributes
the first one is going to be real and
that is going to say that this is a
style sheet that I will link into we're
going to say style sheet
and what's it going to have to say the
name of that style she thought the link
to that style sheet so right now we are
just gonna use the name of that
particular CSS file because on this
replay right all of these are Under the
same folder so we can just simply say
the name of the file instead of saying
you know folder slash whatever because
we have it in the current folder so I'm
just going to say style dot CSS now once
I say this anything I'm any CSS I code
in here anything I try to do in here is
automatically going to be added to this
particular you know page it's going to
be effective
now now that you know how to do that I'm
going to start straight into the main
CSS so I'm going to talk about you know
the CSS syntax like how does it even
work how do we even start coding in CSS
so to write code in CSS we need to know
two things and they are called the
selector and the Declaration
so as you can see right here
automatically replay as this basic CSS
code and what this does right so this
HTML right here as you can see
it is the selector so first of all I'm
just gonna let me just remove this HTML
and just have body don't need to worry
about it I'll come out for now so we
have this body right here and that is a
selector and then all of these were
saying the height of body should be 100
the weight of body should be 100 don't
worry about the details of what this
does for now but let me just introduce
you to how we write code in CSS so this
is the selector right and this is the
Declaration now this means that this
body
we want whatever we are doing inside
here to be affected on this body element
so what this is going to do now it's
going to go into whatever HTML is linked
to it and it's going to look for your
body element so it's going to come here
and it's going to look for this body
element right once it sees this body
element
he's gonna say whatever we do inside
these brackets we want to have it been
affected on this body element without
wasting any time let me show you how to
do you know our first change
so let me just get rid of this and let's
actually do something so I'm going to
use the body again let me say body
this is how we write a CSS code so we
say the elements right that we want to
change and then we use this curly braces
and you press enter
now anything you do in here is going to
be affected with the HTML or whatever
file is being linked to it so now our
same body now there are different
declarations the Declaration can be we
want the color to be you know red we
want this whatever font size in there to
be you know 15 we can do a lot of things
I'm going to go through all of that in
this section of this course so first of
all let me just show you how you can
change the background color of the body
to be let's say blue or red so first of
all you know that this body is where all
the code goes into that means everything
we're going to be coding in our HTML is
going to be under this body the visible
part of the web page so now we want the
visible part of the web page to have a
background color of let's say Green
Let's Make a green so what we're going
to do now we're going to say body now
whatever we're doing here which you
should know now is the Declaration we're
going to say background this is how you
change the background color background
hyphen color
and we want that to be green
and then you must add this semicolon now
the reason why we must add this
semicolon is so that we can have another
declaration right here let's say I want
to change the font size I can write
something else if you don't add that
semicolon it's going to think that
whatever you add here is still part of
this first declaration
so you must add the semicolon to end
that declaration so this is how you're
doing background color which is what we
want to change you put your colon and
then you put the value so think of this
as a key and this is a value
now let's run this and see
so we're going to run this
as you can see now the background color
of this is green so it is effective
immediately
now let's check what if let's say I
remove this right
I'm just going to delete this that means
this HTML page is not linked to this
style.css now if we try to run it you're
going to see now that it doesn't show us
a background color of green normal and
that's just to show you that no matter
what you write in your CSS page if you
don't connect it or link it to your HTML
page it's not going to be effective
so now let's remove bring that back
and when we run this again we should
have the background color as green
now let's talk about comments in CSS so
when we're looking into HTML earlier in
this course I talked about comments in
HTML and in there I talked about why we
use comments what it is and you know how
we can actually code that in uh file so
in CSS it's very similar to HTML the
motive for using a comment is you might
want to explain a bunch of code or you
might want to just remove a part of a
code that you don't want to be run when
your file is run basically let's say I
have this CSS file here so if I comment
out all of this body the code is still
going to be present in this file but
it's not actually going to be effective
so it's not going to be run by the
browser so let me show you how to add a
comment right here in CSS
so we talked about it in HTML but it's
quite different here so let's say I want
to explain what this you know code does
I can add a comment and to have a
comment and I'm going to have to use the
forward slash then I'm going to use the
asterisk sign
and here I'm going to write my comment
let me just say comment for now
and then for me to close that comment
because right here you can see that CSS
still sees this as a normal code due to
the colors I'm Gonna Leave a space a
steric mark and I'm gonna use the
forward slash again now you can see that
that part is grayed out
you can see that the color is gray so
this just shows that this is a comment
right here and I can just write
something in here like changes
the
background
color
of body
right so that is explaining this code
right here now that is a
one use of you know comments you might
also want to use a comments like let's
say we have another thing that just you
know let's say another iterative or
something like that and he has a value
right and then I just want to comment
this up I can do exactly the same thing
I'm just going to have the forward slash
I'm gonna have the asterisk sign right
here I have the asteric sign and the
forward slash again so that part is
still going to be in this code but the
web browser is not going to run it when
you actually run that file so that is
those are the main two uses of comments
but apart from just using it to you know
adding it on top of like let's say a
code you can add it somewhere else let's
say we have different you know
declarations right here let's say we
have second declaration third
declaration that's just an example and
we want to explain each declaration by
themselves so we can have a comment
right beside this particular declaration
let me get rid of this so right here I
can just have a comment here that says
you know
change
to Green
so for me to do this I have to add the
forward slash steric sign
and right here you have to do the same
thing
I'm just gonna do
steric sign and forward slash so you
cannot see that that part is greater let
me just make this something like this so
that is now a comment right
so that's the easy way of you know using
comments in CSS is quite easy
like when you're learning programming
well you're going to notice that if you
learn other programming language each
programming language has a different way
of writing comments but the motive
behind using comments is the same in all
your programming languages now you can
also have multiple line comments for
example instead of just having one
straight line I can create a new comment
right here
and I can just say
comment
uh-huh I can go to another line continue
writing the comment
yeah okay just something random and then
I can close it right here
so you can see that all of that has been
commented out so it doesn't just have to
be a straight line so that means I can
even comment out all of this code you
know you can basically be very flexible
with your comment you can do whatever
you want to do
so that is a very simple and basic way
of using comments in CSS
now let's talk more about selectors in
CSS so earlier in this course I told you
about how the syntax of CSS work that
this is the selector right here and this
is the Declaration but now let's look
more into how these selectors actually
work how we can pick different elements
from HTML and style it so say the CSS
selector is divided into different
categories but first of all I'm going to
break down in I'm going to break
everything down right now so once again
CSS selectors they're basically used to
select HTML elements that you want to
style right so it's very easy the first
way to just
have a selector is to come into your
HTML and look at the let's say we have
an H1 right here
I we want to look at the elements right
and then we're going to come in here and
just write the element right there we
can just say on H1 tag we want the
background color to be green so we've
basically selected that H1 tag very easy
and very plain now we can select
an element or we can decide to style a
text or something else without selecting
the actual element we can select an ID
in that element so remember when we add
when we did a form and then we add an ID
as an attribute now you can have an ID
not just only in a form input you can
have it on any HTML element you want for
example I can add this ID and say the ID
is welcome message
welcome so now that this has an idea of
Welcome right I can come in here
and then select this all this particular
elements just by the ID so what I need
to do to do this is to come in here
instead of just writing it directly I
need to write hashtag now once I put an
hashtag CSS automatically knows it's
trying to select an element by
identifying its ID
so what you just need to do now is to
write the name of that ID now CSS is
going to go into this HTML file and it's
going to look for an element with the ID
of welcome and then it's going to make
the background color green now let's run
this and let's see what it gives us boom
you can now see that the background
color of that old element is green
so that's a very simple way of using an
ID and this is also very you know
very useful now let me explain a use
case for example let's say we have two
different H ones
and this one says
Tommy
and if I run this
you can now see that only I is as an ID
of green I mean it has a background
color of green now imagine I didn't use
an ID and I just use H1 this is going to
affect every single H1 type that we have
here so it's going to have all the H on
as green but what if I want just I to be
green or just told me to be green that
is a use case of using the ID to select
it because the ID is unique to every
single element so that is also very very
useful
so now that is one way of doing that
let's run that again and see everything
is working another way of selecting an
element or a text or whatever you want
to style is to select it by the class so
there is something named classes in HTML
and this class is also an attribute
right it also identifies a particular
element so once you have a class in an
HTML element you can then use that to
select that particular element and style
it
so just the way we have an ID we can
have a class here
just the normal way we write HTML
attributes you write class and then you
give it a value
so let's say this class we want this
class to be something like
adding so that is the name of this class
so now we can select just this class and
say we want to style all of this
for you to do that now let's actually
just create another you know
declaration selection and declaration so
first you do this now we want to select
this particular element using its class
so we're gonna do Dot
adding
so this is the selector
when you see dot something that means
we're selecting an element based on its
class
so this means
we are trying to select a class and this
is the name of the class and now we can
just say we want the color
of whatever is there
to be blue
and we can use a semicolon to stop that
now once I run this you should see that
it has a color of blue just this one and
that is because it has been seen or it
hasn't selected just by the class now
this is very helpful right
so you can also do like more advanced
stuff with this for example let's say
there are two different let's say there
are two different elements that has a
class of adding so let's say we have p
and this just say told me small or let's
just say Tommy again and this also has a
class
of Eden
if I run this
this is going to show
a smaller tell me but it also it is also
affected because you selected it by the
adding so anyone that has a class of
adding is going to have this blue color
on it
but let's say we just want to say just
the H1 tag that has a class of adding
should be blue
so that means we don't just want to get
every single element that has a class of
edging just an H1 tag that has a class
of adding now for us to do this what
we're going to do right here beside the
dot we're going to say H1 so now what
this is going to do is that it's going
to go into the H1 element and it's going
to look for any H1 elements that has a
class of adding now if I run this you're
going to see that that P is not affected
no more this is just black but this is
still blue
that is a very good a good example of
how you can do this
now there's also one more thing and this
is the universal selector
so the universal selector is basically a
selector that affects every single
element in the HTML page so let me show
you what I mean so let's say
I want every element on this page to
just have a color of red every single
element should be read
for me to do this I'm going to use the
asterisk sign
if I use the asterisk sign and have my
curly braces normally like this this
means that whatever I'm writing in here
is going to be affected by every single
element with no one left out so now I
can just say color
I can say purple
so let me just get rid of this
and now let me run this
so you're going to see that every
element on it has a color of purple
that's because we use this asterisk sign
also known as the universal selector
now this is you know a very good use
case because you might just be building
a page and you want that page to you
know let's say all the text should be in
the center you can use this to do it
right so that is a very good one so the
last one I'm actually going to talk
about is the grouping selector remember
when we first started this CSS video
there was like uh HTML and body
something that was written like this and
I got rid of one because I said we're
going to talk about that later so now
what this is is called the grouping
selector let me get rid of all of this
right and let's say I have an H1 tag on
each one selector
that says you know
color
and let's say green
and then I have a P tag
a p selector that says color
green also
right as you can see I'm just repeating
the same thing if I run this
it's gonna have green all of it because
these two are H1 and this is p
now I'm repeating the same particular
you know declaration for two different
elements now instead of having to write
all of this because let's say I have a
lot of elements and I want all of them
to be green I and I have to start
writing H1 color green P color green you
know B color green
strong color of green we don't want to
do that you can actually just come in
here have a comma and say p
so this means that for the H1 and P
element do this
now once I run this you're gonna see
that that has been affected on this so
that is a more broader explanation on
selectors what they are and how you can
actually use them
now we are going to look more into
backgrounds in CSS so we I briefly
showed you how you can have this as a
how you can let this have a background
of like red or purple or whatever you
want it to have but they're actually
more to talk about in backgrounds in CSS
so like we can make a particular element
of a background color we can make that
element have even a background image so
let's say we just want this part to have
like a background image where an image
will be debugger or we can just make the
old page to have a background image so
there are you know lots of other stuffs
we can do and we're going to talk about
them now so first of all let's just make
this the body right
and in here instead of just saying color
green we actually want to say background
color
so similarly to what we've done before
and once I just click on run the whole
background is going to be green that is
very easy and simple right
but there are also more stops we can do
than just this for example instead of
just having green let's say we want to
have blue and instead of just having a
normal blue we can say we want it to be
light blue
if I say light blue you can see the it's
going to be light blue compared to the
normal blue so there's a lot of stuff
you can do and I like replay because it
automatically just gives you a lot of
suggestions once you say blue you see
all the blues that it has so you can
also go online to search like what color
of blue do we have you can see medium
slate blue
you can run that it's going to be that
particular blue color so you can go
online and search all CSS colors or css
acceptable colors you can see a list of
it and you know you pick which one you
want to pick
now that is one right and there's
another thing we can do by adding an
opacity or making it more transparent
basically so we there is a opacity
declaration that we can add and it's
going to make this you know a bit
lighter or a bit more transparent for
you to do this is very easy you're just
going to say opacity
and let's say we want it to be 0.4
so you can make it all the way from zero
to one that is the range so the lower
the value the more transparent it's
going to be if I say 0.4 you're going to
see that it's quite transparent right
but let me say 0.1
you're gonna see
that is very transparent but what if I
just say 0.9
you're gonna see that is opaque very
opaque so you can do that and you know
that's how to just have a transparency
on your background colors
now let's just go straight into talking
about background images so for example
let's say I don't want this to be a
background color and I want it to be an
image
so since we know that we've already
selected the body now if we add anything
it's going to affect the old page now
let's just do that real quick
now first you have a background image
quite similar instead of writing
background color we just change our
color to image so I'm going to say
background
iPhone image
and now we're going to have to specify
the URL where we want this image to come
from right the source URL so if I I have
a link copied I'm going to paste that so
that is the link right there and it just
opens the an image of the free codecamp
logo so I'm gonna just copy that again
and I'm gonna close that
so since we know we have the URL to the
Africa Camp logo what we just need to do
now to tell CSS where to get that image
from is to say URL
and then we're just gonna have a
brackets and we're gonna have the codes
and in that codes we're going to paste
the link to that image so if I run this
you're gonna see that the background of
this is actually that free codecamp
image so as you can see the text don't
show but they're actually there they
don't show just because
the background is black and the text is
black so now that we know CSS what we
can just do is to say you know this is
H1 and P you can say H1 we can use group
selector h1p and then we can just say we
want the color
to be white
now once I run this again
the text should show exactly so you can
see that that works this is just the
background image this doesn't really
have any effect on it what this is the
text that is still showing the next
thing that we want to talk about is the
background position so for example let's
say we just have a background image that
you know is very small and it just stops
here right we can have a background
position and say we want it to be at the
top right corner so we're going to do
background
I've in position
and we can just say we want the position
of that to be at the top right so we can
say right
I want you to be at the right
and then we're going to leave a space
and say top
so this means that it's going to be at
the right corner but the top of that
right corner so that's what that does
so now that we have all of that that's
the very basic way of you know having
background images in CSS
now we are going to look into margins in
CSS so margins are used to create
spacings around elements so for example
when I have this let me change the color
of this to Black
I'm gonna run this so
it should show the text let's say I want
this P tag to have a margin of let's say
or let's say I want this tag to be
somewhere around here instead of just
from the beginning I want it to be here
that's when we use margin so we can
specify the like space we want from the
left side from the right side from the
top I can also bring it down and I can
also like take it up so that's what
margins does it basically allows you to
create like spaces around elements now
there are different ways we can specify
the margins as I said we have the margin
top we have the margin right we have the
margin bottom and the margin left so
each of that I just used to specify the
spacing for whatever we want we want it
to be if you want there to be a space at
the top we use the margin top we want
them to be a space at the right with the
margin right for the bottom margin
bottom and for left margin left
so now let's just go straight into this
so I'm going to remove this H1 and we're
just going to have p so automatically it
has a color of black we don't need to
write that
so what I can just do now is to say
imagine
is how I write it ifin let's say left
once I say imagine left then now when I
want to give it a value now there are
different values we can give it we can
specify how far we want it to be like in
in actual numbers like I can say 20 PX
now if I run this you're going to see
that once I run it there's going to be a
space on the left you can see that it
moved a little bit so you can keep going
like that with numbers right right I can
say well 50 now
if I say 50 and I run it you're gonna
see that it's gonna move again a little
bit so that means I've created a space
of 50px
from the left right I can do the same
thing on the right the top and the
bottom so that is one way of specifying
the value another way I can specify a
value is by using a percentage so I can
just specify it by saying 50 percent
and once I run that you're gonna see
that it has it in the middle so what it
what the percentage does is that it
calculates the old width of the you know
element and it puts it in like from 50
so this side is 50 of this o width so
that is why we have it there so that's
for the percentage what I can just do
now is to actually show you what more I
can do like I can say instead of having
50 I can say 50 PX
so I can specify this was just for the
left if I run it it's going to have
space in here I can also say I want
there to be margin
on the top if I say margin top and I
also say 50
the X
now if I run this
you're gonna see now that they it came
down a little bit there's now more space
here now I can also do the same thing
and say imagine
right
I say 50px
right so I'm saying the margin right
should have 50px not going to really
show any difference because there's
nothing is actually
um like moving from relative to it like
for the left is moving 50px relative to
this border from the top is moving 50px
relative to this you know this H1 tag
but there's nothing here so that's why
it doesn't really move right well I can
also say imagine
bottom
and I can see 50px now once again it
shouldn't move that's just because
there's nothing is moving relative to
this right so that's how it's going to
be and once we have that we basically
know that we can specify what particular
you know side we want it to move from so
instead of writing all of this right
here you can see that this is quite a
lot of code just you know to make some
spacing you can actually compress all of
this into one so what I mean is that
let's say I get rid of all of this
I can just actually make this one so I
can say imagine
and I can say it's going to have a value
of let's say 50 PX 50 PX 50 BX and 50px
so what this does is that instead of
having to write margin left margin right
all of that it just uses this to say
this first 50px is the top margin this
second one is the right margin this
third one is the bottom margin and this
is the left margin so you can compress
all of this into just one line of code
or css automatically knows what they
stand for so you should also know that
the first one is the top second one is
the right third one is the bottom and
fourth one is the left so if I run this
you're going to see that there's still
some space in the same spacing as the
same margins as we said before
now that is for you know if you want to
specify four of it but let's say you
just want to have three margins now what
does this mean this just basically mean
this represents the top this represents
the right and this represents the bottom
so I'm going to run this
and you see that we still have the same
thing I can do exactly the same thing
and just have two margins
and you should have guessed by now this
just basically represents
but this is quite different right this
represents the top and the bottom margin
right and this represents the right and
the left margin so that means it's
basically the same thing as saying 50px
four times because this 50px represents
both default the top and four and bottom
and this is the right and left if I run
this it's going to be the same obviously
and you can also just have one margin if
I have just one margin what this does is
that this 50px represents all of the
four margins so top right bottom left
this 50px represented and once I run
this you are going to see that it
basically has that the way it is
so there's also one more way we can
specify emergence we can say inherit so
let me explain what this inherit does so
if I come in here and let's say I have
this p
right under let's say a div tag
if I have this P under a div tag right
uh let's just say something like a b tag
so let's say this B this p is under this
B type and I come in here and I'm I
actually you know
style that b tag and let's say I say
imagine
top
is something like 50px
let's say 60px xcpx so since this P tag
is under this B tag that means I can
inherit right I can inherit this margin
from that beta so if I want to specify
margin top
and I don't want to actually like start
writing I can just in input in edit and
what's our input inherit is going to
have the same margin top as this B and
when I say in edit what CSS is going to
go into it's going to go into HTML and
it's going to look for the tag that this
is under so since it's under a b tag
it's going to come back in here and see
the margin top on that b tag and it's
going to do the same thing for this now
if I run this let's see what it gives us
you can see that we only have a margin
on the top so that is a simple way or
basic way of using margins in CSS
now we're going to talk about borders in
CSS now what I mean by borders is
basically like a wrapper for a
particular element so for example if you
want there to be like a square on this
element that's when we use a border so
without wasting any time let me just
show you how we actually use borders
so there are different styles of borders
you can have uh or just a simple
rectangle wrapped around this or you can
make it dotted or just dashes I'm going
to show you what we're gonna do to do
that so I'm gonna get rid of this B
and on this P tag what I'm just gonna do
right now is I'm gonna say
I'm gonna get rid of this I don't need
this and I'm just gonna say
for the
Style
now once I say border style CSS now
knows that I'm trying to put a border
around this particular P tag so now
there are various Styles I'm going to
talk through every single one of them so
let me first put
dotted
now once I put dotted and run it you're
gonna see that there's a border around
this that is dotted now that's the
simple way of doing that actually let me
just change this to the H1 just so you
can see it better
so now we are talking about the H1 tags
good so as you can see that is what it
does very simple now there's a lot of
different styles that we can use and I'm
gonna talk about all of them right now
so the first one is dotted there's
another one named solid so if I change
this to solid
and I run it you're just going to see
that it's going to have a solid body
around it a normal square is not dotted
it's just a normal line so if I didn't
explain this border style is just a way
to to actually put a border around this
particular element and that border style
this particular style
says or asks for us to put the value of
the style that we want so before we put
dotted now we put solid so this is what
this solid brings if I put let's say
apple there's another one named Groove
once I put Groove and run it you're
gonna see that it basically shows a boy
like more Slimmer just a normal line and
is more fade compared to the solid now
if I put dashed
and I run dashed
you're gonna see that it's not dotted is
like a dash dash you know with spacing
between it and I can also put W just
going through what you can use as your
butter
is similar to groove but let's say more
thicker than that now I can also put
reach
by pull rage and run it
you're gonna see that is how that looks
like there's another one named outset
outset and inset and once I run this
outset as you can see it basically gives
you like this highlighter of this
particular you know elements now once I
say inset
when I run inset
you're gonna see that it's just the
opposite of that the top a thick and the
other parts are not thick so what if
let's say you don't want to
uh you don't want the butter you don't
actually want to have a border that's
when you just use none
if I run none you're not going to see
anybody just gonna be there right
unless I want to have a border but I
don't want you to show it's basically
give you the same result as none but
this is eating so it basically like has
a border but it's not showing now once I
run that
you see that nothing changes okay then
that's just simply because we use Eden
now let's say you want to mix different
types of borders like let's say you want
this top to be dashed you want the
bottom border to be solid you want this
part to be double you know we can do
that what you just need to do is to
basically specify what you want so for
example the right here where we have
this value hidden what you're just going
to do is to say and say dashed
double
dotted
and solid
now if I run this you're gonna see that
each of these stands for different ones
so I'm just gonna
expand this right here just so you can
see it so you can see that the first one
which is dashed is right here that's for
the top
and this uh double as you can see is the
one right here
double is the one right on the right
and when you say dotted that represents
the bottom and it says solid that
represents the left so this is
top right bottom left so that's just how
you can mix different ones together if
you want and once you know how to do
that that's basically the basics of
actually you know inputting a border in
uh in CSS
but they are more to that like what if
we actually want to be more flexible
with this what you want to be more
Dynamic with this that we want this to
be like our own design so for example
let's say we want the width of this to
be larger so first of all let me just
change all of this to
solid
and now let's say I want this to have a
width let me first run that so you can
see the output of that and let's say I
want this to be quite bigger like I
don't want it to be this small I can say
butter
I think with
and I can say 10px
and if I run that you're gonna see that
this is quite thicker I can change that
to let's say 6px
just to reduce the thickness
as you can see it is less thicker so
that is one way of giving up value to
the width with the other ways we can
also give values just the way we when we
we're dealing with margins we could give
value with six with numbers we could
also give value with inherit and all of
that but in this one we can give values
with PX
and we can also give values with you
know the rate like for example I can say
medium
now if I say medium
this means it's gonna be thick me you
know medium or we can just also say
thick if I say thick
it's just going to be very sick that's
what it is so you can use that to
basically specify the you know the width
of the border that you want it's very
easy
but what if we want to actually just
specify different side width like let's
say we just want only this part to be
5px then we want this part to be you
know 10 PX then we want this part to be
11 PX we can do that now the first thing
you need to do just the way we could mix
different styles we can also mix
different width so what we're gonna do
is we're going to specify for the top we
can say the top should have 10 PX
and then we're going to specify for the
right we can say the right should have
5px I'm going to specify for the bottom
part you can say the bottom part should
have let's say 11px and then for the
left part we can say if you have 22 PX
now if I run this
you're just going to see there is a
mixture of different width in the Border
Lines so that is how to do that
but you can also split it evenly so for
example you can
imagine I have just two different you
know PX
two different sizes put here what this
is going to do is that it's going to
take this 10px and input it for the top
and the bottom and it's going to take
its 5px and you put it for your left and
right it's gonna split it evenly so as
you can see left and right has 5px top
and bottom as 10 PX now that is a very
simple and basic way of doing that
now after specifying the width of what
we want we can also add the color let's
say we don't want this to be black we
want this to be you know you know Green
we want I want this to be purple what
you just need to do as you might have
guessed is to say border color
and once you say border color you can
just directly give it the color that you
want you can just say purple
and once we say purple we put our
semicolon if we run that you can now see
that it has purple
now once again we can have a mixture of
colors like we can want the top to be
green we can want this part to be purple
we can want this part to be Violet pick
out this part to be black now we're
going to do that right now so we're
going to say the top part should be
purple and let's say the right part
should be blue right side and then we're
going to say the bottom side is going to
be let's say green
and let's say
the left part should be red
now if I run this
you're gonna see so each should have a
mixture of different colors so okay
um the reason why that gave us an error
is because there shouldn't be comma in
there so what you just need to do is
when you're specifying different values
you don't actually use a comma I'm going
to remove get rid of this comma
get rid of that
get rid of that and once I run this
you're gonna see that there's a mixture
of colors as you can see all the borders
has different colors within them
so you can see that that is also you
know very easy to do
so instead of also just having like this
style for everything to be solid we can
basically I'm gonna remove all of this
and we can just say something to
style like only the top right so for
example I can say I want border
I think top iPhone style
so for this
you know instead of saying you know
before we we basically compress
everything into one where we say border
style and we could say Dash we could say
you know solid Ricochet dotted and
everything is just going to be split but
let's say you just want to have each of
them differently you can say this should
be dashed
and brother
I think you know you can say right so
I'll say dotted
I also say brother I think bottom
Style
now you can just say you know you can
give you the same thing let's say dotted
also
let's say brother
I've been left so
we can just say dashed
now if I run this you're gonna see that
is basically going to have different
you know once like this is Dash and this
is dotted this is dashed and this is
dotted so this is a long way of doing it
but the way I said already went with
this style like this and then we specify
different one by saying let's say dashed
and then we can just say dotted
you know so this is you know for the top
two the top and bottom and this is for
the left and right so this is the
shorter way of doing it like see how
compressed that is now
so I also highly suggest that you do
that instead of actually going
to do every single thing you know one
after the other
so that is
also a good one so for example so let's
say you want to have
a border but you don't want the border
to be a square you might just want it to
have a border on the left or on the
bottom on the top now what you can just
do very simple and straightforward you
can just say butter
for that bottom
and let's say dashed
now once you run dashed you're just
gonna have
a border on the bottom and it's going to
have dashed we can change this to border
left
and you're just going to have a dashed
border on the left like this
good now you know when we specify the
Border button I mean when we specify the
Border style the color you know the size
and all of that we can just do
everything at once like where I have
border left instead of saying border
left then I'm now going to say border
colored and border with what I can just
do is to First say
the width so I can say the width should
be 10 PX then I'm going to say the style
and then I'm going to say the color
let's say purple
now what this does is that it allows us
to just compress every all those code we
are going to write into one line so
instead of writing border with to have
the width where you can just have it
here and instead of writing border color
we can just have it here if I run this
you're going to see now that we have a
left you know border of all of this
so if I don't want this to just be left
I can just remove this you know
and now the old Border is gonna have all
of this
so that is very easy and straightforward
now the last thing we're going to talk
about is putting rounded borders so let
me change this back to solid
and when I change this to solid let's
see
now let me change this to something like
free
just want it to be smaller
cool now what I want to do is to make
this border rounded so if you look into
this particular repeat page you can see
that this basically has a border that is
rounded
but as you can see on these edges they
are not squared like the way this border
is squared these edges are actually
curved so that's a rounded border I'm
going to show you how to do that on
these edges very straightforward what
you just need to do is to say brother
hyphen radius
so now you're going to specify or you
know write our curve you want it to be
so let's go with 4px
we want it to be that curve and I run it
you're gonna see that it is curved for
PX
let's say 10px it's gonna be very curved
as you can see it is very curved so the
more you increase it the more it works
if I run it as 20px
now you can see that is more code so
that's basically how to do that and I
hope you understand everything now about
borders in CSS
now let's talk about CSS padding the
padding is used to create like a space
around an element or text inside any
border so for example let's say we have
this eye right here unless you want to
create a space like we want there to be
more spacing on top here and or below
here and also on the left that's when we
use padding
the first use padding is very easy for
example we'd already have this border
right here now let's say we want there
to be space on the top what you just
need to do is to say pattern
icon top
that easy then now I'm going to specify
how much we want the space to be you can
say 40px
and then once we run this we're now
going to see that there's gonna be a
space on the top of 40px we can do the
same thing by saying padding
left
and let's just say 40px
once you do that there's going to be a
space of 40px on the left and then you
can also say padding
you can say bottom
and then there's also going to be a
space of 40px on the bottom
so as you can see that works and you can
also do the same thing you know for the
right side
you can just change this bottom right
here
to write
but when you run that
doesn't really make any difference
because there's already a lot of space
here
now instead of having to write all of
this you know top left bottom right you
might have guessed just the way we did
everything for border and for margins
when we are doing margins you can just
say padding and then we can just specify
let's say 40 ex MPX
20px
answer apx
so once you say all of that this is
basically the 40px is for the top the
right is for 10px and 20px is for the
bottom and 30px is for the left now if I
run this you're gonna see that that is
going to work perfectly
now you can also do the same thing by
you know removing one when you remove
one this just simply means the top the
right and the Bottom now if I remove the
second one what this is going to is
going to split it evenly so 40 is going
to go to the top and the bottom and this
is going to go to the left and the right
if I run that you're gonna see what that
does
so that works successfully now let's say
I just have 40 in here
and I run this what this is going to do
is that it's going to left the left have
a pattern of 40 top 40 bottom 40 and
right 40. so just what we've been doing
for you know border for margins does the
exact same thing that happens here
so I hope you understand what is padding
and why we even use padding
now let's talk about height and weight
in CSS now the item which is just used
to set the item weight of a particular
element so let's get rid of this all the
borders
and let's just run this normally
so let's say we want this eye to have
like a not the actual element but you
know around the element the space around
the element to have a height of you know
let's say 60 PX so what you need to do
is just to come into H1 and say height
so you can say add and say 60px
so once you say that and you run it
right obviously you might not see any
change okay you can see a change now
this is the reason why we see a change
is because there is
now an height of 60px around this so
This starts from after that that's how
you can see the space in these two so
first actually see it visibly more let's
set the background color
so when we have a background color
of purple
and I run it you can see where the
distance of background color of purple
now the height of this is 60px I can
change this to 90 PX and when I change
this to 90 PX you can see that it now
has an a bigger height so this height is
basically the height of you know
everything around that particular
element now we can also change the width
and let's say I want the weight to also
be 90 PX now if this width is 90 PX and
we run it you're gonna see that the
width was reduced drastically
but let's say I just want this width to
go all the way from the beginning right
from here to the end of the page for me
to actually get the end of the page
because obviously I I might not know how
large any body screen is so like for
this screen I don't know if the end of
the page is 200 PX even if it's 200 PX
for another screen it might be 500 PX so
for me to get rid of that problem and
let it just be all the way to the end of
the screen what I just need to do is to
use percentage
so when I use 100 percentage
100 is not going to be calculating it
based on pixels or PX what is going to
calculate it based on is the percentage
of that screen so now once I run it
you're going to see that the width goes
all the way to the end of the screen so
it calculates the 100 of that screen if
I change this to 50 of that screen then
you're going to see that it only stops
at half of that screen right here
so that is a basic you know thing about
height and width now there's also
something called Max width and the max
width is just used to set the maximum
weight of an element it's that easy so
what you can just do now is right here I
can just say Max I think width if I say
Max width and I run this it basically
just set the maximum width of that
element it doesn't really make any
change that is noticeable but now we
know that the maximum with other
elements can have is 50 of the screen
now we are going to talk about outlines
in CSS
so what outline does is that it draws a
line outside a border in an element so
for example we have this Border in this
element right if we add an outline to it
it basically just draws a line outside
that particular border and what it does
is just it it just makes that element
stand out that's basically the main
reason of an outline so very very
similar to how we Define uh borders
that's how we also Define outlines so
let's say we have this border right here
actually we don't have a border this is
just a normal background color stuff we
can just get rid of this and I can say
outline
style so when I say outline Style just
the way we say border style that's how
we say outline style and I just want it
to be a normal solid
now if I run this
you're just gonna see that it has a
basic you know outline of solid
so it's very basic you can change this
to dashed
once I run this it's going to be dashed
you know you can change it to basically
whatever you want to change it to so
that is the basic you know concept of
outline it's very easy we don't need to
you know
you don't need to you have to put a
border or whatever you can use an
outline or a border or you can even use
both for example let's say we have
border right here we can say border and
let's say we just say it's 2px we can
say it is um let's say dashed and we can
say it is green
so if I run this you're gonna see that
we have our border normally but then we
have an outline after let me change this
to solid instead of dashed
so you can see that we have let me just
make this a little big
you can see that we have this Dash right
here this dashboarder but outside that
we have this outline so that's what an
outline does you just make that element
standard or it wraps around the
particular element so it's very easy and
you know very straightforward
but you can also do something
to get a space between the outline and
the Border and that is called the
outline offset so what you just need to
do is to come here and say outline
I think offset so once you have an
outline offset let's say 10px
that means we want a space of 10 PX
between the outline and the border so
that is what it just does right here
this is the outline and this is the
Border there's a space of 10px
so that's how straightforward outlines
are is very easy okay so this is the how
we basically Define outlines in CSS
now we're going to be diving deeper into
texts in CSS so I'm going to show you
everything you need to know on styling
text in CSS
I'm gonna get redeveloped this real
quick let me just run that again
so what we're gonna do first of all is
to talk about how to style the colors of
a text
so if you select an element and in that
element you declare
a color and give it a value of let's say
blue
that is going to give
the value the color of blue to all the
text in that element so that is the easy
way of changing a text in an element now
we've talked about this you know
previously a lot and this is just
emphasizing on that so whenever you just
say color and you give it a value it's
going to do for all the text in that
particular element and change it to Blue
now you can also you know talk about the
background color of a property but
that's basically the background color of
that text but not of the text actually
like we've also done this you can just
say background I think color and then
when you say background I think color
you can just simply say you know red and
it's going to give it a background color
of red
good that is easy and straightforward
now the next thing I'm going to talk
about is alignment so I'm going to get
rid of all these colors don't really
want to talk about the colors again now
what I want to talk about is the
alignment so what I mean by the
alignment is to show how aligned the
text is so for example if I want this
text to spin in the center or instead of
being at the left I want it to be on the
right that's when I use text alignment
so for me to align the text what I need
to do is to come into the element that
contains that text and what I'm just
going to do is to say text hyphen align
once I do a line I can say right
so I can specify three different things
left Center and right if I say right
you're going to see that all the H1 tags
the text in them goes to the right
if I say Center
you're going to see that they
automatically align at the center right
here
now I can say left but that is just
going to be default so as a default if
you don't give it a text alignment it's
just going to be at the left so if you
also align it to left it's just going to
be right there where you want it
now if I say justify let me change this
to justify
and I run this
now when you run it we justify it
doesn't really make any change but if I
come in here
and let's say
I change this to
random text
and I run this
so what justify does is that justify
basically stretches out each line so
that everyone every line has like equal
width and length so what this means is
that if we have let's say we have a full
text here and then we come in here and
we say text align should be justified
what this is means that it basically
makes sure that this particular text
wraps around the O length of that screen
so that is what justify does very easy
and after talking about justify the next
thing I'm going to talk about is text
align last now what text align last does
so I'm going to change this to
iPhone last
what text a line last does is that it
basically aligns the last line of a text
so for example if I say Center
right so if I say Center and then I try
to run this
you can see that it aligns that because
this is the last line of the text that
is why it aligns this at you know the
at the center so for example let's say I
just have let me just copy this
and just keep going like that and I run
it
so you're gonna see that all of these
start from the left but only the last
line aligns at the center so that is
what test align Center does I'm just
going to remove all this and put it back
the reason why this also that I also
aligns are the center is because it is
also the last line even if it's also the
first line
so that is what the test align last does
you can make it right you can make it
left you can make it whatever you want
so I'm also going to talk about vertical
align so when I say vertical align I'm
going to change this to vertical
iPhone align
so when I say vertical align what that
does is that it basically aligns that
vertically so for example let's say that
we have
this is Tommy is a guy and let's say
that this guy has a P tag
oh now let's make a b tag
just so that doesn't start on a new line
and then let's you know give you like an
ID
of or not a class yeah we're gonna give
you an ID
and let's just say this ID is something
like
um
text so once we give that that ID well
we just want to actually don't let us
give it an ID let's use a class
attribute so that we can just easily get
that from there so once you give this a
class what we can just do now we give
that a class of text you know copy that
text and I'm going to come in here so
I'm just going to say
H1 now I'm going to say
B dot text so right here now what I'm
going to do is to come
in here and I'm going to say
the dot text
and I can just say B dot text you have a
vertical alignment of let me say top
now if I run this
you're going to see
I'm gonna wait for that to run
so it says to me is a guy so that
doesn't really make any change that's
just because it's uh the size is the
same as the H1 but let's say this is
actually like smaller like this P right
here
week is once we make the alignment go to
the top it's basically going to just
shift all the way to the top right here
but because this guy is the same size as
all of this so when it tries to shift to
the top it basically wraps around all
the oh you know the old margin of this
particular text but for example let's
say you have a smaller text or let's say
this a is smaller then it's going to go
up to the top a little bit so that is
what that does
so now that we know about the vertical
text alignment the next thing I'm going
to talk about is text decoration so I'm
gonna get rid of this OB
it's gonna run that again and I'm gonna
come back in here so right here where we
have text decoration so what you can
what text decoration does is that it's
it adds a line to a text very easy very
simple so right here where we have H1
what I can just do is to say text
decoration line
hyphen line
I can give you a value and say
underline
so if I say underline this is just gonna
have an underline
under the it's just gonna have a line
under the text that's what that does now
there are different ones and I'm going
to try all of them now so we can say
something like line true
once you say line three it's just going
to strike a line across the text so you
can see there's a line striking across
the text if I say over line
as you might have guessed there's going
to be a line on top of that particular
text
now you can also add two different
decorations together like I can have an
over line and I can have an underline
if I have both of them together it's
basically going to have one on top and
also one on the bottom as you can see
right there now we can do more we can
actually like you know say the color
that we want for that decoration line so
you can see text decoration
color
let's just say green
once we say that and we run it you're
gonna see that just the color of that
line is green and not the text as you
can see it changed the color of that
line to Green
another thing we can also do is to
specify the style of this line like what
if we want this line to be you know
dotted or dashed or solid what you just
need to do is to say text
decoration
Style
and I can say dashed
once I said Dash to this line is gonna
be dashed
so I can also you know change it to
double
and I can also change it to dotted
you know I can use basically any style
just similarly to what I use in the
borders so that is dotted
so what I can also do now is to specify
the thickness of that particular line so
I'm just gonna say text decoration
I'm gonna say thickness
now I'm going to use pixels we can say
10px and that is just gonna give it a
thickness of 10 PX
as you can see it's quite thicker if I
say in 90 PX you're going to notice that
very well
so okay this should be SS
so you should notice the thickness yeah
that's a lot so if I say 10 let me just
go back to 10.
you can see that that is 10 BX so now
instead of having to write all of this
you might have guessed again we can just
compress all of this and you know have
it on one line so I can have what
decoration do I want let me say over
line
and the color I want should be purple
and the next one you're going to have to
say is a style so let's say we want this
style to be solid
and then the thickness let's say we want
you know 6px so this is how the syntax
goes you first specify you know the one
that you want the line that you want the
type of line and then you're going to
specify the color then the
style and then the thickness so once I
run this now you're gonna see that that
works perfectly
there's also something else that we can
do we can just basically say text
decoration we can say none
now this text declaration known as come
very handy especially when I'm building
my pages with HTML CSS for example let's
say we have a link and I'm going to show
you this right now so right in here we
are going to have an a link
let me just say link
and let's just say h3f
and that goes to hashtag
if I run this you're gonna see that it
automatically has this underline right
there right but what if I don't want
that line or any decoration on this what
you can just do is to come here and say
an a tag every 8X should have a text
decoration of none because as you know
automatically it has this underlined
decoration and once I say no decoration
you're going to see that it doesn't have
that underline no more but the link
still works perfectly so that's a you
know very useful
tip that I've used a lot
and now we're going to talk about text
transformation
so text transformation is basically
transforming in the text you can make it
uppercase you know lowercase capitalize
you can do a lot of stuff with the test
transformation so what you can do now is
you just say
let's say
text
I'm gonna come here and type text hyphen
transform
so what I want to transform you to let's
say I want everything to be lowercase
so now you're gonna see that all of
these texts are going to be transformed
to lowercase
I can want you to be uppercase also
and once I run that you're gonna see
that this is all uppercase
now I can also change this to car
italyze now what capitalized does is
that when we have a sentence every word
in that sentence starts with uh
got an uppercase so if I come in here
and let's say Tommy is a guy
now every single word on it is going to
start with
an uppercase
so okay this term is a guy belongs to a
P tag so Andy okay what we can just do
is to come here and add that P tag
so that it affects it also
so as you can see every single word in
that P tag now basically as
starts with a capital case
now the next one I'm going to talk to
you about is
text indentation
so I'm going to remove all of this and
let's say we have a sentence like this
and we want it to start with a paragraph
or something like that what you just
need to do is to say text
indent
and we're just going to say something
like let's say 30px
once I say that
you're now going to see that all of this
stats you know as a space before it so
that's a very simple way of you know
showing how to indent your text so and I
hope you understand that
one more thing you know the last thing
we're going to talk about now in this
old text
is the letter spacing so for example
let's say you want there to be more
space between each letter what you're
just going to do is to say letter
spacing
so once I run this letter spacing
and I'm going to see that there's going
to be a spacing of 30px within every
single letter so that is how the later
spacing works now I hope you understood
everything we talked about concerning
text
now let's look into fonts in CSS
so front just basically allows us to
change how the text looks like let me
get rid of this spacing letter spacing
and just have it back to normal
so I'm also going to get rid of a just
want it to affect H1 and P
so what we can do now is to actually
change the font of this text so for me
to change the font of this text I need
to use something called font family
now there are there's a lot of like
fonts you can use and you can easily
search Google to get the list of CSS
fonts that you can use but I'm just
going to test a few ones now to show you
the first one I'm going to test is area
so I can say to use this I'm going to
say aerial comma
so it should give us like
or vertical
and that is under the sun's serif font
so once I run this you're gonna see that
the font of this has changed to area we
can notice that it is now a different
font so I can also change this to
you see the console so that's a font
and you don't need to know all of this
on the top of your head everything is
available for you on the internet
so
I can say new
and then this is on the mono space
if I run this
you're gonna see that that changes the
font to that particular font so it is
very easy to change the font and you
know
it's not that complicated or you just
need to know is in the name of the font
so I'm just going to comment that out
and the reason I commented that out is
because now I want to talk about font
styling so I can say font style
and I can say that this style should be
italic
if I say this style should be italic
it's just gonna make the text a little
bit slant so that's just an italic tile
so this is basically a font style named
italic and I can also change it to
something like oblique
and once I change that to oblique you're
gonna see
that that is oblique very similar to
italic
and now I can just have it as normal if
I have it as normal it's not going to
change nothing the style is not going to
change just going to be the same way
that it is
so the another thing I can do is to
affect the front weight so I'm just
going to say font hyphen weight
and if I say font weight should be let's
say bold and that
font is going to be bold
if I say font weight should be as you
can see there's a P tag but it's now
bold you can see font weight should be
normal
and that is just gonna be
normal
so that is how easy it is as you can see
this was an H1 tag
and an each one tag is always bold but
because I told you to be normal now as
you can see it's no more that bold it's
just normal
and
the another thing the last thing I'm
going to look into is talking about the
font size so the font size is basically
giving it like the text size if I say
size and let's say I say something like
50 PX
and I click on run I'm gonna see that
this is gonna be 50px so this is that
huge so that's what it just does you
don't need to over 10K what you just
need to know is that it changes the size
of that particular text
now the way we change this size using PX
we can also change the size using em
so what we can just do now is to say
let's say
50 em is actually a lot if I run this
you're going to see that it is massive
so
actually that didn't show yet you can
see how massive it is so I think 16
pixels equals to 1 am so basically this
is like 50 times 16 pixels which is
going to be you know let's see 50
multiplied by 16. so we're basically
saying 800 pixels so that is why it is
that huge so but let's say something
like you know
a
4 AM
and then if we run that you're gonna see
that it is that huge so that is how to
deal with fonts in CSS
now let's talk about icons in CSS so for
example let's say I want to show like an
icon let's say a cloud icon or you know
a computer icon or any icon how do I
actually show that now we are actually
going to use like an external
source so let me just get rid of this to
make the text normal back
and I'm going to come into HTML to
actually do this
so what you need to do is to go into
your adding element and paste this in
there now you don't need to know like
where what this is what it is just is
that it basically linking a particular
style sheet which is an external CSS
file from a Google API so Google product
provided like a CSS that allows us to
just make icons very easily so what you
just need to do is to paste or right
type in this particular code in your
adding element and once you type that in
your add element what you can now do is
to come into your body and when you come
into the body wherever you want the icon
to be now you need to type it or you
need to write that you want the icon to
be at this place so we're just going to
say we're going to use an element named
I
and we're going to close it like that
and that is going to take a class
of material so we're going to say equals
to
material
I think icons
and now we are now going to write the
particular icon that we want to show so
if we want the cloud icon to show we're
going to say cloud
we can do the same thing to have another
icon so you can say I
exactly the same thing we're going to
say class
and then we're going to say equals and
then we're just going to say materials
I can't
I'm always say material icons now we can
now say let's say we want the computer
icon to show we're going to say computer
so now we should be having the cloud and
computer icon show now if I run this
you're going to see that two different
icons are going to show this is a cloud
icon this is a computer icon that is a
very easy way of doing it with Google
Icons API that you provided for us now
we can keep going let's just copy and
paste this what we just need to do is to
change this actual value so let's say we
want traffic
icon
if I hit run you're gonna see that it
gives us the traffic icon now there's a
list of icons you can see you can just
also like you know go over to the Google
Icons page and look at the list of icons
that they provide so that is basically
it's about icons in CSS
now we are going to talk more about
designing or styling tables in CSS
so right now the first thing that I'm
going to do is to just create a very
basic table so right here I'm actually
going to get rid of all of this we don't
need all of this for now
and also of this
so right here I just want to create a
very basic table we've done this in the
HTML section of this course so now we're
just going to have table and then we're
going to have a TR
and in this TR we're going to have the
add-in so let's just say name
and let's say h so those are the add-ins
and now I'm going to have another TR
another table row and right here I'm
going to have TD which is table data so
let's have one name as John
and let's say John is you know 15.
and then we're going to have one more
table row so TR
and let's have a TD
and let's just say team and let's say
team is 19.
so now if I run this this is just gonna
show me that basic table that we have
here name age and all of that
as you can see this just looks like at
least comprised together we actually
want to make it look like an actual
table so what we're going to do now the
first thing that we want to do is to
just make it have like you know some
borders so like to have like the lines
right here like the way normal table
will so for me to do this what you just
need to do is to select the table
we need to select table we need to
select this th which is a table heading
and we also need to select the table
data so I'm going to come in here and
say table
I'm going to select the table heading
and then the table data so once we
select these three what we cannot do is
to say border
we can specify and say like two pixels
should be that thick and we want it to
be solid
now if I run this you're gonna see that
we have this border that is you know two
pixels thick and it is solid so that is
basically how we can do that
now the next thing I want to do is to
have a width for it so I'm going to have
with and let me say the width is 100
and when I run this and say that the
width is 100 you're gonna see that it
extends all the way to the end of a
particular
evil
it's a particular screen
so what I want to do now as you can see
it looks weird and the reason why it
looks weird is because each one has its
own border like this has a square around
it this has a rectangle around the
rectangle a rectangle I just wanted this
to collapse into one line so all of this
should just be one line and not double
lines on that so what for me to do this
what I just need to do is to say brother
I can say brother collapse
so once I Collapse this
and I run it then you're gonna see that
everything basically adds one line which
is very good and this is what we want so
that is you know the first
step in actually designing this table so
we can make this let's say we want this
to be 50 percent
so that is basically fifty percent
so that is good that is what we want
and now we can talk more about the you
know actual size of this particular
table for example I can say I want th
let's say like I just want only this
table to have a width of so what I can
do now is I can come down and say th
you have a height
let me say 50 pixels
now if I run this
you're gonna see that the height of th
is now more like brother so I can you
know specify all of this by just
uniquely using that as a selection like
th then I say I ate and I gave it a
value of 50px so it is that easy to do
and you know that's straightforward now
the next thing I can do is to actually
talk about this still alignment of you
know this particular words like for
example I want this to be in the center
just the way the editing is the adding
as default is in the center but for the
daytime I want this to be in Center on
the right or wherever what I just need
to do is I need to just say TD
because these are the data right so I'm
gonna say TD and I'm going to say text
align
and I if I say right you're gonna see
that all the text aligns to the right
side of that particular table but for it
to look good I'm going to say Center
once I say Center you're gonna see that
that aligns perfectly
so I can also you know change this th to
a line on the left so everything can
line in the left so let's say I want
this to be the left I can just you know
copy this particular one and come into
th and put that in the left so you're
going to see now that every single thing
is in the left
now that is another way of basically
doing that now let's say I want there to
be spacing between like every one of
these like as you can see this is quite
congested what I can just do instead of
having like increasing the width I can
add a pad into it so I can say I can
just get rid of this actually and I can
say th and TD should have a padding
of let me say 10px I'm gonna get rid
of this height
now if I run this
and now I'm going to see that they all
have like an equal amount of space with
it
so that's basically what that does
right and that is straightforward
because you know it makes the
table actually look very good and that
is literally one we want
so what we can just do now is to also
add some like you know something that we
can hover over so for example
if let's say I want to be able to over
Rover this particular line right what I
need to do is to come here and say table
row and what I mean by over is that when
I bring my my mouse on this particular
part I want let's say if you show a
particular color so it can or if you
highlight that particular row so it
shows that I am over that so that all of
this belongs to table row so what I'm
just going to do is to say TR which is
table row I'm going to use something
different this time I'm going to say
column over now when I use colon over
whatever I do here is only going to
happen whenever my mouse is on top of
that particular element that has been
selected so what this means now is that
if I say I want the background color
of this TR TB let's say blue
now this is only going to happen it's
only going to be true only going to
happen when my mouse is on it now let me
run this and show you what that is going
to do
so now when you see that my mouse is on
it you can see that the background color
change to Blue now this is only true
when you know my mouse is over it so
that is you know a very good one also
because it allows you to easily look at
or easily highlight what you want to do
on the table
so this is basically
uh the basic way or the simple way of
Designing tables using CSS
now we're going to be looking at the
display property in CSS now what this
display property does is that it allows
us to you know display a particular
element or maybe even hide the element
or even remove the element from the web
page but the code is still present for
example I can get rid of this table and
say display shouldn't show or I can hide
it or I can do whatever I want to do let
me show you what I mean now for example
if I come into table right here and I
say display
should be none
if I run this you're going to see that
everything right here is not going to
show no more and the reason why this
doesn't show is just because we've said
display should be none
now they also many other things I can do
like I can set visibility to be hidden
so if I say visibility
should be eating
now instead of this not displaying it
also doesn't display but it is still
right there now what I mean by it is
still right there is if I come in here
unless I have an H1 tag
and I say I now if I run this you're
gonna see that this particular H1 tag
starts from here and the reason why the
H1 stack starts from here and not here
is because we set the visibility of that
table to be known that means it is still
present there but it's not showing that
is why H1 stack starts from here but if
I said display to be none
display
if I set it to be known this basically
means remove that particular
one from remove that particular table or
whatever element from this particular
web page so as you can now see how it
starts from the top so that's the major
difference between display none and
visibility hidden none allows us to
remove that element entirely from the
web page visibility still lets the
element be present in the web page but
not show
now we're going to talk about
combinators and CSS now a combinator is
something that basically explains like
or shows you the relationship between
different selectors
now there are different combinators and
I'm going to explain everything right
now
so I want to get rid of all of this
I'm just going to get rid of all of that
and also get rid of the old table
now let's say for example we have this
H1 tag and in this H1 tag we now have a
so let me just say
I
and within this H1 tag let's say I have
another B tag
that says a
so this B is inside this H1 tag now what
I can just do is to say I'm gonna use
something called The Descendant selector
so if I now say H1 and I leave a space
and say B what this is going to do is
that it's going to select
all the B elements inside an H1 tag and
whatever we do here is going to be done
to that so if I say color should be red
now you're gonna see that this a is
going to be red
now as you can see a is red now what
this is is a descender selector which
means that it selects all the elements
that are inside this initial element so
let me select all the B element that
inside H1 now if I create another B
element let's say I just create another
one like that if I run this because that
b element is still there you can see
that it says that and imagine I have a p
element right
and inside that P element and I have a b
element that says
what's up
and once I run it because B element is
still under this H1 element right it's
still a descendant of it it's still
gonna affect it and it's gonna be red
for now if we use a child selector it's
going to be different so what we just
used now was a descendant selector but
what we want to talk about now is a
chart selector now if I say H1 greater
than b this means that it's going to
select all the elements that is a
children or there's a child or the B
element as a child of H1 so if I run it
you're going to see one difference and
I'm going to explain why you can now see
that this is normal red this is black
now the reason why is because if I come
in here it's looking for only the B
element that are children of H1 even
though this B element inside this p and
let me just make this like this so you
can see it better even though this B
element
that is within this p is still under
this H1 but because it is not a direct
child of this H1 it's not going to be
seen as a child selector
so if I have let's say I have one B
outside this P after a that b is going
to be that b element is going to be red
as you can see but because this bead is
not a child of H1 is a child of p and p
is a child of H1 that's why this is
still black now that's the main
difference between a chart selector and
a Depend and a descendant selector
now the next one is an adjacent sibling
selector now this just basically selects
if I'm going to use plus to note this
but this selects all the adjacent B
after an H1 if I run this you're gonna
see that none of it is red now the
reason is because all of this are
children of B but they are not really
after B so if I come in here now and I
paste this so this is adjacent to H1
it's not a child of it but it's after H1
once I run it you're gonna see that this
one now is actually red
now the next one I'm going to talk about
is General sibling selector so this
agency means selector only selects the
one that is adjacent to it so if I come
here and paste another B and run it
you're going to see that what shows
under here is not going to be as you can
see it is not red this is because it it
only takes the adjacent one to read and
this is the only adjacent one to H1 this
one is adjacent to B it's not adjacent
to H1 but if I use the general simulink
selector which is this you write here so
we're just gonna get that particular one
the there's a sign to select the
adjacent simply selector and it is this
particular sign right here so once I use
this sign this shows that any B that is
you know the next day like siblings of
H1 is going to be red now once I run it
you're going to see that this second one
is also red now this is because this
second one also come as a sibling to
this it's not just only taking for the
one adjacent to it it's looking for the
one that is close to H1 so those are the
major four CSS combinators
now we are going to look into building
drop down menu
so you know normally where you have like
an option where you can like over over
it and once you come about it you see
something that drops down like a menu
I'm going to show you how you can build
that right now
so this is fairly easy what we just need
to do right here in the HTML body I'm
first of all gonna remove everything in
the body and what I just want to do is
that I want to create a div class I'm
going to create a new div class
we talked about what if class were I'm
going to create this div class
and I'm gonna just have it like that and
I'm gonna give you a class of
of drop
down
menu
so I gave you a class of drop down menu
so this is what I actually want to be
dropped down right but right here I want
there to be like a button that we are
going to over Rover and once we go our
mouse goes on it we want this drop down
menu to show so yeah we want to have a
button so there's a button element that
just allows us to have a button
basically and right here we can just say
drop
down
menu
a button
so now we can have a class
and we can make this class say drop down
drop
down
button
so I just giving this class so we can
identify it later in our CSS
so now that we have this this is
basically the drop down button if I run
this let's see what we have you can see
that we just have a drop down button
normally and this div class we're going
to have a basic link so let's just say a
let's close it and let's say uh no menu
or we can just say list
and then we can say
for now let's just make it go nowhere so
we can just say link to hashtag
so we have let's say four different
lists if I run this you're gonna now see
that we have that button with four
different lists right but what I want to
do now is I want first of all I want
this list to not show and I want to
style this button a little bit okay
let's take it a step at a time let's
first style this button a little bit so
what I'm going to do is to come into
styles.c access and I'm gonna come here
and do this
I'm gonna get rid of this
and this drop down button because I want
to style it I'm going to take that drop
down class and I'm gonna say
Dot
drop down button
so I'm going to give you a background
color
but let me see I give you a background
color of blue
so now if I run this it should have a
background color of blue which is good
and I want to give the text color so I
want to give the test color white I want
the color of the text to shift the white
so let's see good and what I'm just
gonna do is to say padding just so
there's going to be a little bit of
space let me give the pattern something
like 13 PHX so let's have a colon right
here and I'm gonna run this
so that is good and what I'm now going
to do is to say let me just try to add
some font size
I'm going to say 16
pictures
so I just gave that the font size so now
it looks a little bit bigger and what I
can just deny is to say border
none now the reason why I'm saying
bother known is because as you can see
on this particular button it has this
border that wraps it around but I want
to remove that so that's why I say
border none if I run this we shouldn't
see any border no more which is good and
now I want to say cursor
now on the cursor to be pointer
so we're going to run that cursor
pointer right
good so that means when we come on this
the cursor is going to change to a
pointer as you can see that and icon is
showing when we come on this so we've
done we've designed this the way we want
it to be the next thing I'm going to do
is to actually now come on this list I
want you to First be a list and then I
want it to not show until my mouse comes
over this particular button now let's go
ahead and do that so what we just need
to do is to let me copy this drop down
menu first so yeah I'm gonna say
dot drop down menu
and first of all
I'm going to say display
since I don't want to display it I'm
going to say display equals none but I'm
going to leave that blank for now
because I want to see the changes I'm
making so let me say the position
is absolute
and once you say position absolute we
can then let's run this first of all
so let's make sure this is this and then
let's say we give you a background color
probably say something like
blue but this time around let's give it
light blue
if I run this you should see that that
has a background color of light blue and
what I also want to give it is a minimum
weight we talked about this
I'm going to say mean wait
and when we give it the mean mode we're
going to say something I want 50 pixels
and then what we are just gonna do is to
let's just run this
okay great so what we can now do now is
to say the for the list under this we're
gonna say dot drop down menu
a
you want to say for the list under this
the a tag
we want the color to be
black
we're going to give you a padding
of something like let's say 11 pixels
and 15 PX
let's give a text decoration of none
because it is a link it's going to have
this underlying text decoration so let's
make sure the text decoration
is none
once we say that we can say display
so we can give the display value block
now if we run this this should you know
show the changes as you can see now it's
been listed this way which is what we
want and then we gave you a text
decoration of none so now it's still a
link sometimes I can still click it and
it's going to take me somewhere as you
can see but it just doesn't show that
underline no more which is what we want
so now we want to have an over so what
we want to do is to say that
the drop down content
right we're going to say a
but what we want to do instead of just
saying a directly we want to say a over
I'm gonna do this and say over and then
I'm going to give it a background color
so by giving this a particular
background color when you know we over
over every single list on it so I'm just
going to give a background color of you
know let's say white
let's see how that looks like if I run
this
and I come over you can see that when I
hover over each of it now it turns White
so what I'm now going to do is that I
want this to only show so first of all
let me make the display of this let me
remove that comment and make the display
of this none so now you can see that
let's wait for it the list is not show
me no more but I want this list to show
only when we over on this so what I'm
going to do is to say
Dot
this drop down right here which we
already had from the beginning so what
I'm just gonna do is to say that
drop down
and we're gonna say
colon
so instead of saying this we're going to
say over
and then we're gonna say dot this drop
button
what we want to do now is to just
basically okay so the first thing that
we actually need to do is to say the
drop down over we're going to say the
drop down menu so this whole menu we
want the display to be blocked
right so we're gonna say
display
block
now when we run this
what we want is that when we hover over
this this you have a display of block
but this doesn't have a display of
blocks so the reason why this doesn't
have a display of block is simply
because
when we come in here we want to have
this div class to be
so we have to discard there's a class of
drop down menu we actually want Let's
see we want all of this to be wrapped in
a div class so let's say we cut all of
this and say div right
and then we say this is like class
and then we just say equals you know
let's say drop down
now since we know we have this drop down
here we can just say
from drop down DOT over that means all
of this uh colon over we want to show
drop down menu now let's see what this
does so as you can see now when we over
on this it basically shows that drop
down menu this is literally what we want
to happen
now what we can do we can just add you
know a little bit of sauce on it and say
the drop down
and when we overrun it
we now want to even change the color of
this drop down button to maybe something
lighter so we can then say
Dot
the button so the class of the button is
drop down button we're going to say dot
the button
I'm gonna say background
color
it'll be something like let's see gray
let's try it out now when we run this
you can now see that we have a when I
overrun it the colors change to Gray and
we have this basic list right here now
that is literally what we want to happen
and that is what has happened now we can
also you know
as you can see everything is basically
done successfully but we can just come
in here and under this drop down button
let's say we just want to add
some styling to this drop down class
I'm gonna come here and just say that
drop down
and I'm gonna navigate let's say the
position
should be relative
and let's say the display
inline
so we talked about this when we were
looking into all the different display
and all of that in CSS
so as you can see everything basically
Works successfully right now we can also
have this list coming to the you know
Center if you want that is you know
optional but you can see this is a basic
drop down and once we come over this we
can basically look at all of this and we
can click on it and it takes us to a
particular link
so as you can see all of that work
successfully does how to build a simple
drop down with CSS
now let's look into attribute selectors
in CSS
so let's get rid of all of this
and I'm also going to get rid of all of
this
and let's say I have
let's see a div class
a div element that has a class
of let's say
test
and in here we then have a p
that says I
so if I then run this we just have a
basic diff closer as a p that says I
that's that so right here let's say we
want to change something to this old div
class we instead of selecting it we're
using its element name we can select it
using its class name
so what we can do is to come in here now
and we can just simply say
div
so it's going to say any div that has an
attribute name class
then we want to change the color
to red
so if I run this you're going to see
that the color of this changes to Red
now this is because we selected the div
that has an attribute of class
so that is a very basic way to actually
select an attribute but again an element
by an attribute but let's say that you
want to select with the exact value for
example let's say I want to select the
element that has a div class now I have
a div element and it has an attribute
right with a value of test what I need
to do is to say div and then I'm going
to say class
equals I'm going to write the value so
this is still going to be I right
and it's going to have the red this is
because it's going to look for a div
class with a div element with a class
named test so if you come in here we're
going to see that we have a div element
with a class name test
imagine I just removed T and I say test
now this is not going to be red no more
it's just going to be black because that
is not true for this particular
condition
so that is a basic way of you know
selecting with the value so that's how
to use attribute selector in CSS
now that you know the basics of HTML and
CSS I'm going to teach you how to code
in JavaScript you're about to learn all
the basics of JavaScript programming by
coding an RPG game line by line this way
of learning JavaScript will help you
understand better how everything works
together so if you're following along
you'll be able to record you'll be able
to code each line right before I do
based on my instructions there is some
starter code so go to the link in the
description and it should open up just
like this and then you can Fork the
rebel this will give you my stutter code
so just click Fork Rebel
and then you'll have to sign up or log
in if you haven't already
so this is the starter code for the RPG
I've already provided the HTML and CSS
and we're now going to create the
JavaScript so let's look what the
starter code looks like so when it's
loaded in the browser it looks like this
so you can see it's a text-based RPG and
it will give you a description of what's
happening right here and then you'll
have a few different options and these
buttons here and it's going to keep
track of your experience points your
health and your Co your gold now right
now none of these buttons do anything we
still have to create that and all this
is just hard coded right now so you can
see in the HTML we've already learned
about how to set up an HTML page so a
lot of this should look familiar to you
so you can see we have a div full of the
stats at this that's this top div and
then we have a div for the controls
those are these controls here and then
we have
this special one monster stats and and
this is not showing up yet because we're
using CSS to hide that for now and we
are we're also we're ex basically hiding
this whole section the whole monster
stats section and uh because that will
only appear if you're fighting a monster
and then we have our main text here and
you can see
um we have all these elements of the
page but nothing is happening yet
because we haven't created our
JavaScript but let's look at the CSS
really quick so this is also provided
and it's basically just styling the page
how you can see it and one thing to look
at is the monster stats which I already
talked about currently it's set as
display none it's only going to show the
monster stats if you're fighting a
monster but we're not yet fighting a
monster we haven't even implemented that
feature of the game yet so now we'll go
over to our Javascript file so if you
want to just kind of explore the HTML
and CSS a little more to understand that
you can and but we're now going to code
this game from scratch and you are going
to code the game step by step based on
my instructions so I'm going to just
close this section here I will zoom in
just a little more so you can see the
code a little better so the first thing
I'm going to have you do is create a
variable but first let me show you how
to do that I'm going to do VAR XB equals
zero and we'll zoom in one more time and
I can just put a semicolon here so to
keep track of the player's experience
points we've declared a variable called
XB and then we've assigned it to the
starting value of zero so I want you to
follow this example and create another
variable to keep track of health and
start it at 100.
so hopefully you're following along
you're trying it before I show you so
now I'm going to show you VAR health
equals 100.
and so you can see we follow the same
pattern so this is so we say it's a
variable with VAR then we say the
variable name and then we assign it with
the equal sign and then this is the
value that we're assigning and then the
semicolon here in JavaScript semicolons
are optional so you can use a semicolon
to signify that it's at the end of a
line but you don't have to do it but for
now we're going to use semicolons so now
now that you have the pattern down see
if you can create another variable
called gold and set it to 50.
okay now we're going to create another
variable and this is going to be called
current weapon and we're going to set to
zero but when a name has two words the
convention is to use what's called Lower
camel case which is how you do is the
first word is all lowercase and then the
first letter of every preceding word is
uppercased
so we'll do current so we'll do VAR
current weapon
equals zero
so we've been declaring all our
variables with VAR
however in modern JavaScript it's better
to use let instead of VAR you can
actually there's three ways to to
declare a variable you can use VAR let
or const it's better to use let instead
of VAR because it fixes a number of
unusual behaviors with VAR that make it
difficult to reason about so let's
change all the vars to let and one quick
way to do that in replit is I can
highlight the first VAR and either do
command or control D to highlight the
next and every time I press command or
control D it highlights the next
instance of VAR and now I'm actually
using multiple cursors and I can just
type in all at once so I change them all
to let now let's declare a variable
without initializing it so in every one
of these examples we've initialized the
variable that's this part where we set
it to equal something but you can create
a if you just don't put the equal number
or equal value you can declare it
without initial using it so using the
let keyword let's declare a variable
called fighting but not set it equal to
anything so it's just like this let
fighting
now we'll do the same thing with
variables for Monster Health and
inventory it's common to just create all
your variables up front toward the
beginning of your program before you
start using them you want to have them
declared before you use them later in
your program so we'll do let Monster
Health
and let inventory
now let's set the variable inventory to
equal a string stick
a strings are a group of characters
surrounded by quotation marks so we'll
do equal string or equal
stick and we use double quotation marks
but you can also use single quotation
marks as long as the quotation marks are
the same another thing you can also use
back ticks but you just have to make
sure that at the beginning and the end
are both the same for now we'll just use
double quotation marks now right now the
inventory is just a single thing a stick
but the inventory can store multiple
items so we're going to change the value
of inventory to be an array with the
item stick dagger and sword an array is
basically just a a list of different
values you can store multiple values in
an array and you you create array by
putting brackets around the list of
values
so it's going to be like this so the
first item we're going to put the
bracket here stick and then we will have
dagger
and sword
and then we do an in bracket there so
now we've created an array of three
strings
now putting three items in this list was
just an example so for now let's just
start the player with just the stick so
we're going to keep this as an array but
we only want one item so we're going to
delete dagger and sword those items
and then later it will give the player
an opportunity to add more items to the
inventory but it has to start out as an
array if we want to add elements to the
array in order to update HTML elements
on a web page on an HTML page you need
to get references to them in your
JavaScript code so here's an example
this is not the one we're using I'm just
giving you this as an example where we
can this will get a reference to the
HTML element with an ID of L because
this is the CSX CSS selector for ID and
it's going to have the ID of el and
we're going to store that that HTML
element in a variable called l
what I want you to do is update this to
get a reference to the htl the HTML
element with the ID of button one and
assign it to a variable with the name
button one
so basically we're just going to do
button one and
button one let's just look over our HTML
really quick so you can see where that
is if we go to the HTML and we can see
here
the button ID of button one that's this
one where it says go to store so now
we're getting access to this element and
we can do things to it like we can
change the text in the element or
basically do whatever we want using
JavaScript once we have a reference to
that element so we'll go back to our
JavaScript and now what we're going to
do is change this let to const so I
already told you earlier that you can
create a variable with VAR let or const
so VAR allows the most changing
basically it's so you can basically do
anything you want with a VAR later but
you may but that could open yourself up
to bugs and const it means that it is
the least amount of changing once you
declare a variable as a const you cannot
update it so we do we are going to want
to update the XP the health the gold but
now once we get access to this button
we're never going to you want to update
this variable we're not going to assign
button one to button two it's always
going to be button one so that's why we
can use const
you may you want to use const anytime
you are creating a variable that should
never change if the value is never going
to change you declare the variable with
const because it's a constant so now we
want to we want to get access to a bunch
of other elements on the website we're
going to basically get access to
elements with all of these different IDs
I'm just going to about to paste it in
here but you can give it a try yourself
if you want first
okay so we got these all pasted in so
basically we have access to all the
different elements on our website that
we want to update using JavaScript so
now instead of typing this whole thing
in every time document.queryselector and
then the ID we can just refer to the
variable okay now we're going to make a
comment to describe what the next few
lines of code will do comments can be
written with either two forward slashes
or with a multi-line sequence so if
you're going to make comment on one line
it can just be two forward slashes and
you can do comment or if you want to
make a multi-line comment you can do
slash star at the beginning and star
slash at the end and then you can say
this is a
comment and then you can see that the
comment the code editor automatically
makes comments gray and because this is
a multi-line comma you can see it's all
gray here so basically we just want a
single comment that's going to say
initialize buttons
so now this indicates what the next part
of code will do
so let's designate what the first button
in the HTML does by setting the on click
property of button one
and we're going to set that property to
the function name go to store so here's
an example of how you would do it for a
different button so this is just a
generic button and if you want to make
the button open up call the function
open program you could do it like this
but we're trying to make it so button
one will call the go store function
which is a function we'll create later
so basically it's going to be button one
and just go store
and so we can see that the button one
already says go to store so now when we
click the button one it's going to call
this function which is going to make our
game go to the store in the game now
we're just going to follow the same
example to set the on click property of
button 2 and button 3 to be go cave and
fight dragon
so I can just actually copy this line
paste it in here so this will be button
two button three and it'll be go cave
and fight dragon
now we're going to create a function so
we already made it so these functions
will be called when you click the
buttons but let's now create these
functions that are called now functions
are are just a group of a section of
code that you can run over and over
again every time you call that function
so it's a way to repeat easily repeat
code so every time that function is
called it it just runs all those lines
of code in that function so let me show
you how you would just create a generic
function so see you always start with
the word the keyword function and then
you do a space and then you put the
function name which can be anything and
you're always going to have two brackets
or two parentheses and then these curly
brackets and inside the curly brackets
are where you put the code that's going
to run when you call the function so
right now instead of creating the
function called function name we're
going to create a function called ghost
color so that's pretty simple you just
do go store that's what it's called now
okay now let's make this function do
something we're just going to
basically do some example code really
quick but we're going to make the go
store function output the message going
to store to the web console so basically
we do console.log and then in
parentheses we put the string going to
store just like this
console.log so it's going to log it to
the web console going to store
and
that's it now we have something that
this function will do and now we've
actually done enough to to test our
program out so now when we click go to
store it's going to put going to store
in the console Now where's the console
it's not this this isn't the console
this is part of the website so to get to
the console you can do it either from
your browser's Dev tools or write in
replit we can click this this um thing
this uh this wrench here toggle
developer tools and now down here we
have our console so click the Run button
and now we we do get the this goat cave
is not defined because we haven't
created it yet but we still should it
still should work I'll click go to store
and it says I'm going to store right in
the console
so let's create a go k function that
will console oh that will log to the
console going to Cape
so I can just copy this and just paste
and put go cave
going to cave
and then we'll just create a fight
Dragon function that will say fighting
dragon
so
we'll just print paste in another one
here and this will be called fight
dragon
and it'll say
fighting dragon and now we should be
able to run this and we don't get an
error down here because all the
functions are defined so go to store
go to cave
and fight Dragon we can see in the
console those are appearing
okay well let's do some refactoring
refactoring is when you change code to
improve code or make it better that
you've already created so we're going to
change the go to store function this was
just kind of to demo it we're not
actually going to
console going to store and we're not
going to log that to the console because
when people are playing the game they
won't actually be seeing the console so
when we when a player clicks the go to
store button the buttons and text in the
game should change so what's in these
buttons to change and what's in this
text up here it should tell you what's
happening at the store right down here
so we're going to remove the console.log
we're going to remove this and we're
going to add a new line of code inside
the function that updates the text of
button one so it says I10 health for 10
gold
so I'm gonna
delete that and then let me just
show a quick example we're not going to
use this one but this is how you would
update the text of a button button dot
enter text and then set what it equals
and we're going to make the button one
say I can go by 10 health for 10 gold so
let's change this to button one and then
we just change the text in here the
inner text is now going to be by 10
health and then we'll just put it in
parentheses 10 gold
now we also want the text of button 2 to
say by weapon 30 gold and the the text
of button three to say go to Town Square
so basically you're going to go back to
where you began
so I can just copy this
and then we'll do button two button
three
and then this will say by weapon
for 30 gold
and
go to Town Square
so now that the text on these buttons
have changed the on click properties on
the button should change so inside the
go store function we'll update the on
click property of all three buttons the
new function should be by Health by
weapon and go town
and you should already know enough right
now to be able to do that all on your
own
but basically I can just copy the the
initializing these buttons
and then
put it here now see how it's not
indented the same amount
um now indent indenting is actually
optional in JavaScript it's just to make
sure your code is more readable but it's
still good to do any time something's in
a block of code and these curly braces
you want to indent it the same amount
even though it doesn't actually impact
how your code's working so I'm going to
highlight everything and now I can just
press Tab and we'll indent everything at
once so the button one is now going to
say by health
uh button two or is not going to go to
not say
um
by weapon
this is the function that's going to be
called and then go down
now we're changing the inner text of the
buttons but we also want to change the
inner text of this section here that's
the the property this is the has the ID
of text and we want to say you enter the
store
so I'm just going to copy this again
and just stay text
you enter the store
and now let's create three new empty
functions called buy Health by weapon
and go town
so I'm going to create a function
you have to use the keyword function
by health
parentheses and that's just going to be
an empty function and then we'll do
another one and another one so by weapon
and go town
and at this point we can test it out so
if I click go store
I'm going to just
move this here so you can the buttons
still stay in a row here so you enter
the store
and unfortunately we can't go back to
the town yet but we were able to enter
the store if I refresh this I can try it
again
go store you enter the store
okay so every time you click a button
it's basically going to do all these
things it's going to update the button
One update button two update button
three and then change the functions for
the buttons and it's going to put some
new text here so we're gonna
um move this go town function to be the
first function and then we're just going
to copy all this and put it in that
function
so I'm going to just do command X or
Ctrl X to cut it and then we'll put it
right here command or control V and this
time I'll do control or command C and
then I'm just going to paste it
and basically when you go to the town uh
we want all this to be what we started
off with all the text we started off
with is what's in the town and all the
click the on clicks we started off with
was what we want the town to have so I'm
just going to just
peace and update the updated code with
go to store go to Cave fight dragon and
you can see these three are the same as
these three but instead of the text
being you enter the store now we're
going to say you are in the Town Square
you see a sign that says store
you see a sign that says store well this
should be actually in quotation marks
because it's what it says so let's put
quotation marks around the word store
so now we can see based on what
uh the color of the this that
something's wrong
um so usually strings are this brownish
color but it's switching the black and
we have these squiggler lines because
you can't put quotation marks inside a
string well actually you can't I'm going
to show you how if we put a backslash
before each one
you can see now it all is the right
color so putting this backslash this is
called escaping and it's signifying that
the next character after that slash is
not supposed to be it's not supposed to
be the end of the string it's supposed
to be literally rendered so there's
quite a few different special characters
that you can you that you can put in
with escaping the character like that
so you may have noticed that there's
some repetition in our code so if we
look at this all this code looks very
similar to all this code
and when you have repetition and code
it's a sign that you need a new function
so above the go town function let's add
another function we'll create an empty
function called update
this time the function should take a
parameter named location so data can be
passed into the function when it's
called a parameter is a variable that
you just put in the parentheses so let
me show you what that looks like
so we have the function called update
and this is the parameter we can now
pass in when we call the function we can
pass in the location so let's create a
new const here called locations and
we're going to set it equal to an empty
array
this will be used to store all the data
for the locations in the game now arrays
can store any data type including
objects objects are similar to arrays
except that instead of using indexes to
access and modify their data you access
the data in objects through what are
called properties so inside the
locations array We'll add an empty
object using curly braces
so basically we just put these two curly
braces and here so now inside the array
and there's one item which is this empty
object and the object is going to
consist of key value pairs
so let me just give you another example
of an object so here is an an array
that has an object that are curly braces
and there's one key value pair the name
is the key the value is
Quincy Larson so we're not going to use
this this is just an example so here now
we're going to create a property called
name or the property is also another
name for a key so the property name
called name with the value of town
square
so we'll just
put these onto new lines like in the
other example we saw and then I will do
name
Town Square
so now after the name property we're
going to put a comma and then on the
next line we're going to add a property
named button text that has a value of an
empty array but since button text is two
words instead of a name is this one
where we're going to need to put
quotation marks around it so I hope
you're following along and you've tried
this so as just as a reminder you should
be trying everything right before I show
you and that will help you learn this on
your own so we're going to do button
text and then we're going to just set
that to
and empty array
oh and like I said we do need a comma
here so each element in the object each
uh each key value pair and the object is
separated by a comma so we have two two
elements in this object
okay so now this button text inside this
array we're going to make it a a list of
three strings we're gonna there's gonna
be three elements inside the array and
it's going to be the button text that we
see in the go town function go to store
go to cave and fight dragon
so I'll just actually paste that in
there just like that and now we're going
to add another property in the object
with the name button functions and the
value should be an array containing the
three on click functions the ghost or go
k fight dragon and you see these aren't
strings so they will not be strings in
the array either
so it should look just like that now
I'll just add one final property called
text and it will be the text from here
you are in the town you see a sign that
says store
just like that
the locations array currently has one
element which is an object
within the array and after the object's
final curly brace will add a comma and
on the next line within the array We'll
add another object with all the same
properties as the first object we'll
keep the property names the same on the
second object but change all the
property values to the information from
the go store function
and we'll set the property name to store
so I'll just go up here and I'll just
paste it in to make it a little quicker
here so now we have an element in this
array that's an object containing all
the information from the go store
function now we can consolidate the code
inside the Gotan and go store functions
so we'll copy the code inside the Gotan
function and paste it in the update
function then we'll delete all the code
inside the go town and go store
functions
so we're going to come down here so
here's where we're going to copy that
and put it right in the update function
and then we don't need this code here
now
and then we don't need
this code
okay so instead of assigning the inner
text and the the on click like we're
doing now
the update function will now use data
from the location that's passed into it
First Data needs to be passed into the
update function so inside the go town
function we'll call the update function
so to call a function let me just put
the name and then
parentheses after it so we now have
called the update function so when you
call the go town function it will now
call the update function and we're not
just going to call the function when we
call the function we need to pass in an
argument see it accepts a location when
we call the function we can pass a
location so here we're going to pass in
the locations array
just like that and so this is
the locations array right up here
so the locations array actually contains
two locations the Town Square and the
store currently the entire Ray with both
locations is being passed into the
update function but we just want to pass
in the first element of the locations
array so we can do that by putting
brackets at the end and putting a zero
just like this so this is going to pass
in the first element in the array
because in programming counting starts
as at zero so zero is the first element
one is the second element two is the
third element and so on so when you put
the name of an array and then use these
brackets and then put a number in those
brackets that's how you specify a single
element in the array so now that the go
down function calls the update function
with the first element of the locations
array it's time to use that location
information to update the inner text and
on click properties
inside the update function let's change
the button one dot enter text this one
right here
to equal the the button text the the
location button text
so we can do it like this uh we'll get
the we'll use location that's what was
passed in and then we'll use brackets
just like before but to specify a
specific part of the of the object we're
going to do just like this see how we
have button text we want that button
text so that's what we're going to put I
just copy that I'm going to paste it in
here so the location with brackets
button text that's how we access a
specific element in an object and you
can see this just happens to be an array
and we already know how to access a
certain element in an array which is the
same way we use brackets again and we
put the index number in this case index
0. so the location gets us this whole
thing
and then we put the bracket button text
that gets us this and then we put
bracket zero that gets us this so we've
now accessed the go to store so now
let's update these next two items using
this same pattern so I'll just paste
these in
and then we can just do
index one element index two so the first
second and third element now we can just
use the same pattern for the on click of
the buttons so I'm just going to paste
this in but instead of button text it's
going to be button functions so I'll
just copy the word functions
button functions and it's still going to
be 0 again
because the first item here so let's
update go the go cave
fight Dragon zero one
two and then finally we'll update the
text Dot inner text to also get from
locations now there's there's two ways
we can do this we've been using bracket
location which is just like this
location
text so we could use this notation but
we can also use dot notation so to use
dot notation just two ways to do it
we'll do dot text so we can do location
Dot and then you just put the word here
now this only works if it's a single
word like this when your key is two
words like button functions you have to
use bracket notation but for the text we
can just use the dot notation okay now
we'll just update the go store function
and so the code should look basically
this same as the go down function except
the number zero should be changed to one
so let's just do that really quick
and then it will be time to test our
game
so
up to locations
one
and now I'll click run
and we should be able to move between
the store
oh good see it has the information for
the buttons we have you enter the store
that can go back to the Town Square you
are now in the Town Square you see a
sign that says store so now we can move
between the Town Square and the store if
we press these other buttons nothing
happens we haven't done that quite yet
but this game is starting to work
now I'm just going to shrink this a
little bit and we're going to add a
third object in the locations array
and it's going to have the same
properties as the other two objects the
name will be cave and then the button
text is going to be fight slime fight
Fang beast and go to Town Square and
then the button functions we're going to
have some new functions fight slime
fight beast and go town and then the
text is just going to be you enter the
cave you see some monsters
so maybe you tried that on your own I'm
just going to paste it in here see we
have the cave with new button text here
and then new button functions a few of
these we still have to create and you
went to the cave you see some monsters
so now we'll just update the
go cave function
with using our calling your update
function and let's create some more
empty functions here it was for the
fight slime and fight Beast
so fight slime
so now that the store and Cave locations
are complete we'll code the actions at
those locations
so first we'll do the buy Health
function so inside the buy Health
function set gold to equal gold minus
10.
so it's just like this gold
equals gold minus
10. and you can see we're getting the
gold from our variable that we've
already said we start with 50 gold but
when you buy Health we're going to
subtract 10 from the gold and if we're
subtracting 10 from the gold we need to
give some health so let's add 10 to the
health
so that's pretty straightforward but let
me tell you about a quicker way you can
do something like this so there's a
shorthand way to edit subtract from a
variable called compound assignment the
long way to add it is like this but
there's a short way where you can do
Gold Plus minor we can do gold minus
equals 10. so let me show you if we just
do minus equals 10 that's just the
shorthand of subtracting 10 from
whatever that value is and assigning the
new value to the value so this basically
does the same thing as before so let's
change this to also use the compound
assignment so it's just going to be
Health Plus equals 10. so the line that
I change this from does the same thing
as the line that I change it to okay now
that the golden health value variables
have been updated we need to update the
values displayed on the screen so if we
look at what's being displayed here we
have health 100 gold 50. well we've
changed the variables but it didn't
actually change anything on the screen
so how can we do that well we can use
the we can set the inner text to Gold so
for the gold text that inner text let's
set to gold and we'll use the same thing
for health text so
so gold text I enter text equals gold
Health textilet text equals health so we
can update the text on the screen
so what if the player doesn't have
enough gold to buy health
well let's put the code in this by
Health function we're going to put all
this code
inside an if statement
so let me just show you how to do that
so I'm going to add an extra line here
and it's going to say if
and we want to say if condition we'll
update that later and then I'm going to
put curly braces just like we have the
curl it's kind of looks similar to a
function where we have something in
parentheses and then we have the curly
braces I'm going to copy this or I'm
going to cut it and then I'm going to
put it here let me get the tabs correct
okay so this is an if statement so if
something is true we haven't specified
what we want to be true at though but if
something is true then we do all these
things right here if this is not true
then all this code will be skipped this
is called a conditional so it's code
that you only want to run in a certain
circumstance in this case the
circumstance is we want to
check if the amount of gold the player
has is greater than or equal to 10. so
we just have to do gold is greater than
or equal to 10.
so if this is true if the variable is
equal to greater than or equal to 10
then we can buy Health if not all this
will be skipped and we cannot pay health
and you can also do instead of just
greater than it can just be instead of
greater than or equal to it could be
greater than it could be less than and
so there's a few different conditional
operators that you can use but we're
just using greater than or equal to so
if you want code to run only if this is
false then we can put an else statement
so an else statement just like this else
and then we put curly braces so any code
in these curly braces will run if this
is false if it's true we run this code
if it's false we run this code
so if the player doesn't have enough
money to buy Health we'll inform the
player we'll set the text I enter text
to you do not have enough gold to buy
health
just like that
okay so before we write the code for the
buy weapon function we'll use const to
create a weapons variable right above
the locations array and set it to an
empty array so I'm going to go up here
we got the locations array and then I'm
going to do const
weapons
equals empty Ray
just like in the locations array all the
elements in the weapons array will be
objects so we'll add four objects to the
weapons array each with two properties
the properties are name and Power
so the first would be should be the name
stick with power set to five then dagger
with power set to 30 claw hammer with
power of 50 and finally soared with
power of one hundred
so if you do all that it will look like
this so we can see we have all the
different weapons and just so you know
these don't all have to be on different
lines this whole thing could actually
just be one line of code but spacing
things out this way just makes it more
easily readable for humans
so let's go back down to the buy weapons
function and we'll we want to check if
gold is greater than or equal to 30.
so just like that and we're going to put
some code in this if statement if that's
true the first thing is we're going to
set goal to equal 30 less than its
current value so gold
minus equal 30.
and you can see every once in a while I
forget the semicolons and it is there
they are optional it's just usually
people just use always use semicolons or
never use semicolons so if we go back up
to the top we can see that the value of
current weapon
uh is going to correspond to an index in
the weapons array you start with the
weapon at index zero that's stick
so let's go back down to my weapon
and the player starts with a stick
but in the by weapons function we want
to add one to current weapon since the
user is buying the next weapon in the
weapons array
so we just do current
weapon
plus equals one
oh and I this was supposed to be an
equal signs that you probably heard me
say it and you probably noticed but yeah
minus equal 30.
so just how there was a shortcut when we
at first we did gold equals gold minus
30 and then we did a shortcut to do gold
minus equals 30.
since it's so common to want to
increment by one or
decrement by one so a I want to subtract
one there's a shortcut just for doing
that so whenever you want to do current
weapon plus equals one or current weapon
equals current weapon plus one here's
the shortcut just current weapon plus
plus
so doing plus plus just adds one to the
current weapon and now we'll update the
intertext property of gold text and text
text is going to equal you now have a
new weapon
so it should just look like this
now let's tell the player what weapon
they bought so in between the two lines
that we just wrote in between these two
we're going to add a new line we're
going to use let to initialize a new
variable called new weapon and set new
weapon to equal
weapons so new
let
new weapon
equals weapons so right now we're just
making it equal the entire array but now
we're going to add brackets so we can
get to an individual weapon and we're
going to set it to the current weapon so
instead of just putting a number here we
can put a variable
and this is going to be the index of a
certain weapon in the weapon array
weapons array
but we don't want just the entire weapon
we just want the name so we can use dot
notation and do a DOT name
and now let's see how we can insert
variables into a string we can do that
with the concatenation operator which is
actually just a plus symbol so we're
going to update this string to at the
end of a string add a plus and then put
the the new weapon so we want this to
say you now have a and then put the new
weapon so basically it's going to be
like this you now have a and then I will
do plus new weapon
so this is outside of the string and we
have to make sure we put the space here
so it's going to put in a space a new
weapon but we also want a period at the
end so we're going to have to
concatenate a period at the end you now
have it and then it's going to show the
new weapon
so way back at the beginning we made
this variable variable called inventory
and the inventory it starts off with
just a stick
so what we want to do is
add a add the new weapon onto the end of
the inventory because you still keep the
inventory what you already have will
still keep the stick but if you buy a
new weapon now you should have the next
weapon in your inventory and you can do
that by using dot push so we just do
inventory dot push and then we put the
new weapon in parentheses it's just like
this we'll go back down here
and then we will where is it
inventory dot push
new weapon so we've added that to the
inventory
so so far anytime that inner text was
updated the old text was completely
erased
but this time let's use the plus equal
operator instead of the equal operator
so we can add text to the the end of
text.inner text and we're going to add
the text so we're gonna still we're
gonna have this text but then the next
line we are going to add a string in
your inventory you have
and then we are going to put what we
have in our inventory
so it's basically going to look like
this text intertext plus equals and then
we're going to have a space because we
want to have space after this period and
in your inventory you have and then I
can just put inventory now this is an
array and whenever you print out an
array it's just going to put every
element in the array separated with a
comma okay now we just want an else
statement and else if it's just going to
say we're going to update the intertext
to say you do not have enough gold to
buy a weapon just like that once a
player has the best weapon they can't
buy another one so let's wrap all this
code in the by weapon function inside
another if statement so basically it'll
be a net we'll have an if statement
inside another if statement this is
called necessif statements so this outer
if statement the condition should check
if current weapon is less than three
which is the index of the last weapon so
I'm going to add this if statement here
now let me
tab everything over
and then put another curly brace here
if I move this over
now we can see everything okay so if oh
wait this has to be lined up right there
okay so if current weapon is less than
three then we'll do all that
so at some point in the future you may
want to add more weapons so instead of
checking if current weapon is
less than three like this let's check if
current weapon is less than the length
of the weapons array so we just have to
put the name of the array dot length so
just like this weapons dot length
well not quite this is not quite what we
need to do because we've now introduced
an error the current weapon variable is
the array index array indexing starts at
zero so the index of the last element in
the array is one less than the length of
the array so in this if statement let's
change weapons.link to weapons.length
minus one
and if the user can't buy a weapon we'll
update the inner text to say you already
have the most powerful weapon so here we
go else enter text sex and inner text
you already have the most powerful
weapon and once a player has the most
powerful weapon we'll give them the
ability to sell their older weapons back
so in the L statement we'll set button
2.inter text to equal sell weapon for 15
gold and we'll set button two to unclick
to the function name cell weapon
so just like that so you already have
the most powerful weapon and then the
button is going to change and then you
can if you click it it will do cell
weapon
so after the buy weapon function let's
create an empty function called cell
weapon
so first of all prey player should not
be able to sell their only weapon so
inside the cell weapon function well add
an if statement with a condition that
checks if the length of the inventory
array is greater than one
okay and then inside this statement
we'll set goal to equal 15 more than its
current value and update gold.inner text
to the new value
okay now let's set use the let keyword
to create a variable named current
weapon but we won't set it to anything
yet
and if you notice if you remember we
already have a current weapon up here
we've already have a current weapon that
we've used in this another in another
function we've used in the by weapon
function but since we've created since
the let keyword is used instead of VAR
this new version of current weapon is
scoped only to this if statement so at
the close of the if statement once the
if statement is over
then the old version of current weapon
will be used again so this will can't
come out of the if statement because we
use let if we use VAR then it would be
able to be used outside of the if
statement we're going to remove the
first
element from the inventory array
and put it into this current weapon
variable we're going to use the dot
shift method so it's going to be like
this equals
equals inventory
dot shift
okay just like that so shift is now
removing the first element from the
array and returning it into this
variable
and now we'll just set the inner text to
you sold a and then put the current
weapon
so it's just going to look like this you
sold a plus current weapon plus period
now we can use the plus equal operator
to add to the inner text and add the
string in your inventory you have and
then add the inventory variable at the
end of the string
just like that
so now let's add code so that if the
length of the inventory is not more than
one a text message appears that says
don't sell your only weapon
so we can just do that with an else
so now we'll start working on fighting
monsters let's organize The Code by
moving the fight Dragon function to the
bottom of the code near the other fight
functions so I'll just go to
fight dragon
uh cut it and then we'll just put it
here so now we have all the the monster
fighting functions all together
now below were the weapons
variable is declared so we have the
weapons here we're going to create
another array called monsters and in the
monsters we are going to set the
monsters with three different monsters
that each have a name a level and a
health this time I'll just show you
okay so see we have the monster slime at
level two Health 15 the Fang Beast level
8 Health 60 and the dragon level 20 and
health 300.
and fighting each type of monster will
be very similar so all three fighting
functions we'll call a function named go
fight so at the end of the code let's
add an empty function named go fight
let's go down here I can just copy this
function
and this will be called go fight
so inside the fight slime function
we'll set fighting to equal zero which
is the index of the slime in the
monsters array and then we'll call the
go fight function
so just like this thing equals zero go
fight
and then we'll do the same for fight B's
and fight dragons so this is going to be
one and then we're gonna we don't need
the console.log and this is going to be
two so zero one two
and now we need a new location in the
locations array
and it's going to have the same
properties as other objects in the array
we'll set name to fight the button text
is attack Dodge and run and the button
functions are attack Dodge and go down
and we'll set the text so you are
fighting a monster
so just like that
and now we have an attack and a Dodge we
need two more functions let's so let's
create those functions at the very end
here
so
we have attack
and Dodge
so in the gothight function let's update
and pass in the location of the the
fighting location so just like that
next in the go kite fight function we'll
set Monster Health to equal the health
of the current monster you can try to
figure that out first or you can just
wait for me to show you how to do it
so Monster Health equals monsters
so that'll be from the list of monsters
and then we have the index of what
monster will were fighting like say it
was two and then we're going to get the
health so it's using the combination of
bracket and Dot notation
okay let's go look back at the HTML
really quick if you remember from when
we talked about this the HTML earlier we
have this monster stats and the monster
stat has a style
of display none so it's hidden it's not
showing up but when we're fighting a
monster we want the monster stats to
show up so we're going to display
the monster stats HTML HTML element by
updating its CSS display property to
equal block
so you just basically do the
element.style that display equal block
so it should just look like this
see monster stats that style that
display and this is if if we use an
element that style this is how we can
update
CSS styles through JavaScript
now let's set the inner text property
the ma of the monster name text equal
the the name of the mods we're fighting
and the index intertext property of the
Monster Health text to equal the Monster
Health
so it should look just like this so the
name text is monsters the monster that
we're fighting the name property and
then the Monster Health we already got
that from up here
so we'll build out the attack function
now for the first line in the attack
function
let's update the text message to say
the monster attacks but use the actual
monster name of what the monster of
which monster is attacking so I'm just
gonna be like this the
monster that's how I get the name
attacks
okay now we'll use the plus equal
operator to append more text to text
that inner text We'll add the text you
attack it with your and it'll say the
weapon name
so that's going to be just like this we
have the plus equals we have the space
here so we have a space out of this
period you attack it with your and then
we use string concatenation to get the
the weapon name here
now now let's set the health equal
Health minus the monster's level
and you can get the Monsters level
um very similar to this but instead of
name it's just going to be level
so just like that now we'll set the
Monster Health to Monster Health minus
the power of the current weapon
okay so when you attack you get damaged
the monster gets damaged
and then at the end of the line We'll
add a random number between one and the
value of XP that's the experience
so so let me show you I'll just paste
that in here so you can see what that
looks like so
we're subtracting from the Monster
Health the power of the weapon plus just
some random amount based on the
experience so
math.random is going to create a random
number between 0 and 1. and then it will
multiply it by the experience points and
then math.floor will round down round
down to the nearest whole number so get
this all rounded down to the nearest
whole number and then add one so
basically that's the formula for getting
a random number between one and the
value of XP
and we'll just update the inner text of
the health and Monster Health
and then we'll check if health is less
than or equal to zero if it is we'll
call the lose function
so then remember to see if you can try
to figure out this stuff before I show
you but that's just like this if health
is less than or equal to zero
lose
so we've talked about if and else
statements an else statement can be
conditional with an else if statement so
at the end of the if statement let's add
an else if statement to check if Monster
Health is less than or equal to zero
and if it is we'll call the defeat
monster function so that just looks like
this so normally is else and then we
have a curly brace here but now doing
else if and we can put another if
statement and then defeat monster so if
this else then we'll do another if
statement we'll only go to this if
statement if this one is not true so if
we haven't lost then we'll check if the
monster has lost if the monster's health
is lower we'll call it defeat monster so
we'll just have to add those two empty
functions for defeat monster and lose
okay there we go and inside the Dodge
function let's set text to enter text to
you dodge the attack from and then put
the monster's name
so just like that you don't detect from
and then monsters then we get the mods
who are fighting the name and then the
period
and then we can update the defeat
monsters function
so inside this defeat monsters function
we're going to set gold to equal
the Monsters level times 6.7 but then we
want to round that all down to the
nearest whole number
so just like this gold plus equals and
so we're going to add this this new
amount of gold which is going to be the
level times 6.7 and then round down to
the nearest whole number
then we'll set XP to equal XP plus the
Monsters level
and now we just have to update the inner
text on the screen
and finally we'll finish this function
by calling the update function and pass
in locations four
so update
locations
four
so that's up obviously a brand new
location that we're going to have to add
to the location section because that's
actually the fifth location uh index
four and so we're going to add a new
location what we're going to have the
same properties as all the other objects
the name is kill monster the button text
is go to Town Square go to Town Square
and go to Town Square because there's
only one thing you can do after you kill
a monster and then the button functions
go down go down go down in the text the
monster screams ARG as it dies you gain
experiments and find gold
so we have all that updated for what
happens after you kill a monster
now where it says the monster screams
are here if you're saying something
there should be quotes around it so
let's add quotes around it we already
learned about escaping quotes but
there's another way you could include
quote marks is if the outer quotes are a
different type than the inner quotes So
if we want to have the inner quotes be
double quotes we can make the outer
quotes single quotes so let's do that so
now
you can see the color all looks correct
so we're using the single quotes at the
beginning of the end so we can use the
double quotes in the middle and that now
these will appear and we don't have to
escape them they'll actually appear this
text will appear as with the quotation
marks
and let's just add another location for
when you lose name lose button text is
just all three says replay question mark
button functions are just restart and
it's just going to say you die
so it's going to look just like that so
there's only three options that can
happen the buttons all say the same
thing and the button functions are all
the same so after a monster is defeated
the monster stamp box should no longer
display
so on the first line of the update
function
let's add that the monster stat style
display is none so every time it updates
it's just going to make sure that the
display box goes away the monster stats
box goes away
so it's just here and I'll just put in
there
so whenever you go to a new location the
monster stats will no longer show up
okay now let's go use the loot we have
the loose function at the bottom so
let's make it go to the correct location
update
locations
five
and now at the end we're going to make a
restart function so after you lose you
may want to restart and we just want to
set all the initial variables back to
their initial settings and then we want
to go to the town so let's go all the
way back to the bottom and create that
function so then we got restart and see
we're setting all the variables back to
how they were at the very beginning
we're making sure the inner text of all
these things on the screen are the
correct values and then we go to town
okay now let's make an update to the
attack function inside the attack
function we're going to update the
contents of the else if statement
this is which is this statement right
here so we're going to update the
contents here instead of calling the
defeat instead of calling the defeat
monster function right away we'll create
an if statement with an else statement
if the player is fighting the dragon
which is if fighting equals two then
we'll call the win game function else
we'll call the defeat monster function
so let me show you what that looks like
and we're going to talk about something
new which is this Opera so if fighting
equals 2 when game else defeat monster
so here you never just want to use a
single equal sign because a single equal
sign is an equality operator you would
either want to use the double equal sign
or the triple equal sign if if you want
to compare two things if you want to see
if one thing equals another thing as far
as comparing you're going to use double
or E triple equal sign
it so the double equal sign that double
equal operator will compare for equality
after doing any necessary type
conversions and the triple equal
operator will not do the conversions so
two values have to be the exact same
type so it's often safer to use the
triple equal sign because it's not going
to do any conversions to test the
equality
and this is the perfect time to talk
about
the ternary operator or sometimes called
the conditional operator it's basically
can be used to do a one line if else
expression I'm just going to show you is
pasting some example code which we're
going to delete so the exam here's the
example code so if age is greater than
or equal to 18 adult function else kit
function we can simplify this using the
ternary operator so basically you put
the what's in the if statement right
here and then we have a question mark
and this would be the if true and you
will put a colon and this is
else so this is going to be if true this
is the else so the key things to see
here are the question mark and the colon
so basically it's a one line if else
statement when you only need it they're
very helpful if you only need to do one
thing in the if in one thing and else
which is exactly what we have up here so
I'm going to delete this and we're going
to update this code to use a ternary
statement
so it's just going to look like
this so basically it simplifies things
quite a bit if fighting equals equals
equals two
then if it's true when game if it's
false defeat monster
okay after the lose function
we're going to create a new function
called win game and inside that function
we'll call the update function and pass
in location six
so you can see it's going to look very
similar to the Lewis function we're just
calling location six
and that's a new location so let's
create a new location
everything should basically be the same
as the lose location except the name is
going to be when and instead of saying
you die it will say you feed defeat the
dragon you win the game
just like that the replay and restart
are going to be the same
now the game
could be complete now we're going to add
a few extra features but let's test it
out so I'm going to click run up here
and we'll be able to see if we made any
mistakes already so uh monster stats
unexpected identifier so let's go to
um line 109 it looks like it's because
we forgot this curly brace or I forgot
it hopefully you got it right because
I'm probably put a little note at the
time saying that I made a mistake there
so this is why it's sometimes helpful to
test out your code more frequently so
you don't have a air a while back so
let's try it again so click run
and then we have another error here so
let's check that 144
and again it's just a missing curly
brace
and hopefully we don't get any more of
those missing curly braces
okay
and then we have a missing
semicolon so it um
217
one thing this helps you realize is that
finding errors can actually be easy just
by looking at the console and the errors
you get right in there so it looks like
we just need to have a
semicolon here
okay
and no more errors
I fix all my mistakes that hopefully you
already had fixed in your code okay so
let's test out the rest of this
application here so welcome to Dragon
repeller so we have all this information
here go to store
let's see if we can buy a weapon yep my
gold went down and now I have an extra
thing in my inventory
I can buy some health
and my gold went down my health went up
let's go down to Town Square or go to
the cave
I'll fight the Slime name slime Health
15. you are fighting a monster I am
going to attack and my health went down
my experience went up and it tells right
here what happened so go to Town Square
I'm gonna go to the cave again fight the
Slime attack and now I have more gold so
I can go to the store and buy a better
weapon now I have a claw hammer so I'm
going to go to the cave and now I can
fight the Fang Beast
and attack that a few times
I defeated it now let's just I'm not
gonna check every single thing here but
let's check what happens if I fight the
dragon and die
attack
okay my health is going down quickly I
don't have the most powerful weapon yet
you die see my health went down so if I
replay yup it starts back over you were
on the Town Square you see a sign that
says store
great everything seems to be working so
far
okay let's do a few things to make the
game even more interesting
um first of all I'm gonna
close the console here we don't need
that anymore I'm gonna bring this over
and now let's go to the attack function
so in the attack function we're going to
change
this line right here
to something that's going to be a little
more
complicated basically so instead of just
subtracting the level of the monster we
are going to
get an attack value based on the level
of the monster so I'm going to
um put in a I'm going to call a function
here actually so get monster attack
value
and then I'm going to pass into the
function the level of the monster so
we're passing in the level of the
monster to this function and this whole
function is going to return a number
that's going to be subtracted from the
health
so let's create that function so we're
going to call that function it's going
to be right here it's going to take a
level so get monster attack value it
takes in a level here
and now the attack of the monster will
be based on the monster's level and the
player's XP so in this function we'll
use let to create a variable called Hit
and we'll set it to equal to an equation
let me just show you instead of
explaining it to you first
so you can experiment with different
equations to figure out what the attack
value is going to be but in our case
we're doing we're first we're
multiplying the level of the monster
times five and then we're subtracting
well we're getting a random number times
XP and then we are uh rounding it down
so let's do a console.log we're going to
log the value of this of hit to the
console to use in debugging this is
something we talked about at the
beginning console.log so to console
.log and then pass in Hit
and now we're going to do something we
haven't done before and a function is to
return a value we already talked about
how we're going to get the return value
to pass into Health but we haven't
created a function with the returned
value yet so we're going to return we're
just going to use the return keyword
and then put hit so just like this
return
hit
okay so now when we call this function
it's going to return a value that we can
then use in this health equation up here
okay now we want to make it so a player
can potentially miss when they go to
attack they can miss so first of all
there's an extra semicolon here so extra
semicolons basically don't do anything
they're not they're not going to make
your your code fail or anything so we
want to put this whole line
in an if statement so
if and then the condition of the if
statement is going to we're actually
going to call a function to get the
result to see if this is true or false
so we're going to say
if is Monster hit is Monster hit
and we're going to check if the monsters
hit and if so then we are going to
subtract from the health
and if the monster is not hit well of an
else and we'll use the plus equal
operator to add the text you miss onto
the end of text.enter text
so it's just going to look like that
so maybe I can even put some
lines around here so we can see what
happens so if the monsters hit
we'll subtract this attack value if not
you miss
obviously we now have to create the is
Monster hit function we're going to use
the math.random function to make it so
twenty percent of the time it's a myth
and eighty percent of the time it's a
hit
so after the get monster attack value
I'll make another function the other
function and this is how we're going to
do that is Monster hit we're going to
return and then we're going to do a
conditional anytime you have a
conditional like more than less than
more than equal to or like the double
equal sign the triple equal sign it's
always going to return a true or false
so math.random if you remember I said it
gives a number between 0 and 1. so so
point two that's basically twenty
percent of time it's going to be 0.2 or
less and then eighty percent of time is
going to be above that so it's going to
return When
math if math that random is greater than
0.2 that's eight percent of time it's
going to turn true otherwise false so
21st 80 of the time there's going to be
a hit
now we want to actually the players that
hit if either math that random is
greater than 0.2 or if the player's
health is less than 20. so basically
it's always a hit if the player's health
is less than 20. so let's look at how
you can use an or in an if statement so
you can check for two conditions in an
if statement
so we actually want to return true under
two conditions
if math.random is greater than 0.2
or if the player's health is less than
20. so if the player has low Health
there's always going to be a hit
so at the end of the return statement
we're going to add the logical or
operator which is just two straight
lines and we can check if health is less
than 20.
so let me show you what I mean so this
is the two straight lines this is the or
operator so we're checking for this
or this so if either one of these is
true
then it's going to return true
we could also use the and operator if
you two to do two ampersines that would
be saying both of these have to be true
to return true and if either one is
false then it returns false but we're
going to go back to the the orb
the or operator
okay now let's add another thing so for
the attack we're going to make it so on
every attack there's a small chance that
the player's weapon breaks
so at the end of the attack function
we're going to add an if expression with
the condition math.random is greater
than or equal to 0.1
so let's go here
okay now we'll use the plus equal
operator to add
your and then it's going to say the
first item inventory array your weapon
breaks
and it's going to add that to the end of
enter.txt
and we can use inventory dot top to both
remove the last element from the array
and return the element let me show you
what I mean
so right in here
text enter text plus equals your and
we're using a string concatenation with
the plus your
and now we do inventory.pop this is both
going to remove an item remove the final
item in the array and return it so it
appears in the string here breaks so
it's not going to be in the inventory
anymore and we get to see what the item
is
and now we can next decrement the value
of current weapon
so we'll just do that with current
weapon
minus minus
but we never want the player's only
weapon to break so
so well let's use the logical and
operator which I was talking about
earlier to add a second condition to the
if Express and we just wrote If a
player's weapon a player's weapon should
only be able to break if
inventory.length does not equal one
so you can do does not equal within with
an exclamation point before the double
equal sign
so so let's see that so we're using the
the and the Ampersand ampersine for and
and then this is the does not equal so
there's two conditions both conditions
have to be true math.random has to be
less than or equal to 0.1 and also the
inventory dot length should not equal
one so for not equal you can either this
is the not equal that's equivalent to
three equal signs and this is the not
equal that's equivalent to two equal
signs it's for the most part you should
use the the one that's equivalent to the
three equal signs so we're checking for
both though it it can't just be one or
the other both have to be true for the
inventory item to break let's do a quick
test and see if we can get our our
inventory our item to break so if I just
go to k I'm just going to keep um
finding the slime
until we hopefully well actually we have
to buy first we have to buy it go to the
store I forgot where to buy the weapon
and then we can see if we can get it at
the break so go to the cave
um it we may have to do it quite a few
times to get the break
your dagger breaks it happened well you
know so what we kind of got lucky when
it gets unlucky to get it to break so so
our dagger breaks and now we only have a
knife or a stick or whatever the first
one was so so that's actually working
correctly so everything's working
basically how we want there's just one
more thing to do which is to add a mini
game Easter egg basically a hidden
feature of the game and really this is
just a reason to be able to teach you
one last part of JavaScript so at the
end We'll add another function called
Easter egg and it's going to call the
update function and passes in locations
seven
so we'll add that at the very end
Easter Egg location seven
and then we're going to have to add the
new location for the Eastern egg it's
going to have a name of Easter egg and
the button text is going to be 2 8 or go
to Town Square and the functions are
going to be pick two pick eight or go to
town
and then the text is going to be you
find a secret game pick a number above
10 numbers will be randomly chosen
between 0 and 10 if the number you
choose matches one of the random numbers
you win
so we'll just add that and you can see
that text here basically you can only
choose two or eight for for the numbers
so now we just have to add the code
that's going to randomly choose these
numbers between 0 and 10.
but first let's create the the pick 2
and pick 8 functions and each function
is going to call the pick function which
we still have to create and pass either
a 2 or an 8 into the pick function
depending on the function name
so I'll just go down and
add those functions pick two what's
going to pick two or pick a is going to
pick eight
and then the final thing is to create
the pick function
so let's create that function so
function
pick and obviously it's going to need a
guess
and then what's going to happen in this
function well first let's create a a new
variable called numbers and it's going
to be an empty array so let numbers and
it's going to equal this empty array
and we're going to push numbers onto
this array using a while loop so we're
going to talk about two different types
of Loops in this section the first is a
while loop and a while loop will keep
doing something while a condition is
true so a while a little bit it start it
starts off looking kind of like a an if
statement so we're going to do while and
there's going to be a condition we'll
fill that in a second and there's going
to be some code in between these curly
braces so the condition we want to put
in is while numbers dot length is less
than 10. so numbers dot length is less
than 10. so it's gonna it's the right
now the length is zero so while it's
less than 10 it's going to do something
so we want to push an item onto this
array so we'll do numbers dot push so
numbers dot push and then we're going to
put what item we want to put on and here
we're going to create a random number
between 1 and 11 or 1 and 10. so to
create number a land number there's a
basically a formula we've already kind
of discussed we've already discussed the
formula but we're going to do
math.random to get a random number
between 0 and 1 and we multiply it by
11. so now if we just round this down
because it's going to
it's it's going to have a decimal so
we'll do math.floor
this will give us a random number
between 1 and 10 to put onto the numbers
list
so there's definitely different ways we
could have created this list but I
wanted to demonstrate how to use a while
loop so while this condition is true
while there's less than 10 numbers we
will run this code and then after this
code pushes the tenth number onto the
list the 10th random number it will go
back to the condition again and it won't
be true anymore so we'll pop out of the
while open go to the next line of code
and the next line of code is we are
going to display using the text I enter
text we're going to set it to equal you
picked and then put what they picked
here are the random numbers
one thing I just added to the end of
this is an escape character so with this
back slash in
that's the that's the how you say new
line so if you want to add a new line
right in the string you can use the the
Escape character the backslash n and it
will will add a new line to the into the
string
and let me just add a few semicolons
here
okay now we're going to talk about a new
type of loop called a for Loop again
it's going to be set up just like the
while loop at first so we're going to
have the four that's the keyword there's
going to be parentheses and then we're
going to have the brackets or the curly
braces so we're going to run this code
in here based on what's in these
parentheses so there's going to be three
items in these parentheses each separate
with a semicolon so first we're going to
initialize a variable so first
we're going to initialize a variable
then we're going to put the condition
that we're looking for for the variable
to have before we before we're done with
the for Loop and then we are going to be
able to change the variable so let me
show you what I mean we'll do let I
equal zero
semicolon
I less than 10
semicolon
I plus plus
so let's go over this so first when this
when we go into this for loop we're
creating a new variable just for the for
Loop since we use let it's only going to
apply in this block of code and we are
going to Loop
until I is less than 10. so once I is I
is less than 10 we'll be out of the loop
and this is something that's going to
run at the end of each iteration of the
loop I plus plus that just means I
equals I plus 1. so I start at zero and
then every at the end of each iteration
of the loop it's going to go up one and
once I is
and it's actually basically it's it's
while while I y i is less than 10 it's
going to keep looping so while I is less
than 10 it's going to keep looping and
once I is no longer less than 10 the
loop will be over
we are just going to use this Loop to
add a to add all the numbers from our
list
and it will put a new line character
after each number on the list
so just like that so we'll do plus equal
numbers and so
when we do it numbers I so first it's
going to be
so I is going to be updated each time we
go through this Loop so the first time
we go through the loop I is going to
equal zero so this is going to be the
number this is the number here at index
0 which is the first number and then I
will be updated and it'll be index one
index two index three until the loop is
over with and after each number we will
put a new line
okay so now we have our final section
we're going to put an if else statement
we want to figure out if the number that
was picked is in this list
well there there's a kind of a fancy way
we can do that
so first let's create the if statement
so if
so we're going to put the condition here
we are going to find the index of the
guest number so we can do numbers dot
index
of and we can pass in the guess so in
this case it's going to either be two or
eight but we can use this function for
any for a guess of any type of number so
we're trying to find the index of it of
it we're looking for that number
in the numbers array and we're trying to
find the index so either you know the
index starts with zero one two three
four so which s part of the array which
order in the array
is that number
but if the number so this is always
going to return a number but if the
number if is not in the array if it
cannot find the index of that guess it's
going to return negative one so we can
use that so if the index of guess
does not equal negative one
that means it's in the list that means
you guessed a correct number so we're
going to do the does not equal and then
put negative 1. so in that case we are
going to set inner text to right you win
20 gold we're going to add 20 gold and
we're going to update the inner text of
the gold
just like that the plus equal right you
120 gold we're gonna add to the gold and
then update the inner text of the gold
else it's going to say wrong you lose 10
Health we're going to subtract 10 health
and we are going to set the inner text
of the health
so it's going to look
just like that let's put the other curly
brace here and anytime you subtract
Health we have to check if the player
has lost
so that's what we'll do now
see if you can figure out what code you
should add to if the player has died
that's going to be just like this if
health is less than or equal to zero
lose
okay
we are done
the only other thing we need to do is
make it so you can get into this Easter
egg
so how we're going to make it so you can
get into the Easter because we're going
to go back up to
the
locations and during the the kill
monster once you've killed the monster
it's gonna say go to Town Square go to
square go to Town Square but we're not
going to use the same functions for each
of these the final function we're going
to do Easter egg so even though it says
go to Town Square
if you know the Easter egg you're gonna
go to the Easter egg function Okay so
now there's nothing else to add so let's
just try out the Easter egg I'm going to
run
and we know that if we go to the cave
we know
okay now let's just check out oh yeah we
got
obviously there's some sort of air we
have to fix here so let's go to a line
100
and
oh when we edit when I had Easter egg I
somehow deleted that it's curly brace
okay so now
I'm going to first I'll just go to the
store by weapon now I'm gonna go to the
cave fight the Slime attack okay now I'm
going to click the third go to Town
Square oh yeah and while we're doing it
you can see in the console it's putting
uh the 10 here because if you remember
we did do a console.log uh when there
was an attack uh where was that
here where we console.log the hit so but
I'm going to click the third go to Town
Square you find the secret game pick a
number above 10 numbers will be randomly
chosen between 0 and 10 and then if you
choose them if the number you choose
matches one of the random numbers you
win so I can click eight
he picked eight here in the random
numbers uh let me just turn off this
console right you win 20 gold because 8
was in there and then if I choose the
wrong because I can play again so you
pick two right I got right that time
right again oh man I'm on a roll here
wrong you lose 10 health so I tried too
many times uh so now I can go to Town
Square
the game is complete
now that you know the basics of
JavaScript Tomy will take over again for
this next section he's going to teach
you how to create a front-end web app
with HTML CSS and JavaScript afterwards
I'll teach you how to create a back-end
web API using node.js Express and
mongodb then I'll teach you how to
connect tomi's front-end web app to the
backend web API in this section of this
course we're going to be building this
web application that you see right here
so it's going to be a very basic app and
what it's going to do is that you're
gonna be able to just allow a user to
search for any movies and it's going to
show results of those movies for example
if I search for smile
you're gonna see that I have results of
the movie smile so I'm going to show you
how to build this from scratch so we're
going to design the HTML the CSS then
once we're done with that we're going to
use JavaScript to fetch this data from
an API so let's get straight into it so
I'm just going to close this tab and
we're going to come back to replit
so now we are just going to get rid of
this whole style.css and let's just
start with our index
so I'm going to close this and what I'm
actually going to do is that I'm going
to open this on another tab
so that we can just see how the
application looks live rather than
having it like in a small frame
so that is also what you can do with
replit so now I'm going to close that
and we have all our
you know code enough with enough screen
for us to use so what we're going to do
first of all
I'm gonna actually just have all the the
HTML you know diff element everything
I'm going to use then I'm going to start
styling everything that we code in here
and after styling it then I'm going to
use JavaScript to you to fetch some data
from an API so I'm going to show you how
to do all of this if you don't know what
these are don't worry I'm going to walk
you through it
so the first thing I want to do is to
actually just
get rid of all of this
and right here I'm just going to leave
this title blank so to this point you
know that this is just a basic HTML you
know template this is how the base the
normal HTML structure should look so we
have this docketype HTML which tells us
that we are using HTML5 and then we have
the root element which is HTML and this
is where every other thing goes in and
in there we have the ADD and as I said
previously in this course in the end we
have the title and then the CSS that
we're going to be using which is this
style.css we have it linked right here
and then this body is where most of the
visible stuff or basically all of the
visible stuff of the web page is going
to be so let's get straight into this so
what I want to do now is I want to
change this title to movie
site
so once I change that to movie site
let's just come straight and the first
thing I want to create is like a very
basic nav bar right here so as you saw
in the demo I showed you there was a nav
bar that just shows movies and at this
right corner there was like a search bar
where a user could search for something
so let's start with that so the first
thing I want to do I'm going to create a
new div
element
and that development I want to give it
let's say a class
of
top nav
so I'm just going to give all of them
different attributes so I can use the
attributes to actually style them later
in the CSS
so now that I have that the next thing I
want to do is to just let's say I have
an a tag and this is just a movies site
so this movie site now is you know what
is going to be shown right here
and let me say
I'm gonna give this a class also so we
can style it so let me just say this is
active
and I'm gonna say
it should link to we don't actually want
it to link to anywhere so we're just
going to give it this value
#so it doesn't really go anywhere so
that is what we need to do for the
movies adding
now the next thing I want to do is to
actually create another div tag in here
and I'm gonna
give this gift tag a class also
so
it should also close
I'm going to close that div tag
so now that I've closed the gift tag we
just need to make sure everything is
right and structured so this is the div
that is ending here that's the 8i
and this is a div type so in here what I
want to have is basically a form
so I'm going to have a simple form right
here
I'm just gonna say form
I'm gonna create that form for us let me
just bring this here
now before we have this form let me give
this Diva its own class so we can style
every single thing if we want to and let
me say this because this form is going
to contain the search bar so let me and
this search bar is going to be part of
this div class so let me say it's like a
search container
right and then this form I want to give
it let's say a role
search
and I'm gonna give it his own ID and I'm
I'm going to use this ID later in the
JavaScript also so I need to name it
form
now you're just going to have one input
and the input it's gonna
close that input and the type
is going to be
search it's actually a type that I
search
and when I say ID let me just give it
let's see let's say query
and we can give it a name of just Q
and let's give it a placeholder
and let's just say
search
now this is what we've done to this
point let's actually come here and see
what that gives us
so if we refresh this you can see that
we just have this basic movie site and
this search bar now let's come back in
here and what I can just do is
let me change this to search
what I'm gonna do now is after this div
tie
or this div class I just want to have
another you know div element that is
gonna take care
of the whole film so you know when we
search movies in that site when we
search movies and we saw some like cards
here that shows the image of the movie
and the title that's what I want to do
right now so I'm going to have one diff
and I'm gonna have this
of a class
of row
it's gonna be a row
and I'm actually gonna have another div
in there so now this is going to take
care of the column class
so we're going to say class
equals column
so just the way we have rows because you
know that we are going to have a row and
we're going to have different columns so
we need to have that specified in the
div type and then let's create one more
div tag
and this one is going to have a class
of card because this is going to be the
one that contains the actual you know
details of that particular movie
so I want to have an image in here
and that image is let's say gonna have
a source
so for now let's leave the source as
hashtag
let's say that is hashtag but I want to
have a class and I want to name this
class thumbnail
so that's what I'm going to do to that
and what I want to do is I want to put
this in an element named Center
so once I say Center I'm going to put
that in there I'm going to show you why
I did this later when we are styling it
now we're also going to have
um let's see let's use an H3 tag to take
care of the title of the image of the
movie so let's say movie try to
right and that is basically what we need
for this part so let's have if I save
this and you just come here and eat
refresh let's see
so this is the image this is movie title
everything is all over the place for now
but don't worry about that let's
actually give you like an image so if I
open this up I put this image.jpg there
and if I click on it it just shows this
wakanda forever image so what I'm gonna
do is in here
let me just say images a jpeg
if I come here now and hit refresh so
that should show basically right there
so we're going to style this later but
let's keep going
so what we cannot do now since we have
all of this let's actually have a
padding because as you can see just
after that nav bar there is like the the
movie card is right after it so we won't
have some space in beside it so we can
just have like let's see
we can start this in the CSS but let's
take care of it right now and we can say
div right
and then what we can just do is to say
Style
let's say pattern
let's see let's see left
and we give it 16px just so it has
button from the left and automatically
I'm going to explain something right now
so this basically has a padding on the
left
so what we're gonna do now
to make sure everything is correlated so
we have that having a padding on the
left but we also want it to have like um
spacing on the top of it so what we can
just do let's actually get rid of this
and this is just going to give you some
padding on the left for you to have some
spacing on top of it that is automatic
because we already have one div
like one diff tag here so once I save
that that should be fine right now and
let's see
let's see what we've done to this point
Okay cool so this that doesn't take care
of the space in here but we're going to
take care of that in the CSS but let's
let's just move forward with no this
timing so let's go through what we just
did right here so we created a
a div class for the top knife that's for
the navbar we add all the details of the
nav bar in there and then we just added
this div tag for some spacing and right
here we have the row we have the colon
we have the card and in the card we have
the image and the H3 tie so we have all
of this done now the next thing we want
to do is to actually go into the CSS and
start styling all of this
so right now we're gonna come into the
style.css file and let's just get
straight into it so first I'm going to
use this as steric selector and I'm
going to say
the whole element in this should have a
box sizing
of Border box
yeah let's give it that
so as you know the aesthetic selector
basically affects audio elements in the
HTML file before we even get here we
must make sure that this
style.css is connected to this HTML if
not it's not going to affect it so since
we know that we've linked it right here
using this link element we can go ahead
and start you know coding right here
so let's see let's say we want to have
the body
to have a background color
I'm gonna give it this background color
so I'm going to show you the color code
it's hashtag one three one seven twenty
yeah it should look like that
now we're gonna do that and let's give
you a font family
and let's say Sans serif
let's save this and let's just see
we come here I need to refresh good so
you can see now that it's looking like
what I showed you in the beginning so we
have the background color and this is
we're going to take care of this later
but let's just keep going
so when you're using replicate you
actually don't need to save the file
before you come here and eat refresh
automatically it's like saves it for you
that's also why I like replay so since
we've taken care of the body let's just
see
so we can see that right here this is a
black but we want it to be white so it
actually shows because of the background
color and that is in uh let's see it's
an H3 tag
so we're going to come in here into our
style.css I'm going to say for H3 tag
you select that I want to give you a
color of white
so now if I hit refresh we should see
that that is white good and what we're
going to do now is to just add some
proper styling to this nav bar that we
have right here we want this to be here
we want this movie site to actually look
good let's do that so we're gonna say
let's see the class we used for that
top knife so let's just copy that
so now we're gonna say dot top nav
let's give it an overflow and let's say
that should be hidden
and we're going to give that a
background color
let's give it the same background color
as the normal background color of the
body
so again let's say
one three one
seven twenty
and we want to have a padding
of 10 PX so it's going to have a padding
on the top on the bottom on the left and
the right of 10px remember earlier in
this course I thought about you know
this button when you have just one in
CSS when you say padding and you have
just one value it uses that value for
the Left Right top and bottom
so now let's come here and
let's see what that has done so you can
see that there's some padding up here
and you can see that the space that we
talked about earlier is you know it's
not as close as it was before if we have
a pattern of like 30 this this is going
to come down a lot but let's just keep
going
so now what I'm gonna do let's see we
have
in here we have Okay cool so let's style
this movie site so this movie site is in
an a tag that's what we're gonna do
right now so we're gonna say for the top
nav
I want to select the a tag in there the
a element
and we're going to say let's see let's
floaty to left
we're going to say left
and then let's have a display of block
and let's give that a color also of
white
and we want to give it
let's align
the text to the center so we can say
test align
enter and let's give you a padding
of 14
e x and 16 PX so this is going to split
it evenly between both top right and
both left both top and bottom and left
and right so let's also have a text
decoration of none because it is a link
right it's an 8i it's going to have this
underline on it so when we say text
decoration
none
then that should take care of that we're
not going to have it's not going to look
like a link basically
and let's give you a font size
so instead of using let's instead of
using PX let's just use REM so I can say
1. let's see two REM
and let's make it uppercase this is the
title The text transform
and we can say uppercase
I think there's enough styling for this
and let's see what that does
so as you can see now it changes all of
that it doesn't look like a link
everything is uppercase test decoration
is done good
so now the next thing that we want to do
is to take care of this particular
search it's not looking good so let's
see what that is so it's under the top
nav also and it's called search
container right using this div class of
sales container
so what we're going to do is to say dot
top nav
since we're using the class and not the
actual elements we're going to say dot
search container
unless float
let's floaty to the right
the
let's save that
it refresh you can now see that that is
on the right that is good
now the next thing we want to do is to
take care of let's see let's come in
here
okay
so we're already taking care of that
particular search bar and let's just
take care of this old form in general
so what we can do since we took care of
this particular you know input but we
want to add model design to this form
because it's not looking good right now
so we're going to do that so what we're
just going to do since this is already a
form tag we can just come in here and
say
form
I want the phone to have a background
color
I want it to be different from the
normal background color so it's
noticeable
let's say
one five one
f30 yeah that's how it looks like
and then
we should have let's see a width
of 300 PX
and let's also have an eight
a 43 PX
and let's give you a border radio so
it's actually
you know circular at the edges something
like this
border radius let's see let's say 11 PX
and display let's make this display Flex
now just so that looks better and let's
align
the items
to the center
let's come here and see what that makes
good so this is what we want to see okay
so this is how that looks what I want to
do now is to you know give it more
stunning because I want this you can see
that it still has like an edge but this
has a border radius I want it to look
you know better so I'm gonna actually
style the input because this is the old
form but this input now is what I want
to style so it has an input tag let me
just copy that
and in here I'm gonna say input
let's say all should be on set
I'm going to give you a font of
let's say 15 PX and let's give it system
UI
now let's give you a different color
let's just say
normal FFF
and height
now let's wrap it around everything that
the old you know eyes that it can take
so 100 of that and the width
should also be 100 of that
let's make sure that we have a semicolon
and let's give you a padding so the
spacing around it let's give it six
pieces
and then we can say 9px let's see that
should look good
good so as you can see this looks a lot
better
now let's keep going and let's see what
we can do so now that we have that done
I think the next thing we should just
talk about is this image it's not
looking good right now so let's see what
we use to identify that image but come
in here so we gave you a class of
thumbnail you know copy that thumbnail
I'm gonna come into style.css
and I'm just gonna see since the class
I'm gonna use Dot
let me give you a height
I'm gonna say I should be 350.
and I'm gonna give it a width
I'm gonna say that with
be let's see 300
and let's give you a border radius so
it's not just like showing like this as
you can see
the Border radius of let's say 19.
let's see how that looks like
so as you can see that is smaller okay
that's good that's what we want to see
now the next thing that I want to talk
about is let me come in here and see so
what we can do now is to style this div
tag that has this colon class so what
I'm just going to do is to copy that
colon class I'm going to come in here
and I'm going to say dot colon
and let's look at what is wrong with
this now
as you can see it's in the right but we
want it to float to the left so what we
can do is to say float
left
and let's say with let's give it a width
of 25 percent
25
and let's give you a padding so it's
going to have some spacing around it
let's say 10 PX and
let's just say 10px also
so that should you know give it a little
bit of styling as it refresh and let's
see do it so that this is how it looks
like
but now what do we want to do we want
this to be in a card if we come in here
you're going to see that we have this
card class that is that belongs to a div
element so I'm going to style this card
and I'm gonna say Dot card
what I want to do now is to say
let me give the card its own a border
radius so it's going to have like a
border on its own
but I'm going to give you a Buddha
radius of like 19px
and I'm going to give you a padding also
so you're gonna see the spacing around
the card so you're gonna see what is on
top of the card basically let's say 15
X
and let's align it to the center so
anything that is with it should be
any text within it should be in the
center
and let's give it his own background
color
and let's say
#151 f30 just the one we used before
so now
I think this should be good with this
styling let's see the result and see if
we need to add anything so let me hit
refresh good so you can see now that
this is the card right it has its own
border radius this is the image it has
its own border radius and the text
within that card is centered to the
middle so this is actually what we want
to do
now that we've done all the styling that
we need what I want us to do all we're
going to do now is to just add our you
know JavaScript to it so we're gonna
be getting some results from an API so
let me just open
oh
page again so
just drag this
be able to open that
so right now what I want us to do is
that once we search this let's say we
search something like smile which is a
movie it should bring out the results of
that movie for us with you know the
image and then the title so for now this
is just a static you know
data because right now it's just the
data that we put right here in our HTML
but we want let's just close this real
quick but we want this data to be like
Dynamic like whenever we search
something
that is what you showed there so what
we're going to do to what we're going to
use to do this is an API so we're going
to use this movie DB API so what you
just need to do you don't need to read
all of this you just need to make sure
that you have an API key from this movie
DB API to move forward now for you to
have this API key you need to click you
need to come to this page right here
right and then you need to click on this
API link so once you click on this API
link is going to take you to where
you're going to create an account and
login once you do that make sure that
you click on this API link and then it's
going to take you to where you can
create an API key so I have created my
API key and this is the API key I have
right here you need this API key to move
forward in this tutorial so once you
know that you have this done we can move
forward
so the first thing that I actually want
to do before I go into my JavaScript is
that right here I want to make all of
this all these OD being inside like a
section so I'm going to have a section
element
and I'm going to put all of that in
there now this is just so that I can
group all of this into one section and
when I'm using the JavaScript you're
going to understand later when we are
coding it in JavaScript so I want to
give it an ID of let's say the ID should
be section
and I actually want to get rid of all of
this so for now I'm going to comment it
out now this might look weird for now
but I'm going to explain why I'm doing
this if you come back in here and hit
refresh we're not going to see any data
for now
but what I'm going to do is that I'm
going to use JavaScript to dynamically
automatically create all of these tags
right here I'm going to show you in a
bit
so if I open this up you're going to see
that we have the script.js so I'm just
going to drag that script.js right here
because we need that now
well before we can even use the
script.js we need to link it
from our HTML so to connect your HTML
file to this script.js file you're going
to have to use the script element
and it's going to have an A source so
we're going to give it a search and the
source will just be script
dot Js
so that is that and now when any
JavaScript you put here will be will
have an effect on this right here
so I'm going to walk you through
everything that we're going to do right
now the first thing we're going to do is
to create like six different constants
or variables so I'm gonna have const I'm
going to say API link
and for now I'm going to leave this
blank I'm going to come back to this
and I'm gonna have another constant and
I'm going to say
IMG path
so this is the image part that is going
to show that is gonna you know specify
the path or the link to the image of
every movie and I'm going to have
another constant
unless it's search API now these are the
API you know remember I said we're using
that API right so this is specifying the
link of where we can access that API
from and this is specifying you know how
are we actually going to search for
something and get some response from
that API
so now that I have all of that what I'm
going to do is to give you some values
so right here on API link I'm going to
paste in this code this link actually
and what you just need to do is to type
out what I pasted and I'm going to
explain it for you
so right here I'm going to paste this
in here so as you can see this is like
the link to that the movie DB that I
talked about but we are accessing it
through its API so just write everything
out the way it is right here with the
page and every single thing the only
thing you need to change is your API key
remember when I showed you how to create
an API key from there make sure that
this key right here is your API key so
this is my API key but make sure you
change it to yours
and for the image part I'm also going to
paste in an image link and I'm going to
show you what this is so this image part
is actually the root part to every
single image of the movies so that is
what this is and then for the search API
I'm also gonna paste in the query so
what this does is that if I paste this
it uses that the movie DB right to
search for a movie and you must change
this to your API key also that's the
only thing you need to change and this
query we are going to add our own query
to it so what I mean by that is that the
query that we use is what we're going to
add like let's say for example if a user
searches for like you know Black Adam or
something else that is what is going to
be put in this query right here so that
is where you need to know so let's get
rid of this let's make this double
quotes
right so now that we know that we have
all of that since this is Javascript you
must add you should add the semicolon at
the end of this
and now the next thing I'm going to do
is to actually get some elements in this
HTML file so I want to get this whole
section so what let me just walk you
through what I'm going to do to actually
make this work so what I'm going to do
is that I'm gonna when a user searches
for something and click enter
we're going to have a function that gets
the result of what the user search then
sends that query to this API and the API
is going to send up some response so
let's say the user searches for like
Barbie right it's going to send us let's
say 10 or 20 different responses with
the image and the name so when I get
those image and the name I'm then going
to create
a div these all of this div tag right
containing the data of that particular
image and name right here you can see
that we just have one div tag but what I
want is that depending on how many
results right that we get that is the
amount of div tag I want to have so
that's why we're going to have to create
this div tag from JavaScript so there's
a way JavaScript can create an element
for us and it's basically going to
create all of this I'm actually going to
delete all of this later but for now I'm
going to use it to reference when we are
creating all this tag in JavaScript so
let's move forward and let me explain so
what we need to do now is to get
this we're gonna get this section right
and then we're gonna we have to get the
form which is this form right here so we
can actually get the from the phone we
can get the you know the query that the
users search for so what I'm going to do
now we need this section so I'm going to
say let me name it main I'm going to say
equals to document
dot get element
by
ID
I'm getting an image section
so by getting the elements by the ID and
the ID is section right we're going to
do the same thing
for the form and search so we're going
to say form search so we want to get
this old form
right and by getting it by the ID we
need to
use the ID of form
and then for this search since we want
to get the actual query
we're going to use the ID of this input
and we're going to say query
so once we have that done the next thing
I want to do now we're going to have to
create a function named return movies so
let's just say
let's see let's say function
I'm not going to say return
movies
and we're going to give it a URL
go outside here I want to add this and
what we're just going to say is we're
going to use the fetch so we're going to
fetch from the URL
so then
in a serious
equals greater than res dot Json because
I'm going to get Json response
then we're also going to say that then
function
and now we're going to say data
right and right here we're going to open
under curly braces and let's just say
console
let's print out the data in the console
so you can just say data the result you
can use this to debug later let's just
have that right there and now what we
can just basically do is to say data
results so I'm going to come down in
here and I'm going to say
right here we actually need to have this
semicolon to show that that ends there
we're going to say the data that we get
the results
dot for each so we're basically looping
through all the elements in the result
so for each element
I'm going to say let me have it here
element
and then what we want to do is to say
I'm going to create some constants now
so I'm going to show you all of this why
I create all this constant but for now
let me just say div
equals to
document
dot create
element
so I'm creating a new div tag right in
this one HTML so as you can see when we
say create element it's creating a new
div element and we're storing that in
this constant name div so for now let's
just you know go through all of this and
what I want to do
I'm going to show you why we use all of
this later but for now let's
make this here
I'm gonna do this and what I need to do
is to add this here just to have
profit and right here we need to have
the closing
bracket let me put that there so this is
everything in this particular function
for now which is working so what I want
to do is up here I actually want to call
these return movies
the op I'm going to paste that function
so I want to you know go that function
up here and the URL that I'm going to
give it is this API link right here so
that's the link that you know we want
you to fetch from
so now I'm going to explain everything
I'm going to do now briefly
so what I want to do is I want to create
you know a div tag for all of this so
I'm going to create a div tag for the
row I'm going to create a div a div
element for the colon for the class yeah
I'm also even going to create like an
image element I'm going to create a
center element this H3 I'm going to
create everything and once I create
everything I'm going to show you how I'm
going to put this image in the center
I'm going to put this Center in this div
that has a class of card so I'm going to
show you how we can do that so what I'm
going to do right here I have div right
what I'm going to do is to say div card
because that's the first one I want to
create right here the first div card and
I'm going to say document or create
element div so you're just creating a
div that element and the next thing I
want to do
let me just actually copy this
I want to create the div row
which is also create element div and I'm
going to create the div column
and the next thing I want to create
is for the image so I'm going to create
an image element so I'm going to create
IMG
and I'm going to create the title so the
title right here which is an H3 so we
have to say title
and we're gonna create an H3 element and
I'm going to create the last one I'm
going to create is let's see I think I
need to create yeah this Center run
right here now we're creating every
single element just so it doesn't you
know affect the styling
so I'm gonna say
right here I'm just going to say Center
a create element Center
right now that should work now that I've
created all this element
what I'm going to do is that I am now
going to start inputting them into each
other so first of all
before I even input anything what I'm
going to do is to say
this title since I know that this title
right here is basically showing the
movie title right and I know that this
image I created right here is meant to
show the image of that movie then what I
can now do is to say title
dot inner HTML so using inner HTML
I'm gonna say
so we're going to have to use
this particular code the code is the one
that we use when we are you know giving
it a value in here in HTML so this code
so in there I'm going to use the dollar
sign
and I'm going to say element
DOT type 2. so this element that we you
know right here we know We're looping
through every single result and we're
giving it this element so we're saying
element dot title and whenever we get a
response from this particular API it
saves it Returns the movie name as title
right so that's why we're using element
dot title and the next thing that we are
going to do
is to say image dot so this image now we
don't when we say inner HTML it
basically says
this value so by saying this value
should be you know the title of the of
the movie but for this image we're not
giving it a value what we want to set is
the attribute which is SRC we want to
give that attribute of value
so we're going to say image dot SRC
right I'm going to say equals to now
remember this image part that we created
this shows the path to that image
so I'm going to say image but
plus now I'm going to say element
Dot poster
path
now what this does is that you remember
when we did element.2 I said that
because it Returns the movie name as
title and for poster part it Returns the
link to that image as poster part but we
need to add that particular link or that
particular one that it returns to this
so imagine it returns let's say it
returns something like you know
um six this is a slash whatever imagine
that's the poster part to that URL we
are adding it to this root URL that is
why we do so I'm just going to get rid
of that that is why we do
imagepath.element.posterpart
so now that we know that we have that we
basically already have what we need
which is the movie name and the image of
the movie
so what I want to do now is I'm going to
say this Center that we created I want
to add this image tag under the center
since it is under the center right here
to do this I'm going to say Center that
we created
dot append child now when we say append
child it allows us to add an element
under another element so now if I say
append image as a child of center that
is true here because image is actually a
child of Center
so once I do that the next thing I want
to append by coming here
is I want to append this center now to
this card and I'm going to append this
H3 also to this card so I'm going to
append the center element and the title
element so now I'm going to say
div card right here
dot append
child
and the child I want to append is the
center that should be under that
I'm going to do the same thing but this
time around I also want to append it
it tied to
now the next thing I want to append is
now this oh
card div I want to append it to this
colon div and after that I want to
append this column div to this row div
so I'm just going to do that so I'm
going to say
div colon
I want to append gift card as a child
and now I'm gonna do it for the last one
and I'm gonna say
devro
I want to append
deep colon as a child
so now as you can see it says we first
have div row which is what we have here
and under it we have colon only to have
card you can see under the row we have
column under column we have card under
card we have title and Center
look under card we have titu right and
center and under Center we have the
image as you can see right here on the
center we have the image but now all of
these I want to add it to this section
this section right here because if I
just say add right is it's just going to
add it like anyway it wants or right now
basically what I've done is I created
this div and I said we should append all
of this but I've not told you where all
of this should actually go so if I say
this div row right should go into this
section that is already in here
then what it's going to do is that it's
going to take all of this and put it in
this section so I'm just going to do is
to say
I think we already got the section using
main so this main right here I'm just
gonna say main dot append
shout and once I append devro as a child
that means all of this goes under this
so divro is not a child and that is
basically what we want
so all of this should be good
and
yeah I think all of this should be
working the next thing that we want to
do is to actually create an event
listener so this event list now is going
to be like for the form so that when the
form is submitted
you know we know when you submitting and
we get the value of that form and then
you know we call these return movies
right here
so what I can just do is to say
form dot add event
event listener
so I want to listen on submit so submit
is the one for the form so whenever the
form is submitted right
say e
and then
what we can just do is to say
let's remove all of this
and just add this and say
e dot prevent
default
so right here we're going to stop that
and then we're going to say main dot
inner
HTML
equals blank now the reason why we're
saying main dot inner HTML equals blank
is because when someone searches for
like a new query a new movie we want to
remove all the other movies that were
there and replace it with the new movie
that they search for so this allows us
to remove all the movies that we
initially there and now we want to
replace it so let's first say let's get
the search
item
go to search the value right so this is
actually the actual value that these are
input
and this search remember is what we got
from here which is the query of this
particular if you come here of this
input
so now that we're getting the value of
that search then we cannot use static
condition and say if there's actually a
search item
okay we actually get a search item then
we want to say
I want to call these return movies
and we're going to call return movies
giving it the search API
plus the search item
plus this search item that we are
passing in here
and after that we just want to clear up
that particular
input so search the value
equals clear so what this is doing is
that whenever someone searches and hit
enter we just want to show the result
and clear up what was in there you can
add that you don't need to add that it's
not that important
so we put the semicolon to end that so
as you can see all of this should be
working
now let's test it and see what we've
done to this point
if I hit refresh
now you can see that nothing shows let
me search let's say smile
and hit enter so nothing shows still now
what we need to do is right here
we need to add let's say the particular
attributes so what I'm going to do is
because in here you can see that this
div card
where's the diff card
if we come here
you can see that
for example
because this div has a card as a class
of card so we actually need to set all
these attributes for it so this div
Cloud we already know that it has a
class of card so we can now say diff
card we need to set its attribute when
we are creating it out here say that set
attribute
am I going to say class
I'm gonna say card
so this is what we need am I going to
keep doing that
but basically all of them because all of
them has one or two attributes so we're
gonna say
colon and I think
the image has two attributes and the
type two yes it has an attribute also
this Center doesn't have an attribute so
now let's check what attributes for row
and column
so row
basically has a class of row and column
as a class of column so we just let's
copy colon
to set a class of colon and for row set
a class of row so diff guard has a class
of card divro has a class of row and D
followed as a class of colon and for the
image we have two different attributes
and the attributes we have are this
class so we need this class and we
actually need an ID for this image also
so let's see for image
copy the class so let's say thumbnail
we need an ID for this image and let's
give it an ID of let's see let's say
image
let me give it an ID of image for the
title the title just has a ID
come in here so we didn't create an idea
but let's give it an ID
of title now the reason why we're giving
all of this this ID is because we
where we need to get the values of all
of this right so let's see
so we already have Thai 2 we have
Elementor title we have image so we're
already giving it these values and the
reason why we're giving it all this ID
and you know classes and all these
attributes is basically because in our
CSS when we're styling it we you know
use the attribute to style them so now
that we have all of this done let's see
if there's any changes
so if we let's say
so as you can see no result is showing
there's probably some errors in here so
let's see what that is
um you scroll down to this function
let's see okay right here we have two
different two brackets that should just
be one let's see if that make any
difference
does it refresh oh good so as you can
see we have some you know results
showing right
so let me see if I search it says smile
that doesn't change the result so
there's still some errors and this is
not the styling that we want so let's go
down and try to fix it so first of all
for this styling
okay so you see we have a certain
attribute but here we are setting the
attribute for diff card right here we
should be setting the attribute for div
row right here which is setting the
attribute for diff colon but we are
setting all the attribute for diff card
so that's where the error is coming from
so if we just try to fix that
image the set attribute
and then tie to
and that so now if we come back in here
and let's just try to refresh this page
great so as you can see the results are
showing so if I search for smile let's
see
the result doesn't change that means
there's an error somewhere
the error can't be here because this
this is not where you know
that happens
let's see form dot add event okay so
there is a
error in the spelling of listener so
there should be E before n
and right here we should have a
semicolon so after all this our app
should be working perfectly
if I come in here now let me hit refresh
let me search for smile
great so as you can see now we have
results on smile we can scroll down to
see different results as you can see
everything is basically working
perfectly gives us a bunch of results on
the movie smile let's say I search Bobby
right it gives us lots of results on the
movie Barbie so that is working very
well and this is you know the basic app
that we've built so let me go through
everything that we did the first thing
we did was to style the you know create
all the elements we need in the HTML
then we came into the CSS and styled it
and then we came into JavaScript and
showed you how to you know get results
from the API and use that and show those
results on this page so as you can see
that is working perfectly and right now
we can even get rid of this particular
you know row if we want so if I come in
here unless here hit refresh
everything is still showing and let me
explain why we even without searching we
just have some results so right here
where I run so I'm just gonna go back in
here right here where I run these return
movies URL and I just use the API link
so what this is doing is it's just
getting all the images I mean sorry all
the movies on the normal page of this
the movie DB website so without
searching for anything without filtering
filtering any such it's just giving you
like the latest movies on this site so
that's why we see we have some results
showing here but then when you search
like I said smile it then shows some
results about what we search so that is
working perfectly and everything is
running so I hope you understood
everything that we've done in this
tutorial up to this point
I'm about to show you how to create a
back-end API that can be used to create
movie reviews an API is a way for two or
more computer programs to communicate
with each other
in our case we'll use URL endpoints that
can be used to interact with the
database
this is more advanced than the beginning
JavaScript project but don't worry if
you don't understand everything at first
I recommend following Along on your own
and you'll eventually see how everything
comes together so let's create the back
end API that we'll use to create read
update and delete movie reviews
I'm on replet.com and I'm going to
create a new replant and we're going to
create a node.js replet to write
JavaScript for the back end so I'll just
do create Rebel
and now I'll just I could have created
the name when I was creating it but I
can also update the name here so we have
the default name but I can just type in
review
back end
okay
that's a good name
so one good thing about replit is that
you don't really have to do npm install
anything because when you run your code
anything that you've imported it will
automatically install for you but one
thing we're going to do we're actually
going to be using import statements from
es6 and with node.js that's not that's
not done by default so we have to go
into our package.json now if you
um if you're doing this locally you
could do the same thing once you
initialize your your project with npm
init it will create a package.json but
we're doing it automatically is created
on replit so what I'm going to do is
right after main I'm going to add type
input module
this will allow us to use import
statements which I will be talking about
more later
and I like how there's two see how
there's two spaces here everything's
indented twice well let's make that the
default it's currently not the default
so I'm going to go to indent size and go
to two Okay now I am going to open my
index.js
and we're going to create the backend
server we're going to separate our main
server code from the code that is
accessing the database and all the
routes will be in separate files now we
could do this all in one file especially
since we're doing a pretty basic app but
when you create a much larger
application you really want to have the
separation of concerns between your
different files so we're going to use
some best practices for how to separate
different parts of your code and that
will allow you to see how you can
access code from one file in another
file
and eventually we will be using index.js
but actually we're going to first create
another file called server.js so click
new file server.js and I am going to
make this a little smaller because we're
going to be focusing on the code for now
and in This Server file we're going to
create an Express server attach the
cores and express.json middleware since
we'll be sending and receiving Json and
make the server listen on Port 5000. so
let me explain a few of those things
before I start typing some code here but
we're going to be using Express which is
a lot a fast and lightweight web
framework for node.js and it makes it
easier to make HTTP endpoints that we
can use for our web server and then
we're also going to be using cores
that's the cross-origin resource sharing
which allows agx request to skip the
same origin policy and access resources
from remote hosts basically it will
prevent some errors when we're trying to
access our database from a different
host as our server
and the course package provides an
Express middleware that can be used to
enable cores with different options now
if a lot of this that doesn't make sense
don't worry about it just follow along
and a lot of things will start to make
sense as we go so I said we're going to
be using Express so I'll do import
Express
from Express so normally if you're doing
this locally you would have to do npm
you would have to go well let me just
show you how you do that locally we in
replet we have a shell and I can clear
that and I could do npm install Express
and that's how you would ins do it
locally and I could do it on replit also
but it's going to automatically install
Express when we press this play button
to run our program so we don't need to
install it manually so so it's going to
be looking for the express that's been
installed and it's going to install into
our node modules directory that's one
great thing about JavaScript is that
there's tons of
extra Frameworks and there's tons of
Frameworks and code that has already
been written and you can just import
that code and then you don't have to
write things from scratch and it makes
it it makes it much easier to write
programs in JavaScript to use code that
someone else has already written so
Express is just one of those popular
JavaScript packages or a set of
JavaScript code that we can use to make
creating our JavaScript program a lot
easier and then we're also going to
import chords like I said
and we'll do from cores and this is
something else that will be installed
automatically into a node modules
directly when we run our program like I
said that helps with the the cross
origin resource sharing if you've done
other web development you'll probably be
familiar with that and if you haven't
you're going to get familiar with it
soon and we're also going to now import
a file that we are going to create so
these first two things we're not
creating it'll just be imported but now
we're going to import a file that we're
going to create so we're going to import
the file reviews
from well that's not the name of the
file that's the name of what we're going
to export from this file and the file
URL is just API slash reviews dot route
dot JS so we are going to have our URL
routes separate from our main server
file and now we have to get access to
express
app cons app that's a variable that
we're just going to load Express into
and this is what we'll be using to
create our web server now we can do
app.use now this is how we can use
middleware middleware are just different
basically programs that Express is going
to use to change how things work so
we're going to first
do cores though we've already imported
and then we're going to app.use
express.json
so what this one is this will allow our
server to accept Json in the body of a
request so if somebody sends a get
request or post request to our server
it'll be able to to read Json so
requests are when you go to a website
that there's a get request to get the
information from the website or it can
do a post request to send information to
the reg to to the URL and now we'll be
able to send and receive Json because
we're using this middleware it just adds
some extra features to our our web
server that we're creating okay now
let's specify some of the initial routes
so the initial routes are basically the
URL that you access to get to send and
receive information so we'll do app dot
use
and then we'll pass in the basically the
URL and so it's going to be that we have
a root URL and then it's going to be
slash API slash V1 slash reviews now
this is just that we can use any URL
here but this is best practice uh when
we are creating an API it's often you
often want to specify that it's an API
and then often it's good to have
versions of the API just in case in the
future you create a new version now this
is just like a demo app so we know
there's never going to be a version two
but it's good to start learning the best
practices now and we for this URL we are
going to use the route from this file so
I'm just going to put a comma here and
then I'll put reviews okay so now we're
gonna use the routes that we we saw to
create later but this is showing that
for this URL we're using that route okay
now we're going to create just the
backup route if someone one goes to a
URL that's not included in what we
create in that route file we'll do
app.use and then if I put asterisk that
just means anything else and now instead
of loading it from a different file
we'll just put it right here and we're
putting a little a little function right
in the line here so
I'll put r a q r e s so that's the
request and result and this is something
that's just part of Express the the
information that it's requesting here
and for the res that's the response not
result the response is going to be res
dot status
and it will send the 404 ER the 404 code
and then it's going to send some Json
and it'll say
error
not
bound now we'll eventually see this this
appear in a web browser when we go to a
specific URL that's not included here
and finally we talked about how we are
going to be connecting different files
together well next we are going to
export our app as a module just like
this export default
app
so the app is this app that we created
here that we added all these things to
and this will allow us to import app in
the file that accesses the database
which will be the file will run to get
the server running
so when you want to use code between
files you're usually going to have an
export statement at the end to export
the something from that file to use to
import into a different file
so we want to separate our main server
code from the database code so here's
our our main server code so let's go
back to the
index.js this is where we're going to
start making the database code but for
the to start working with the database
we need a database now there is a way to
use a databases included in repl it has
a um where is it here the database here
but this is this is a pretty a
simplified database which probably would
be okay for our purposes but it's not
going to really work in a production
environment so I'm going to show you how
to set up mongodb as our database we're
actually going to use a different web
the mongodb atlas website to set up our
database now you can run mongodb locally
and we could even set up to run mongodb
right in our our shell here but we're
going to be using the online version of
mongodb where it just stores everything
in the cloud it actually simplifies
things and they have a free plan that we
can use okay so now I'm over on the
mongodb atlas website and you can either
create an account or sign in I'm just
going to click sign in here
now you may have to figure out some
things that when you're creating your
account for the first time it's not
going to go to this right away but at
some point either during their account
creation process or after the account
creation project process you'll be in
your projects page and you'll go to new
project it may go directly into the
create a project page when you're
creating a new account so we'll just
name the project I'm going to call this
movie reviews
okay next
and then we can just go through we'll
just use the default project owner which
is me
okay now I'm going to build a database
now we have a few different options I'm
going to go with the free option which
will definitely be good enough for our
purposes if you want to specify any of
these things here I'm just going to
leave this all default and click create
cluster so this will create a free
database here and now I can create a
username and password so I will create a
username and password here and then just
click
um create user
okay so the username and password just
so you know this is just for this
database the username you put here is
completely separate from your mongodb
username it's separate from your replit
username you can basically use anything
here it's only for the specific database
we're creating right now and then we
have to decide how we're going to
connect to it well I'm going to do Cloud
environment because we're connecting
from replit which is a cloud environment
and then we have to configure
um enable access from specific IP
addresses now since replit uses
um it doesn't always have the same IP
address it could be a variable we have
to make it accessible from any IP
address to do that we'll just do
0.0.0.0 zero and now we'll be able to
access from any IP address and I'll just
click add entry there and then we'll
keep going down and then finish and
close and now we can say go to database
I am going to uh yeah I'll click keep
that clicked so now it's creating our
database which is going to take a few
minutes to create here while this is
creating oh I guess it just already
created it did not take a few minutes if
I I'll zoom out here so you can kind of
see what this uh all this is what the
page is more likely to look like to you
so if I go to connect this is what we're
going to we're going to get some
information here to connect to our
database from replit so I'm going to go
to connect your application here and
then I'm going to make sure I'm on the
node.js it's the default here and we
have this connection string now we're
going to need this later I'm just going
to click the copy button to connect I'm
copying this connection string which is
we're going to put into a certain spot
on replit so they can connect to our
database so now let me just go back over
to wrap it
so before we start typing into anything
into our index.js let's create some
environment variables because if you
remember we just created a password and
you never want to store a password right
in your Javascript file you want to
store it in an environment variables
environment variables are things that
are not often like are not saved or
they're harder to access
any special information like passwords
or anything that could change regularly
you may want to put in an environment
variable instead of write in your code
and also with environment variables if
you're going to ever up put things on a
GitHub you never want to upload
passwords or anything onto GitHub so you
want to store that into an environment
variable that's only stored in the
environment and then you can still
access that the what that variable is
from your program but you don't actually
have to have the the hard-coded password
right in your program so in replet
there's a special way to deal with
environment variables it would be a
little slightly different if you're
working on a local machine but if you're
just doing it locally you can just kind
of look up how you would deal with
environment variables locally but on
replit we're going to go to secrets and
let me bring this out here so we're
going to create a key so the key is like
the variable name and then the value
would be the the value the value of the
variable so we're going to create one
called uh [ __ ]
username and then I will put bow so this
was just the username I created for our
database add new secret now let's do
[ __ ]
password
okay you have to promise not to tell
anybody what this password is this is
just between me and you it's a complete
secret you cannot share this password
with anybody but I use free code Camp
okay so I'll add new secret and now we
we can now access these in our code
let's just close that for now and let's
start creating this file so first so in
this file we're going to connect to the
database and start the server so first
we'll do import app from
let's see uh
server.js that was just the other file
we created server.js and we exported the
app down here and now we're importing it
so now we can use that code in this file
and we kind of have separation of
concerns between what we're trying to do
here so now we'll do import Mong [ __ ]
DB from
mongodb now this is just a JavaScript
library that when we run our code it'll
automatically be imported and then we
can use these special functions that
will create that the people who create
[ __ ] B also create this JavaScript
library to make it easier to interact
with our mongodb database from
JavaScript
and now we're going to import another
thing and some from a file that we we
still have to create so this is going to
be called reviews Dao
now and it's been could be called it's
going to be from
uh dot slash Dao slash reviews
d-a-o dot Js
now Dao here that stands for data access
object this is basically a common
pattern for writing programs that work
with databases so the data access object
pattern separates a data resources
client interface from its data access
mechanisms it adapts a specific data
resources access API to a generic client
interface and so we're following that
pattern in how we set up this this
program and that's why it's called Dao
here
okay we've imported everything we need
to import now we'll create some
variables we're first going to create a
[ __ ] client this is something that
comes right from mongodb the mongodb
JavaScript library
um that was created by mongodb to make
it easier to work with our database so
mongodb [ __ ] client so I've created a
variable called [ __ ] client that we get
from this and now you'll see how we'll
be able to use that to connect to our
database now let's get access to our
username and password that we stored in
environment variables so we'll do a
const [ __ ]
username
equals
and then we will do this is how we get
an environment variable process dot EnV
now this is actually
um
basically what you would do to access an
environment variable in a local machine
too process.env and then we will do
[ __ ]
underscore username
so remember that was the name of our our
one now I'm just going to copy this line
and then we'll do [ __ ] password
and then [ __ ]
password
so now we have access to both of our
environment variables in the in these
JavaScript variables okay now this is
the the last one this is important const
and this is uh the URI now that's what
we got here on the mongodb website where
we copy this right here this is the the
the URI is the connection string so I'm
going to go back over here and I'm going
to put it in a string I'm going to use
uh I could put this string I could use
double quotes or single quotes I'm going
to use the back tick and using a
backtick allows us to do something
special it allows us to access
JavaScript variables from inside the
string so we have the username hard
coded right in the string here but I'm
not going to use that variable here so
actually I'll just I'm going to copy
that variable and now I'm going to
um do dollar sign and then curly braces
and now I can just put that variable
here now you can see since this is a
different color it's black that's how we
know that this isn't part of the string
we're actually just inserting that
variable into the string and we can do
the same thing with the password so
where it has the angle brackets with the
word password I'll do
um curly brake brackets like that I'm
going to copy this and then just paste
it right in there so now we we're
putting our username and password right
in the string and that will allow us to
connect to our database okay well
actually we're making one more variable
which is the port we we're basically
running our server on a specific port
and the port that we're going to be
running on is going to be 8 000. so you
can the port number isn't super
important they're just different ones
that are common to use for different
things okay now we are going to connect
to our database so we'll do [ __ ] client
I meant to do [ __ ] client
dot connect
and this is just something that comes
with the the mongodb JavaScript library
and I will do a parentheses
and we'll start by passing in the URI
and now we're going to pass in some
options now these options are going to
be a JavaScript object that's why the
curly braces here which is going to be a
set of key value Pairs and these are
just options that the [ __ ] client is
built in to be able to accept we'll do a
Max pool size which is the amount of
people that can be connected to at one
time will set it at 50 and then we'll do
a w
timeout.ms and we'll set that to 2500
that's that's 2500 milliseconds or 25
seconds that's how long a connection can
be trying to connect before it time
times out and the final thing we'll do
is use new
URL parser
and set that to true
now that's added because the mongodb
node.js driver rewrote the tool that it
uses to parse mongodb connection strings
and it put the new parser behind the
flag so you basically always have to set
that to true
and so that will end
the connection so so we've connected by
passing in the URI and then the options
but after we connect we want to do a
uh dot catch so this will catch any
errors that happened when you're
connecting so whenever you're going to
access an external resource like this
database you want to deal with errors so
I'm going to do a DOT catch to catch any
errors that could happen but they may
not happen and I'm going to put in an
error Arrow function this is a special
type of JavaScript function that that
makes it easier that just simplifies
what a function looks like and you can
put it all in one line and you don't
have to name the function so this is the
ER is what we're passing into the
function and then I put an arrow just
like that with the equal sign and angle
bracket and this is the body of the
function and these curly braces so what
we'll do if there's an error we will
console dot error now console.air is
similar to console.log but it just
communicates that it's an error it will
appear right it'll be a message that
will appear in a console and it just
it's just like a special type of
console.log and we'll log
air.stack so the error that comes from
connection if that there is an error
will just log the error stack and then
we will also do process dot exit one
that just means we're gonna end this is
just like a fancy way of ending the
program we're exiting the process of the
process would be the the program that
we're running so after we as long when
there's no error then we can go to the
next part which is a then statement so
first we're going to connect then we're
going to
do something well we're going to pass in
a function into here so it's going to be
an error function and it's going to be a
special type of function in async
function
an async function is just a function
that can run asynchronously or it can
run at the same time as other things so
you don't have to wait for one thing to
end before something else happens or you
can use an async to make sure you wait
for something in before something else
happens which is what we're using it for
so we are going to get the client so the
client is what comes from We're
connecting to the database and it's
going to return a client so then it's
the the this client variable is coming
from the connection to the database and
we're making this into an arrow function
okay we're not going to actually use the
client just yet first we're just going
to start the web server so we can just
just kind of test everything out so I'm
going to do app.listen
so uh we got remember the app came from
our server up here and app.listen is how
you start the server so we are going to
listen on a specific port number and so
we pass there's two basically this is a
function here and we're passing in two
pieces of information the port and then
an uh a we're passing in a function and
we're going to use an arrow function so
if you use parentheses here that means
we're not passing any any data into the
arrow function so we're passing in
nothing to this Arrow function and
inside the body of the arrow function we
are going to just just log some
information
console.log and we will just log
um listening
um port and then just the the port
number Port
okay it's actually almost time to test
out our server but we also need to get a
route
so
um if you remember back over on our
other file our server.js we have this
reviews route so we need to create a
route before we can test out the server
now let's make it we're going to make it
as simple as possible to test out and
then we'll make it a little more
complicated so I'm going to create a new
directory now you don't have to but it
helps to keep your code uh organized and
this correctly is called API so all the
INF all the code for API will be in this
directory first we will create the
reviews
dot route.js so I can so reviews that
route.js let me
make this over a little bit here and so
to just to create our route uh we'll
first import
Express
from Express
then we will create our router Kant
router so this will when people go to
our URL this will route the request to
different different parts of your
application so express.router
it's just part of the express that helps
us make our our web server and now we
will do router.rout
and then we can pass in so slash just
means that the base the base route and
we'll do that get and then you always
anyway creating a route you always have
a the request and the result
and this is going to be a little arrow
function here and the result that send
we're going to send
this result to whoever is requesting
that route and it's just going to say
hello world
and let me close that so it can be all
in one line there and then I will just
do export default router so it can be we
import the route in our other file
okay I think it's time to test out let's
try this so when we press run it's going
to run index index.js where it's going
to get access to our database but it
we're not actually going to do anything
to our database quite yet but when we do
app.listen here after connecting to our
database it's going to run this it's
going to run our app when we have uh
we're using this route and so this is
our kind of our base URL which I'm going
to copy right there and then it's going
to put this at the end of our base base
route and then if you go to that URL
it's going to do hello world so let's
test that out I'm gonna I just press run
and so the first time you run it's going
to have to install everything so it's
doing npm install cores Express
see we imported all of these libraries
cores Express and mongodb and because
see so we're basically just waiting for
it to finish but you can see we import
Express here we import cores and let's
see we already have an error it cannot
find a module
and because what this is one we haven't
actually finished creating the the
reviews
Dao we've used ow so if we go back over
to our index.js
um let's let's just we're not using it
yet so let me just comment that out
um with you know the two slashes will
comment or what I just did you can do
command control and then press slash
it'll automatically make into a comment
you can actually do that for multiple so
if I highlight everything I do command
or control slash and then I can kind of
turn off it and on a comment so uh we're
not creating that yet so let's try
running this again
and then here
oh I somehow
didn't end up with that still being a
comment so comment that out now run it
okay so it's opening up our web view air
not found well that's coming directly
from our
server here if you go to a URL that
hasn't been specified it's going to say
air not found now let's see what happens
if we go to a URL that is specified
another thing I want to show you is that
you don't have to use this little
webview right here so this webview
actually only lets you go to the the
root URL but since I I'm going to copy
this now I'm just going to go open this
up in a new tab and you can see it's
saying uh air not found just like before
but now I'm going to get this to add to
the end here and I'm going to add that
to the end of the URL
and it says hello world so when we go to
the URL it says hello world and it's
coming right from our route the route
that we create here it's sending hello
world when we go to the we go to the
root URL and this add slash at the end
and it works so whenever you go to a URL
on a in a web browser it's almost always
doing a get request
but as you may know there's other types
of requests like post put and delete
requests which we will be using as we
continue here
okay so let's
update this so this is just a sample to
see how you can go to a specific route
and here we just put it right in that
file but we are going to put what's
returned and or what happens when you go
to that route in a different file so
right now
what happens when you go to that get
request route it shows right here but
we're going to try to separate that out
so we have our route file and then we're
going to have a control that our
controller file and we're going to
access our controller file to tell what
we're going to do when we go to the
different routes so I'm going to import
another file here so import uh reviews
controller
from
and we'll do reviews controller
.js
okay so we select so we have to create
that file but before we create the file
let's let's use it in this file so this
time I'm just going to paste in some
code here and we'll talk about it so now
we have a different type of Route so
before we just had the slash as the
route but now we have slash movie slash
ID but it has a colon here so if you
have a colon in your route here that
means this could be anything here and
this becomes a variable called ID so now
we can do movie and then put the movie
idea like like five six seven eight or
something like that and then in our in
our review controller we can get access
to whatever ID was put into the URL to
do something with that ID so this is our
this is a get request where we're trying
to get information and see we can see
where all all these we're using the
review we're calling functions in the
review use controller we're going to
create all these functions to say what
happens when we go to that route so this
is the API get reviews
function where it's going to return all
the reviews that are attached to a
specific movie and then here uh route
Slash new is when we want to create a
new review so
reviewcontroller.api.api post review
we're going to be using a see it's a
post request here and post requests are
usually used when you're creating
something new and then that we use a
different format here where now all
these routes are or these are all
different HTTP request keywords for the
same route so it's slash ID so here is
the movie ID but here it's the the
review ID it's a different type of ID
and we can get access to the ID and if
it's a get request we'll call this
function if it's a put request we'll
call this function if it's a delete
request we'll call this function
so let's create our reviews dot
controller so let me go over here and
we'll do
uh
reviews Dot controller.js and you can
kind of see what that looks like here
now close that we're in our reviews
controller
okay this time I'm just going to paste
in some code to make it a lot faster
then we'll review it now it's going to
look pretty complicated uh we uh this
it's more complicated than our last
JavaScript project but just stay with me
and I'll explain how it all works so
let's go back to the top so first we are
going to import our reviews down now
this is is is what we're going to use to
actually access the database to actually
make changes to the database and we'll
be creating that next so basically this
file is all about getting information
from the from from the the ascent to the
to the route
and sending it to the reviews down so it
we're all the controller is just getting
information from the route and then
doing something with that information
and what it's doing with that
information is sending it to the reviews
down which will actually access the
database and then it's going to get
information back from from the database
so let's let's look what we're doing
here so we are going to first we're
going to be exporting default class
reviews controller so this just means
we've had had exports on all of our
files so far so since we're exporting
the reviews controller that means we can
import it in other places and this time
we are creating a class so a class is
something
um
is a class is used in JavaScript to have
multiple functions so we're going to
create a a few different functions in
our review controller that we can then
call uh in our in our routes file so
here's the first
function here it's a static function
because uh you can call directly from
the reviews controller if it wasn't
static we would have to create an
instance of a reviews controller which
we're not going to talk about right now
in this section but since it's static we
don't have to create an instance now
since it's async we can then use a way
await to wait for things to happen and
so the name of it is API post review so
if you if we go back over to our uh our
routes file we can see
it's this one right here
reviewscontroller dot API post review so
we're creating that right here that
that's what we're creating so this
information is actually just coming
right from Express
um the main things we need to look at
are the the request information and the
response so here we're going in the
request the request is going to have a
body so a body of the request that's
going to be some Json that's that's
submitted with the the URL request HTTP
request and it's going to have some
information it's going to have the movie
ID
that we're connecting the review to it's
going to have the review the actual text
of the review and the user so the user
that's creating the review so uh and
right now we can see that we're doing a
try catch so we're going to try to do
all these things and it's going to try
to do all these things and if there's an
error it will catch the error and it
will respond so right now we're just
trying all these things and if it's
there's no error then it never does the
it never catches the error so first we
get access to these variables the movie
ID the review and the user and now this
is where we
add the review so we're creating a
variable review response and we're
awaiting the result of this which we we
have to create this so the reviews now
dot add review we're throwing in all the
different information and then we are
responding the res dot Json remember
before we respond with hello world now
we're spawning with a Json that says
static success and if we go down a lot
of these things are pretty similar so
there are some things different so now
uh here was all that wrecked up body now
we're doing rect.params if you do
rect.params then let's go back to the
route file that's where we get this
right here this is a param so a body is
actually some Json that you include but
the params you can get it right from the
the URL they're just different ways of
getting information so we got uh it's
either we're going to either get the ID
or it's just going to be an empty object
and then we are going to get the review
of passing in the ID that we want 3
review and if there is no review then we
respond with not found and then we just
return from the function but if we
haven't returned from the function then
we'll respond with the review we'll give
back Json of the review that we're
trying to get based on the ID and then
you can see that it can also log an
error and then here to update the review
well first we have to get access to the
review ID this is from rec.params but
the actual review and the user are from
the body now when we test this out
you'll see exactly how this works how
you can give data with the parameter and
how you can give data in body oh in the
body when we when we're testing this out
later
so then we're going to update the review
revamp used now.update review this is a
function we still have to create we pass
in the information the review ID of the
user and the review
and then
um if there could be an error
or their could be
um oh basically there's just two ways
there could be an error so this is one
way there could be an error this is
another way it can be an error basically
if nothing was modified so there's going
to be response here
that's coming directly from mongodb
there's going to be a response from
mongodb and if the modified count equals
zero that means nothing was changed and
then we'll just we'll create an error
throw new air this will create a new
error unable to update review so if if
there's not an error then we come down
here
um where we do the we respond with the
Json success and if there was if we did
throw an error if this error happened
then that air is going to get to this
catch block here which is going to just
respond saying what the error is okay
then the next few are pretty similar
delete review here we only need an ID
we're getting the ID parameter and then
we are awaiting
uh calling reviews now that delete
review or passing the ID and it's either
going to be successful or there's going
to be an error and then the final one
get reviews so this is slightly
different because we're getting a list
of all reviews for a specific movie and
so the ID here is not the review ID but
it's the movie ID and this we're going
to be calling the reviews.getmoviesid
and if there's no reviews then we'll say
not found or else we're going to respond
with the reviews so or there could be
another error that will then log here
okay so now let's create our final file
now we already referenced the file here
and since since we referenced it let's
let's use the file before so we put in
here but we have actually used it in our
index.js so basically the reviews now is
where we're actually interacting with
the database but we connect to the
database an index.js so we have to
somehow send the database connection to
the reviews now which we'll do
down here so right before we um start
listening we're going to basically
connect this together so await reviews
down
uh dot inject DB now this is a function
we have to create that we'll see just a
second so we're going to inject
the client
basically this is just a way to send our
database connection to the reviews now
that which then we can use to access the
database so let's actually create that
now we can see that it's slash now slash
reviews data.js so I'm going to create
that now I will create a new folder
called Dao and then I will create a new
file called
um you can see I just pasted that in
there oh
there there it goes reviews Dow dot Js
okay we're now gonna see how to actually
connect to the database we actually
haven't yet connected to mongodb yet and
this is where it all happens so again
I'm going to paste in some code and then
we're going to talk about it well first
we're going to import mongodb that's
important because we are using the
mongodb JavaScript library to access
mongodb now from mongodb we're going to
get access to object ID
basically uh we're going to be sending
and receiving uh text and integers from
our back end to our database but our our
database it can't for when we're
actually searching for a record in our
database by its ID we can't just search
by a a integer or a string we have to
actually search by a specific data type
called object ID which is diff different
than a string or integer so we're going
to convert our our string or integer
into an object ID when we send the ID to
the database so the database will be
able to correctly look up a record now
you'll see how that works in just a
minute here so first we're going to
create reviews now it says let reviews
that means we're creating a variable
called reviews that we haven't uh put
into where we've created the variable
but we have not assigned the variable to
anything but this is where we're going
to assign our basically our connection
to the database so remember we call the
index inject DB function well first of
all we can see that we're exporting this
class reviews now so we can do reviews
Dow dot injectdb because it's a static
that means we don't have to instantiate
the class before we call the function so
we are getting a connection that's the
connection that that we got in the other
file and if there's already it says if
reviews return that means if there's
already a database connection uh don't
inject don't don't do anything but if
there's not the database connection
we're going to try this so it's a try
catch block so first we're going to try
this if there's an error we do what's
next so this is specifically right from
the the mongodb
a JavaScript uh Library so we're going
to away for the database connection so
the here's the connection that we got
from the other file and then we're gonna
first get the a DB the database called
reviews and then we're going to get the
collection called reviews now uh mongodb
database
um has like the on the top level you
have your database and you can have
multiple collections in the database now
it's not it you can we could name these
anything we we want but since all this
is just reviews I just named the
database reviews and the collection
reviews but you can just change this to
be anything you want so often you may
have
um like this could be movies and then
you could have multiple collections
there could be a reviews collection you
could have the movie information
collection you could have the uh
I don't know movie posters collection so
you have a bunch of Collections and the
collection is basically what you would
think of as a database so it's like a
bunch of smaller databases within the
overarching database uh you'll see what
I mean later once we actually see what
this looks like on mongodb Atlas so
basically we're getting access to our
database okay so now the rest of the
functions here
are all
doing something with the database so we
can add review and so all these
um fun all these functions are functions
that we already called in our other file
so if we just go back over there really
quick
um
but
so for instance we have our
ad review where it just passed in the
movie ID a user and the review so we go
back here we are now going to receive
the movie ID user and review so first
we're going to create our document this
is basically our database entry and it's
going to be a JavaScript object with the
movie ID
so these are the key value key value key
value now we are now going to return
from this function what happens when we
await this to happen so reviews that's
our database insert one
insert 1 is a mongodb command and it's
how you insert a document into the
database and we're inserting review doc
uh so that's pretty simple and then we
can catch if there's an error we'll say
unable to post review I'll list the
error and it's going to return the error
okay now to get a review instead of
inserting one we are going to find one
and if you're going to find a document
in a mongodb database you have to find
it you have to say what you're going to
be searching for the document by it's
very common to search by the ID by
default there's a single every ID is
different so and these IDs are created
automatically so when we when we created
our document
the movie ID is not the ID the ID was
created automatically when we created
the document so if we know the ID we can
now search by the ID now review ID this
is coming in as a as a basically a it's
probably coming in as a string but we're
using object ID that's from here to
convert it to convert the string to an
object ID that we can then use with
Define we can find the ID that has the
object ID of the ID that we passed in if
there's an error we catch the error and
then same with update review we pass in
the review ID the user and the review
and we don't need this console.log this
is a test out thing I was doing earlier
so now we can update one so so we we
basically have insert one find One
update one and when you're updating one
it's like a combination of a find and
basically creating some then putting the
information so so we're passing in two
things so first is the object which get
says what we're searching for so we're
we're finding we're trying to find the
document with that review ID that's when
we're going to update and this is how
we're going to update it we are going to
set so you're going to have to this is
just something specific to mongodb
you're going to set
a user to be the user and set the review
to be the review
and then we can return the the response
that we get and then we have the error
and then finally delete review
so this is just getting an ID uh delete
one and this is we're searching by the
object ID
to the review ID to find what we're
going to delete and then finally get
movies by ID so this time where we have
a movie ID this isn't an object ID this
is basically just an integer that we're
passing in and where uh again we don't
need this console.log so we're going to
get a cursor so this is well basically
when you find multiple items it's going
to return a cursor and we're finding
every item that has the ID and you can
see we are having this
we're passing an ID to this parse int
function so it's going to be a string
but parse and this is from JavaScript
Parts int is a function from JavaScript
to convert a string to an integer which
we're then going to pass in to our find
command of mongodb
and we're going to get a cursor which is
basically just a list of all the
documents but it's not in then it's not
in the format that we want so we have to
convert it to an array we're going to
return cursor.to array
and then it's going to catch an error
okay let's try this out so
I am going to
bring here let's just press play here
see if we have any errors
no errors so far so what I'm going to go
do is go in to so with this here
basically with a web browser you can
only do get requests but if you remember
on a route we have a bunch of other
types of requests
we have the
um the post request put request delete
request you need something special to be
able to do those types of requests so
we're going to use a common command
called curl now a lot of computers come
with curl built in and replit does also
so we can go to the Shell and we can now
run some kernel commands
so the first thing we're going to try to
do is to create a review before though
let's go back to mongodb Atlas before we
create a review I'm going to go to
browse collection so we're going to
browse all the documents in our database
so we can see that for databases we have
zero databases zero collections so we
don't have any information we don't have
any records in our database but we're
about to change that so I'm going to go
back over here and in my console I'm
going to paste in a curl command now
there's a few different ways we could
test this API
we you cannot really do with a web
browser very easily because web browsers
are mainly dealing with get requests but
if you there's some programs such as
Postman or I think it's called insomnia
you can use to do it more of an in a
graphical way but most computers have
curl and uh or at least or many
computers have curl and repl has it
built in so I'm going to paste in this
curdle command and we can see it it's it
spans a few different lines here so we
have curl
Dash X so this is how we're going to
specify what HTTP type of request we're
doing we're doing a post request and
then we have the the URL here so this
URL is just coming from up here
and then we have the
um the slash API slash V1 slash reviews
that's our our key our um base URL and
then Slash new that's right here our
Slash new right here and we're doing a
post request and now we are going to set
the headers of their Quest so we're
going to set the headers the content
type is going to be applicationless Json
and now we're going to set the body of
the request so for the body we need to
set the the movie ID we need to set the
user and we need to set the review so
the user is me bow and the review is
just good and the movie idea is just an
integer here so you can go back we can
actually go into the file where we use
that information
um in the post review we're getting the
movie ID the review and the user and
then we're going to create a movie so
I'm just going to press return
it says success
okay there's a few different ways we can
test that it actually works but one way
is to go right back over here and now
I'm going to click refresh
you can see we it's now showing the
information in our database and we have
the movie ID 12 user bow and review good
and we have it created an object ID so
it automatically creates an object ID
like I said every ID is different well
I'm going to actually
um we're going to actually use the
object ID but first let's go back over
here so let me just clear this again and
uh we'll make it so you can see more of
the console so let's see if we can get
that document that we just created let's
create a few more documents and then
we'll try to get them so I'm going to do
a curl we'll do a same movie ID we'll do
movie ID 12 we'll do for the user we'll
do Quincy for the review uh Quincy did
not like that movie Bad movie that was
his review
okay let's add one more and this time
we'll do a different movie idea we'll do
movie ID 13.
I don't know how this changed review
wait
name
no user so movie ID 13 user this time
we'll go back to bow
um
sometimes the replica console does some
weird things
when you kind of move it back and forth
to update
um
let's see movie ID 12 user Quincy oh
yeah see
this number kind of got in there
okay
user bow
and
review
will be awesome
okay let me just see if I missed
everything anything up with how
everything was changing here I think
that's what we want
oh except I wanted a different movie ID
okay
now let's just check back and hear what
they look like so I'm refreshing in here
and we got the first one movie
the movie 12 movie 12 Bo and Quincy and
then we have another one movie 13.
awesome okay now what I'm going to do is
go back over here and now I'm going to
make a get request so let me clear that
and we'll do curl
X get and I'll show you how we can
actually just make this instead of just
pasting all and I'm going to copy that
and then I'm going to put slash
what was it slash API slash V1 slash
reviews and this is just going to be a
get request but I'm going to put the
object ID of the review at the end of
this so I'm going to go back over here
I'm going to copy this ID I'm going to
see if I can get access to this specific
URL so I'm just going to copy that
string
and put that in there and return
okay we got it look movie ID 12 user bow
and the review is good
okay now let's see if we can get the
reviews for all the reviews for movie
12. so I'm going to
clear that and I'm just gonna this is
gonna be a get request but if remember
how you do that we're going to review
slash
movie slash 12.
and now we've returned two reviews so we
have uh user Bow review good
user Quincy review bad movie so we just
returned all the reviews for movie 12
which was two different reviews okay now
let's see how we can change a review
so to change the review I'm going to do
a curl
X
put
and then I'm going to put the URL I'm
actually going to
um
I'm going to copy most of this
but we have to put the ID so I can get
the ID from right here
and now I'm going to create this header
and I'm going to set the the user to Bow
which already was but I could change the
username but I'm going to leave it the
same and then now the review is going to
be horrible so it used to be good now
it's going to be horrible okay now I'm
going to go back to where we get all the
reviews really quick
and this is something with ripple this
is not the command somehow it knew the
correct command but it didn't display
the correct Command right the it was
supposed to look like this and it I just
pressed up a few times to get back to
the command but it still was able to I
pressed up the correct amount of times
to get to that command and it did run
that command but for some reason it
didn't look like that command in the
Shell that's okay it still gave us the
correct information look Bow review is
horrible and
Quincy review is bad movie so it changed
to horrible and we can verify by just
going back going here I'm going to
refresh says good I'll click this uh
where's I thought there was oh yeah
here's the refresh button here
and now it's horrible so we've been able
to create it we've been able to create a
review edit a review look get a single
review get all the reviews for a movie
now let's just check the test the delete
one so for delete I can
well let me just clear that out so we'll
do curl
X delete
and then I'll put the the URL
which is just that
slash API slash V1
slash reviews slash and then I have to
get again I'm just going to go back and
just copy this of the one I want to
delete this object ID
and then I put the object ID at the end
and now
it should delete let's go back over
there and see if the first one says
horrible if I refresh that it shouldn't
be one that says bow horrible see it
starts at Quincy bad movie and there's
only two objects now they're used there
used to be three so it worked our entire
our API
all worked
so the next step is connecting this API
with the front end
okay the first step in connecting the
front end to the back end is to clone
the front end so this is the front end
that Tomi made and I'm just going to go
to Fork repo and I'm going to
call it HTML
front and that's gonna be my version
and now
let's let it load
okay I'm just gonna hit the play button
right here to start so we can see what
it looks like you can see um
if we spread it out we can see a little
more I can also open this in a new tab
so let me copy that okay this is what it
looks like I can do a searching search
for things and just how Tommy had it so
let's go back to the oh that's my back
end which we are going to oh while I'm
here while I'm on the back end I did
make one change to the back end which
was in the what is it the routes or the
controllers
um the movie ID well we have to parse it
as an INT because it comes it could come
in as a string or an integer and we have
to make sure it's an integer before it
gets saved to the database okay let's go
back to the front end so right now there
is no way to um to see any reviews it's
not made up for any review so what we
want to do is make it so under each
movie on here there'll be a link that
goes to the page of reviews so
um so let's make two more pages here or
two more files first I'll make a file
called movie.html which will be the page
that that's just about the movie that
has all the the the uh reviews and then
I'll make another file called movie.js
which will be the Javascript file and
let me just
um move that over here and to start off
with we're going to just go into the
index.html I'm going to copy all this
and then I'm just going to bring it
right into the movies.html and I'm going
to make some changes I'm not going to
have this sample code here but but we
are going to end up the review we're
going to load the reviews kind of like
the movie so it'll be a card for each
review but I'll take that off we don't
need this and what else are we not going
to have okay we're not going to need the
search because this is just the review
and we want to make sure that when we
click the word movie site it will go
back to the index index
.html that's the page that Tomi made and
then we want to make sure that
and so that's script.js we're going to
make it
movie.js
so we'll be linking to the other
JavaScript file
okay that looks pretty good now I'm
going to go to the script.js I'm
actually going to copy all that too
and bring over to movies.js we're going
to have some things are going to be kind
of similar uh some of the tabbing got
messed up a little here so let me
make sure we get the
tabbing how we want it so if I select
everything and if I press shift tab it
goes back one or if I do shift or if I
just do tab it goes forward one so what
we're going to do is change we don't
need these two links but we still need
an API link but now instead of using the
movie DB API link we're using the API
that we created on the back end so I'm
going to go back to my backend code and
we just need to get so this is the URL
if you're following along it could be
different depending on what your url is
if we go back here and I'll just paste
in this URL and then remember we have
the the other part of the URL which is
just uh what is it API
V1 slash
reviews
slash okay and we took off the search
and the form so we don't need that
and then we're going to delete this
because we don't have that anymore and
now we're going to make some some
additional changes here
but before we make the additional
changes let's make it so a user can
actually get to the the movie page so
I'm going to go to the script.js
remember this is for our our main root
site the the one that Tomi made and I'm
going to make some changes so we can add
a link here so what we're going to do
when it on this section right here where
we update the inner HTML of the title we
can since it's inner HTML we can just
add additional HTML it just doesn't just
have to be a title we can use we can
actually put any HTML in these backdicks
so what I'm going to do is add a link to
the review page in this HTML so first of
all I'm going to put a br which means
means a break a line break so I'll go to
the next line
and then we'll do a href uh you know
that's that's an anchor tag or a link
and we just have to put the URL so this
case is this going to be movie.html
but we're not just going to only put
movie.html we're going to put some query
parameters the we we want to pass some
information from the index.html to
movie.html and we there's a few
different ways to pass information
between pages but one of the easier ones
is just to use Query parameters in the
URL so you've probably seen this before
query you do the the movie.html and we
put a question mark to say that we're
just about to put some query parameters
which are just basically key value pairs
so first we're going to pass in the ID
the movie ID of the movie that the
person is clicking on so we want to make
sure it loads the the reviews for the
right movie based on the movie ID so
I'll do ID equals and then I have to get
the movie ID basically we can use this
exact same way that we got the title to
get the ID so I'm just going to copy
that and element.title but instead of
element.title it's going to be element
ID and then we can just put an ampersand
or an and symbol to do another query
parameter and it's going to follow the
same format of the ID but instead of
this time instead of ID it's going to be
title we're going to just pass in the
movie title and then we'll put title
and then we have to so this is a we're
still in this anchor tag or the link the
link element so I'm going to put what
the link is going to say it's going to
just say reviews
and then I'll put the closing tag just
like that
okay so now I am going to just run that
and let's just test that so far okay so
I'm going to go back to the page I'll
refresh here now we can see it says
reviews now it is kind of hard to read
with the blue like that and you could go
into and change the CSS I'm not going to
focus so much on changing the CSS and
styling but that's something that you
can do on your own if you want to make
it look a little better so if I just go
right into to this one
um it doesn't do anything because we
haven't loaded anything on the page yet
but we can see it definitely did load
the page
and we go back and see the URL bar we
can see that it's saying move.html we
have ID then we have the title and then
it um it because there's spaces to put a
space in a URL you can't just put a
space in url so it put the percent 20 to
represent the space okay let's go back
over to
our file and now we we're basically done
with our updates to the the root the
script.js and the index.html let's go
back to movie.js so I'm not going to
type in everything here sometimes I'm
going to paste some things in here and
so this is going to get information from
our URL so right here we when we do a
const URL we're making a video called
URL and we're using new URL this is a
way to basically make a URL object from
the the actual URL so this is just
something built into the browser built
into JavaScript if you do location href
it'll be a string based on the URL that
the person is at and we can create a URL
object like that and once we have a url
url object we can access different parts
of the URL specifically we're trying to
get the search params so the the the
query parameters we're getting the one
that has the key of ID and putting the
value into movie ID and then the key of
title and putting the value into movie
title so we got that we were able to
pass that information into this next
page since we have the title we're
actually going to uh put in the movie
title onto the page so we already have
access to the main element I'm just
going to copy that and paste that in and
now we're going to get access to the
title element uh if you remember we
actually don't even have a title element
so we have to create that so let's go
over to movie.html and then I am going
to just uh put in some code here reviews
for movie title now H1 if you remember
this is a dark background and right now
H1s are colored black so let me go ahead
and style that CSS and I'm just going to
in the body I'm just going to put color
White
so now all the text color is is refers
to text color so we already have the h3s
are white now we have all the text being
white which makes sense because we have
a dark background and now we don't even
need that one anymore because
everything's going to be white so let's
just see what that looks like so far uh
first of all let me just make sure
everything is correct oh before we see
what it looks like let's load the title
into that title element that we just
created so that's just gonna be like
this it's what you've already learned
about title dot intertext is going to be
title oh before you may have actually
learned about inner HTML I think that's
the inner HTML you can put basically any
any HTML inner text is just going to
focus only on changing the text it's
generally safer to use intertext because
uh you won't accidentally put some some
uh HTML that's going to just mess up
everything so if you can use intertext
but then use inner HTML if you need to
so let let's just play that or run that
basically just reload it
and then I'm going to just refresh over
here and now look we're getting reviews
for Jeepers Creepers reborn that click
movie site I can go to any of these so
how about uh black Adam reviews for
Black Adam it's kind of over onto the
side here so we could go up and change
the CSS so this kind of kind of centered
I'm going to leave that as something for
you to do on your own but you can see
whatever we click on it's going to put
the the movie title right in there let's
go to Pinocchio reviews for Pinocchio so
now let's make it so the reviews
actually show up it doesn't actually
show up as any reviews there so we're
going to change change this so it says
return movies we actually want this to
be return uh review so I just did
command or control D to select multiple
text pieces at the same time and then I
can just say return reviews and I can
change them both at the same time so
then you only have to type it once and
it types it we have multiple cursors to
type those on so we're gonna go to the
URL so but we we are going to have to
change something because if we go up
here we see the URL is this
uh which is uh Slash reviews and if you
remember from our back end here's our
backend here the route we actually want
to go to is it has slash movies slash ID
at the end so we're gonna use keep the
base URL but now I'm going to say Plus
movie slash and then Plus
now plus and then I'm going to put movie
ID which is what we got directly from
the query parameter okay now we're going
to go to this newer URL we're going to
get the data and this time uh we don't
need data.results uh different
um different apis work differently so in
the API for the movie page we did have
to do dot results but with the API we
created it just deliver it just gives
the data directly so I'm going to do
command or control D to select every
time it says data.results and just get
rid of dot results it's just going to be
data and we can keep this console.log
here to see if anything is important now
here
um there's with in programming there's
just a bunch of ways to do everything so
you already learned this method
um but I'm going to show you now another
method so we already talked about how
with DOT Interac HTML you can basically
put a lot of HTML so that's what I'm
going to do instead of creating a div
the basically the the card div the row
div the column div all like this I'm
just going to create it as HTML now
there's definitely there's there's
definitely reasons to do it either way
and it just depends on your use case so
it's really good to know both ways of
doing it so I just want to teach you a
new way that you can do it so I'm going
to this is going to be called div card
I'm going to keep this the same but I'm
actually going to delete all these
things and you'll see soon what we're
how we're going to change this
and yeah all this actually see all this
I'm going to show you a different way to
do almost all that we're not going to do
all of this because we're not going to
have the image there's not going to be
an image
um we're not going to have the
basically that's the main thing we're
not going to have we're not going to
have this the center element so I'm just
going to delete all that and we can see
that right now
okay we're only going to append that
card but first we have to update the
card so right now we've created that
element and then it gets appended here
oh and actually no we don't even need to
do that because we're just going to
append this on to main div card
so I'm just going to do div
card dot inner
HTML
and now I'm just going to put in the
actual direct HTML instead of making
everything individually like that I'm
just going to paste it in here and then
we'll go over it so you can see it's the
HTML format is very similar to before we
create the diva class row we create the
div with class column we create the div
with class card and now it's going to be
a little different because remember
we're doing reviews now not movies so
let me show you what we're going to do
here if I close that here we can see
that I'm going to add an ID that gets
the review ID the review ID is coming
directly from our API because oh
actually this needs to be changed to
review it's not element because we're
getting the data from our API and the
data is basically a an array of a lot of
different review elements but since
we're doing four each we're doing
something for each review in The
Returned data and each review is going
to have an ID it's going to have a
review property and a user property and
we saw all that when we were talking
about the back end so we're going to
create an ID for this card element based
on the review ID the main reason is
because we want to be a a basically a
unique ID that we can then refer to
later so we can get access to this
specific element later and we know that
the review ID is going to be unique so
that's why we're setting that as the ID
so now we are going to create a few
paragraphs so we have three paragraph
tags the first paragraph is going to
contain the review so strong the strong
element just makes it bold so this is
going to be bold and you can see right
here uh the the review we just put in
the review that we got from the backend
database and then we get the user that
we get from the backend database and
then now this is where it gets uh
trickier here
this part right here so there's a few
different components basically on the
screen it's just going to look like two
emojis is this going to look like a
pencil emoji and a trash can Emoji but
this is what we're doing we're creating
it as a a link but it's not going to go
anywhere that's what this um this pound
sign or hash mark means we're not going
to a specific URL because we're going to
put an on click property so when this
element is clicked which in this case is
just this pencil element it's going to
call the edit review function which we
still have to create and it's going to
pass in three Elm three pieces of
information to the edit review function
first it's going to pass in the review
ID then it's going to pass in the review
and then it's going to pass on the user
and you can see we have these single
quotes around each one because it's
going to pass in each of those pieces of
information as a string okay so then
that so then when it says when you click
on this little pencil it's going to call
the review view function passing on the
information or you can click on the
trash can where it's going to call the
delete review function only passing in
the ID
and so then it's going to append for so
that for each review it's going to put
this and it's going to then append it to
the main element okay so let's just test
it out so far
I can press that button to load it and
let's I'm just refresh and now I think I
already I already put some reviews on
this one so let's click here and see if
they show up
okay you can see we have the reviews
reviews for Jeepers Creepers reborn so I
did this off off camera basically I
added some some reviews so they would
show up right in there this is these are
loading right from the database
so if we go over to mongodb Atlas we can
actually see uh there's 15 uh reviews so
we can see some of the ones that I
previously added and you can see some of
them
um some of them don't actually look
correct oh you see it says null here
when you watch a tutorial it looks like
the person just has it all figured out
and just does it really quick actually I
went through and tried to figure
everything out before I started
recording and there were some things
that uh it took me a while to figure out
it was uh saving for a while I had
something wrong so it wouldn't save the
movie ID uh correctly it wouldn't send
it correctly and then I had it so it
would save it as a string that's why it
has the quotation marks on either side
and that's why I showed you earlier
about how I went back in to the backing
code to make it do the purse in to
switch it to an integer so if we go down
here we can see now we're at uh an
integer and you can see a lot of these
uh reviews here are the reviews we just
saw on the page so so let's go back over
to that
okay so right now we can see these
reviews and if I go here if I go to a
one that doesn't have any reviews like
here it's not going to show any reviews
there's no reviews on that one most of
the movies don't have reviews yet so if
it doesn't have a review it's just going
to basically just show like that
and right now nothing happens when I
click these buttons so it's basically
just going to have an error or if I open
up the developer tools see um whenever I
click here it's going to say edit review
is not defined or if I click here delete
review is not defined because we haven't
actually created that yet
okay speaking of creating the other
functions I'm going to create the edit
review function I'm just going to paste
this in and we'll talk about it so if
you remember when you call edit review
it brings in these three pieces of
information the review ID the review and
the user so we have to accept in our
function we have to accept the ID the
review and the user and uh you don't
need these but the console.logs for just
to make sure everything's uh working
correctly we'll just get rid of them
just so we can see only the important
information here so the first thing
we're doing is getting access to the
element so what element that is so it's
get element by ID and that's the ID
we've passed in and if you remember
that's this element this whole div here
we created with the ID which is the
review ID so we're getting access to
that whole div because we're going to
replace what's in that div and so we're
getting the review we're creating an ID
that we can reuse in a few different
place cases so we're we're creating a
new ID that we're going to put into our
elements in um when we update the HTML
so we are going to create a review ID
and a user ID the reason why we're
creating an ID by using a a word that's
always the same plus this ID that's
always different is because we want to
make unique IDs for every single element
that for basically for every single
review element that's on the page and
then we're just going to update the
inner HTML that means we're going to
switch all the inner HTML that's already
there so this is HTML that's already
there which we're now going to switch
with
all this so basically it's going to be
very similar but there's so basically
there are three paragraphs just like
before except each paragraph is taking a
few different lines but the paragraphs
are a little different now we're using
an input box so you already learned
about input boxes even on the index.html
there's an input box but this input box
we are going to have the ID of the input
box to be review input ID and now look
what we're doing we're setting the value
to be the review
so when you click the edit button the
review will just switch into an input
box that you can then edit and it's
going to start with the value that it
already was so the review is going to be
just how it was but now you can edit it
we're doing the same thing for the user
where we're uh the ID of user input ID
and then setting the value of the user
now you'll see why soon why we have to
create these IDs just like this because
we're going to have to reference those
specific elements with those specific
IDs to get the value from the input box
in order to send it over to our back end
so we have this line here
um where we're now gonna before we add
two buttons now it's just one button
it's one emoji a disk icon which is the
which just means save so once you click
this little disk icon it's going to call
the save review function it's going to
pass in three things the review input ID
the user input ID so basically these are
just the IDS of these elements and then
this ID is the review ID that's the the
review ID that gets passed in here
because we're going to if we're going to
edit the review we need to have the
review ID we need to know the ID of the
review that we're going to edit
so let's see how that looks I'm going to
run that or basically reload
and now I'm going to refresh here and
now if I click here let's see if it
works
so it actually just changed into edit
boxes now it it we can't really see that
their edit boxes mainly because of
something in the CSS so let's go back
over and make a just change to the CSS
here I'm going to go into the style.css
and I'm going to basically I'm going to
take off this all on set this unset
property basically call
causes this all the elements to inherit
any inheritable values passed down from
the parent element so that's why the the
color is not exactly what we would like
so but we don't want to inherit anything
we're just going to use the the the
normal input box color which is a white
background and if we're having a white
background we want to make sure the
foreground is black and not white so
there we go uh so I mean it's not going
to look quite as cool as how Tomy had it
but I think it'll be work for our
purposes if you want to customize the
colors even more you can so let me go
back over here and I will refresh and
there we go so we can see these text
boxes I think this is my favorite movie
ever user told me and they can click
save which that's just gonna do nothing
though is in the console it's showing
error because we have not created the
save function yet
so I think you know what we're going to
do we're going to create the save
function
okay here's the save review function
that is called right here with the input
ID the the review input value the user
input ID and the ID so first we're going
to get access to the values of those
input boxes so we do document.key
element by the review input ID dot value
so that's going to get whatever value is
here the value that the person typed in
for the review it may just be the value
that was already there so we're also
going to get the user so we just have to
get the element dot value okay now we're
going to use Fetch and so I think you've
already learned about fetch fetch is
basically a JavaScript command that
allows us to
the send HTTP request to a URL and get
information back so I guess yeah you of
course we've done that we've done fast
we've already have it up here but here
it's using it doesn't say the the method
the HTTP method because it just defaults
to a get request everything basically
defaults to get request if you don't
specify but now we're going to pass in
something else so first we're passing in
the URL
uh so just to clarify the URL is the the
root URL and you can even see it like
popping up on screen what the value of
that URL is and see how it ends with
slap reviews slash then we just put the
ID at the end this is what we created
the URL to be in our back end uh when we
are going to be
um editing a review so now we can then
the second we're we're passing in two
things first we're passing in this
then we're passing in
this so if I see if I put my mouse on
here it highlights that it also
highlights the ending uh curly brace so
this is the second
parameter that we're passing in to the
fetch function and you can see this is
an object that has a few different key
value pairs including the method we're
using put because that's how we created
our API for editing a review we are
using put and then we pass in the
headers these probably look pretty
familiar to when we were using curl to
do this earlier and then we're passing
in the body we just have to do
json.stringify this is a JavaScript
command to make a string from an object
and we're passing in this object and so
we have the user and the review so this
is the key this is the value which comes
from our variable this is the key that's
the value that comes from our variable
this should look kind of familiar to
what how we did it in curl then so when
we are doing a fetch we can do dot then
dot then means after we get the data
after we get the data then we're going
to take the result and we're going to do
result.json we're basically converting
it to Json then we're going to get the
result of that and we're going to log
the result and then finally we're going
to this location Dot reload this is just
the JavaScript command to reload the URL
we want to reload the website because
now there's the edited data and we
wanted we want to reload everything with
the new data that's been edited
okay let's see if it works so I'm going
to run that
and I'm going to manually reload with
command or control R now I will do this
one
good and horrible and test well this is
good and horrible and also amazing and
then I'll see if I can change this to a
capital B if I click save
it worked good and horrible and also
amazing
and if we go over here and refresh I'm
going to be Atlas let's see if we can
find that one good and horrible and also
amazing so we successfully
edited or updated are review
okay there's two more things we need to
be able to delete a review and create a
new review let's do the create new
review first and then finally We'll add
the ability to delete a review
now there's a bunch of different ways
that we could basically visualize the
edit the delete the the create new
review we could create a whole new
website where you create a new review
but I'm just trying to keep things
simple so see how we'd have these
different cards I'm going to make it so
the first card has the little form to
create a new review it may it's not the
prettiest way to do it but it will get
the point across and will show you how
to how to do it and then you can also
always refactor and change things later
so we already have the code for what
it's going to look like when you're
editing well creating a new review it's
going to look basically the same to
editing a review except this time it
won't start with any value in the value
here because it'll be a blank value so
what we're going to do see how we're
basically we create all the cards for
each review
before we start
adding all these review cards up here
after we create the movie title let's
create a card that will allow us to
create a new review now this is
something we could do right in the the
HTML file because it's not going to have
that much stuff specific to that we need
JavaScript for but just to keep things
simple let's do just all right in the
JavaScript
so you can see what I did here so what
we created a new element just like
before just like uh this year now we're
going to add in our HTML just like we
did down here and then we're going to
create all this HTML so like I said we
could just add this to our HTML file but
we'll just do it like this so it's it's
all together here in this in the
Javascript file but you can see we're
not using any variables in here so this
is what it looks like if we're using a
variable
since we're not using the variables
that's the way we know that we could do
it in the HTML so we have the row card
column it's going to say new review
that's something new and basically this
is all exactly the same even this is
exactly the same to the edit the only
there's only thing different is that
we're hard coding the IDS we before we
need to make sure we have different IDs
because there could be
basically an unlimited amount of reviews
and every review needs a different ID
but there's only going to be one box for
the new review so we only need to we can
hard code the new the idea of new review
new user and then when we save the
review this is where it gets different
so we're passing in the new review
that's the idea of here the new user
that's the idea of here but if you
remember down here we pass in one more
item we pass in the this ID this other
ID and then
the review ID that's the third parameter
we passed into the save review function
but now there is no review idea because
we haven't created a review yet so we're
not only going to pass in two parameters
so since we're only passing in two
parameters we're going to have to make
an update to our save review function so
there's a way because normally all these
uh all these parameters all this
information are required there will be
an error if we don't pass in three
things there will be an error but not
for long because I'm going to show you
how to make and and something optional
if we put equals and then I'm just going
to put what it equals we can put a
default value and right now it's just
going to default to an empty string so
if you specify a default value like this
then you can pass in an IDE and it will
take in that information that you passed
in but you don't have to because now if
you don't pass in an ID it will just set
it to whatever the default value is
which in this case is an empty string
well since uh what what you have to make
things think things should happen
differently whether there's an ID or not
because how you create a review is
different than how you edit a review so
the way we're going to make it different
uh for accruing a new review or editing
review is with an if statement so if and
then we're just going to do if ID and
then I'll put the curly braces here so
if ID basically just means if it exists
this will evaluate to false an empty
string evaluates to false but if there
if something was passed in then it will
evaluate to true if it evaluates a true
we want to do all this so let's cut that
and I'll just paste it right into our if
statement and let me do some tabbing so
we can see that it's in this block of
code so here's our if statement but now
we will add an else so else
if there is no ID that was passed into
this function that means we're creating
a new review so let me just paste in the
code here
and it's going to look very similar to
our edit so for edit we have the root
URL then we have the ID at the end but
for creating a new a new review we're
going to have our root URL and it's
going to be just Slash new at the end
which you may remember from creating the
API and instead of a put method put HTML
method we're using a post method and
then the only other thing that's
different is now here we pass in the
user and the review now we're passing in
the user the review and the movie ID
because we need to know what movie ID
are we creating the review for if it's a
brand new review and then this is all
about the same as before so then we
convert it to Json then we log out the
results and then we do location Dot
reload
okay let's try this I'll load this
and now I'm going to refresh and now we
can see a new review here so I can say
um
this movie put me to sleep and then we
can put as the user Quincy
and if I hit save let's see if it works
and it shows up at the end of our list
of reviews so that works and let's see
if we can edit that new review
this movie
kept me awake
and then we'll save that
and it saves correctly
so we can even go and add a review we
can go to a whole new movie
I'll put
better than the original
by
0.5
percent
okay
uh
there we go and now we have a review for
the the new movie so some are not going
to have a review
some are going to have review but we
still can't delete a review so let's go
and make it so we can delete a review
this is actually going to be one of the
easiest Parts because the function to
delete review is not that long
I'm just going to paste that and it just
looks like that so we already have it so
you can call the delete review function
and it passes in the ID so we just go to
the URL slash ID and then we use the
delete method we don't have to put in
any other information we just have to
call the delete method and then
everything else is basically the same so
let me go here
foreign
here so let me try to delete one how
about this uh I'll hit the delete
because we don't want that anyways this
is supposed to be movie not move okay so
that's a bad review let's just delete
that it's gone
the the review is gone so we can even
even search for review let's go to um
hackers and we have one review here uh
before we try to leave let's try let's
create a new review
don't hack
and then it appears don't hack which
obviously is not in the spirit of this
movie it's called hacker so we're
definitely deleting this review
okay it deletes the review we did it we
created the that we connected the front
end of our website to our back end and
it can save update read delete all the
crud operations and it does it with our
mongodb database we've reached the end
of the course thank you all for watching
and good luck creating your own full
stack websites